Das war doch mal ein Anfang, oder? Dennis, jetzt konntest du noch mal so richtig schön in deinen Zen-Zustand hineingeben. Ich hab das alles nur für dich getan.
Was? Was?
Sprachlos.
Dennis ist sprachlos. Das ist alles, was ich wollte. Dann kann ich ja jetzt endlich von Podcast anfangen. Ausgabe Nummer 52 mit leicht verbesserten technischer Grundausstattung. Jetzt würde ich sagen, ungefähr 23% mehr Mobile Max als sonst. Ja, einfach so jetzt vom Gefühl her. Wie? Naja, so mit Features und so. Du weißt doch.
Dabei sind wir heute mit 25% weniger am Start.
Mit 25% weniger was?
Weniger Max.
Das stimmt.
Mit ohne Max.
Wo bin ich eigentlich? Bin immer noch links?
Du bist, was für eine Frage. Ihr habt euch ja umgesetzt, ne? Naja, derzeit sind wir alle gerade, aber in dem Abmischen kann ich dich hintun, wo du möchtest.
Links, wie immer.
Ja, aber ich hab diesen Resonator ausgeschaltet, der war nicht gut, aber HAL, denke ich, kommt ganz gut.
HAL hat mir auch ganz gut gefallen, ja. Super, Jungs, macht noch mehr HAL drauf.
Ja, aber jetzt nicht übertreiben, weil das ist ja die Steve-Taste, ne? Immer wenn wir was von Steve wollen, HAL. Das ist die Steve-Taste, genau so. Ja, ansonsten, wir haben auch Themen. Wir haben auch Themen. Und wir fangen an mit...
Fail Center.
Was?
Das war doch gerade der Fail Center Ton.
Ja, okay, meinetwegen fangen wir damit an. Ach ja, stimmt.
Das hat sich schon voll in das Hirn gebrannt.
Ja, was interessant ist, weißt du, wo nämlich dieser Ton herkommt?
Aus dem Robin Hood Film, wenn der König kommt.
Also es kann gut sein, ja, also ich... Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wo der Ton herkommt. Ich hatte nur gerade so eine Assoziation. Doch, warte mal, also diesen Ton gab es schon mal auf dem Mac.
Und zwar...
Bei dem Mailkleint. C64 hatte keine Töne.
Nicht im OS. Also irgendein Programm.
Doch, da gab es auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung wie auch immer. Ich hatte gerade so eine Flipper-Assoziation. Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher. Doch, es gab mal auf dem Mac 9, gab es mal so ein... Flipper meinst du? Wie hieß denn noch mal dieser coole Flipper unter Mac OS?
Crystal, Caliburn.
Ja, der war cool. War das der erste, der cool war? Ja, doch.
Ich glaube, der hatte diesen Sound drin. Die Flipper von der Bude, wie hießen die mit Wings? Nee, die waren damals die Coolsten auf jeden Fall. Crystal, die gibt es übrigens noch. Kann man sich immer noch runterladen und laufen auch auf OS X so in den Carbon Classic.
Ach echt, von Crystal Caliburn eine Carbon-Version?
Ja, also letztens konnte ich das irgendwie noch spielen. Also Little Wing, genau, Little Wing Pinball waren die Herrschaften, die damals die tollsten Flipper auf dem Mac und meiner Meinung nach auch überall.
Ja, der hat total gerockt. Das rockt auch, erzieht mich auch mehr als diese iPad-Flipper. Die sind zwar nicht schlecht, aber irgendwie irgendwas fehlt. Ich weiß nicht genau, was.
Ich finde ja diese Flipper, die sowieso so 3D-Action machen, also die zu viel 3D machen.
Zu viel 3D, hinter der Kugel her und so weiter.
Der war halt so schön 2D, schön Bitmap-Grafics und so, aber haben sich Mühe gegeben. War so ritterlich angehaucht. Da gibt es auch irgendwo...
Ja, hast du ja gehört.
Also ich kann mich, ich habe zu viel Crystal-Caliburn gespielt. Ich auch. Hier, so sieht er aus. Und den kannst du immer noch auf dem OSX spielen, also zumindest... Bestimmt von einem Jahr habe ich das das letzte Mal gespielt und da gab es ja immerhin dann auch schon...
Da war ja gleich so ein Pro-Tipp hier am Anfang. Von den alten Hasen hier.
Ja, die schon auf Mac OS 7.5 damals gezockt haben. Ja, weil... Eine schmerzliche Erfahrung.
Er hat mir ja neulich festgestellt, ihr seid ja alle irgendwie zum Weg gekommen in seiner schlimmsten Phase.
Ja, aber es war immer noch besser als Windows zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Das fand ich bemerkenswert, dass der Mac in seiner schlimmsten Phase immer noch besser war als Windows.
Also ich mein, da war gerade, da hatten, also als ich meinen Mac bekomme, da hatten meine Freunde alle noch 3.11 oder C64 und so weiter und da war Mac schon echt irgendwie cool, weil ein Kumpel von mir, der hatte auch eine AV-Karte drin und dann haben wir so als kleine Kiddies uns vor den Mac gesetzt und mit seiner komischen Videokamera halt irgendwie, weiß schon, Kinder-News-Nachrichten aufgenommen und am Mac geschnitten und so ein Kram. Das kannst du auch mit Hall singen.
Das spielen wir nächstes Mal zum Einstieg. Das ist auch gut. Ja, Fail-Center, Dennis.
Ja, Fail-Center. Also, haben wir das? War das jetzt vorhin schon drauf auf der Sendung, was der Huckel gesagt hat? Nee, das ist alles nicht offiziell. Also wir wollen, weil wir die vollen Gamer sind.
Mission 500.
Mission 500, genau. Wir sind auch schon, die Hälfte haben wir schon durchschritten. Wir wollen 500 Friends bei Game Center haben, ich und Huckel.
Ich bin nicht so scharf drauf, aber ich hab mehr als ihr.
Weißt du noch, als hier das iPhone rauskam, und dann gab es doch diese Stoppuhr. Dann hat doch einer hier irgendwie bis 1000 Stunden zählen lassen, und dann gab es auch so einen Overflow, und dann ist da diese Stoppuhr irgendwie außer Rand und Band gelaufen. Und jetzt ist unsere Vermutung sozusagen, dass wenn wir 500 Friends haben, was ja das offizielle Limit ist, dass dann auch Game Center irgendwie implodiert oder uns mindestens...
Wir haben sonst iPod kriegen. Jedenfalls, Jungs, also schon jetzt auch die Live-Hörer, klickt, was das Zeug hält, weil es noch reichlich Platz ist. Also ihr könnt noch uns als Freunde kriegen.
Na komm jetzt, sag schon, wie der heißt.
Ach so, das brauchen die auch. Sonst kommt keiner. Ja, Dennis2342.
Und ich H-U-K-L.
Aber wenn ihr in eurer Friend-Liste bei... Wie heißt noch das gleiche Flugzeugspiel? Bei Flight Control ganz oben stehen wollt, dann dürft ihr Dennis natürlich nicht nehmen. Was hast du da jetzt?
Bei dem fünften Airfield, der Windy heißt, den ich auch voll toll finde, weil der ist eigentlich am leichtesten. Oh, jetzt kommen sie schon alle rein, ich muss erst mal klicken hier. Da habe ich 998 gemacht letztens.
998? Ich sage, wer bietet mehr?
Aber ich muss dazu sagen, auch wenn ich eigentlich ganz gut Punkt habe, ich bin bei meinen hier 280 Friends bei keinem einzigen Airfield auf dem ersten oder zweiten Platz.
Ach, was sind denn da die tollsten Werte?
22.000?
Nee, das sind ja nicht in unserer Friendslist, aber unsere Friendslist sind welche, die haben 2.500. Einer hat 2.342. Da bin ich jetzt nicht so sicher, ob er geschummelt hat.
Der hat da bestimmt einfach aufgehört.
Ja, das kann ja wohl nie sein.
Ja, aber da hört man auch nicht auf.
War ehrlich.
Weil Leute, die ein iPhone haben, was hier jailbroken ist, weil die können ja schon schummeln, die können nämlich immer Pause machen, abspeichern, das File irgendwie retten, weiterspielen und wenn sie... Jetzt hab ich den Verrat, nichts geht. Das schneiden wir raus.
Also bei Flight Control, wobei ich sagen muss, ich hab... Mein bestes Ergebnis hab ich nicht hier drinnen bisher.
Prom hat ein iPhone, muss ein anderer Prom sein.
Es gibt wohl auch noch andere Proms.
Das war der Schweinerei. Also Prom, du bist nicht der einzige Prom.
Wie können wir sammeln lassen und nachher abklicken?
Ich bin auf Platz 176. Und auf Platz 249.241 insgesamt.
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, Flight Control ist nicht so mein Spiel. Ich wünschte mir, Doodle Jump würde endlich mal Game Center Integration machen. Da würde ich mich nochmal angespornt fühlen. Oder ich spiele auch sehr gerne das Tetris, auch wenn das von EA Games jetzt ja da rausgebracht ist. Aber dieses Tetris finde ich trotzdem ganz gut. Und auch die haben noch keine Game Center Integration. Also es machen irgendwie extrem wenig. Das finde ich erstaunlich, weil sonst sind ja eigentlich immer alle bei so einem Feature sofort dabei. Hier irgendwie jetzt Retina-Display optimiert, jetzt Game Center optimiert, aber...
Na gut, viele sind ja schon in einem Netzwerk oder haben ihr eigenes.
Ja, aber...
Aber Game Center, ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Nur, dass da heißt, bei den Leaderboards immer nur bei dem ersten Leaderboard hier die Daten anzeigen, hier bei Flight Control, beim Original Leaderboard, bei den anderen vier Leaderboards, so Beach Carrier, Outback und Wendy, da steht einfach gar nichts. Also noch ist Game Center schon so ein bisschen ein Fail-Center.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn jetzt hier, wie wir schon über 300 Freunde haben, dann kannst du halt auch keinen mehr so richtig finden. Also es gibt keine Sucheoptionen. Die sind halt auch nicht alphabetisch sortiert, also ich finde ja den größten Fail.
Und ich hätte gerne Gruppen. Weil es müsste jetzt eigentlich hier eine Mobile-Max-Gruppe sein und ich hätte gerne noch so eine Club-Gruppe oder eine Closed-Friends-Gruppe damit, weil die haben mehr Punkte als ich, das geht nicht.
Wir wollen den Game Center Friends.
Übertreib sie mit der Tasse, wir reden nachher noch über MechOS Zen. Genau, MechOS Zen.
Müssen wir noch irgendwas zu Game Center sagen?
Also Dennis2342, Huckel und Bad Prid.
Genau, und wir wollen 500. Und jetzt, diesmal wirklich, weil wir annoncen das jetzt schon seit zwei Folgen, oder?
Na ja, sagen wir mal, das ist überheblich. Das dauert auch.
Ja, zu lange.
Die Leute müssen extra noch in den Laden gehen, sich ein iPhone kaufen. Ich dachte, unser Podcast kann man nur auf diesen...
Oh, der mit den 2342 Punkten ist auch im V-Chat hier.
Im V-Chat?
Hab ich V-Chat gesagt? Hab ich nicht gesagt.
Dennis wird dann mal kurz geteert und gefedert, dann können wir ja schon mal aufs nächste Thema gehen, oder? Wo wir nämlich gerade bei iPhone eins kriegen sind. Sieht ja nun ganz so aus, als ob das alles die Gerüchteküche gestimmt hat und die Telekom tatsächlich ihr exklusiven Vertriebsrecht für Deutschland einbüßt und jetzt nach drei langen Jahren auch andere Provider an den Zug kommen. Und der Witz ist ja, Mobamex ist ja mal als Blog von O2 gegründet worden. Die haben das ja mal losgetreten. Also irgendein Marketing-Fuzzi, der so ein bisschen Bezug zum Internet hatte, der hat ihm das mal erfolgreich irgendwie auf den Tisch gelegt, hat gesagt, hier, kümmert euch doch mal ein bisschen, um eure Beziehungen zu meckläuten. Wenn wir uns mal so zurückerinnern, 5 Jahre, so Mobilfunkunternehmen, McIntosh, Mobilfunkunternehmen, McIntosh und so, da kann einem schnell schlecht werden. Insofern wirklich eine verdammt gute Idee. Und dann hat sich ja hier so langsam dieser Podcast da rausgeschält. Und jetzt, nach dieser langen Zeit, sind sie wieder im Rennen.
Da fiel mir auch eigentlich echt nur ein Hell-Froze-Over. Also es ist wirklich so... Man hätte es nicht geglaubt.
Doch, ich hab damit gerechnet nach 3 Jahren. Das ging schon lange rum.
Ja, aber ich hätte auch die Telekom irgendwie so eingeschätzt, dass sie auch Apple noch tiefer in den Hintern gekrochen wären, um das iPhone exklusiv zu behalten. Hätte ich mir auch vorstellen können.
Naja, aber ich glaube, dass Apples Interesse jetzt nicht mehr das Interesse ist, was vor 3 Jahren noch galt. Vor 3 Jahren brauchten sie einen starken Partner, der ein starkes Vertriebsnetz hat und der vor allem ein gutes, ausgebautes 3G-Netz hat. Oder beziehungsweise erstmal ein gut ausgebautes GSM-Netz mit Edge hat. Das hatte nur die Telekom damals. Gab sonst gar nix. Und jetzt halt auch 3G. Und da ist jetzt mittlerweile Vodafone und eigentlich auch O2 durchaus annehmbar. Also O2 auf jeden Fall in urbanen Bereichen. Da nimmt sich das jetzt nicht so viel. Nicht, dass ich jetzt permanent den Vergleich hätte, aber abgesehen von diesem Studio hier, ist der Empfang eigentlich überall gut. Und naja, gut. Das Lustige ist, deswegen erwähne ich das jetzt überhaupt auch mit O2, dass sie halt die einzigen sind, die wohl ohne Netlock anbieten wollen. Also Telekom und Vodafone sind wohl tatsächlich der Meinung, sie könnten iPhones verkaufen, die auf ihr Netz gelockt sind. Wenn es einen Provider gibt, der das nicht will.
Kommt ja auf den Preis an, wenn die da ordentlich noch wieder das Telefon sponsern.
Das kann O2 ja auch tun.
Ja, vielleicht haben die aber dadurch einen billigeren Preis, oder keine Ahnung.
Einen billigeren Preis können O2 auch machen. Die Frage ist halt nur, ist das Telefon gelockt oder nicht? Aber ich meine mal ehrlich, wer zu O2 geht und sagt, ich will ein iPhone und ich hätte es gerne für 200 Euro, wie ich es bei der Telekom kriege, oder 100 Euro und dafür unterschreibe ich einen 2-Jahres-Vertrag. Das ist die gleiche Nummer, wie das schon immer war.
Jetzt kann man sich alles durchrechnen. Das ist halt nur kompliziert und viele Leute haben darauf einfach keinen Bock und greifen einfach zu und zahlen halt ein bisschen mehr. Haben sie Pech gehabt.
Ja, die meisten Leute greifen eher zu einem niedrigeren Preis, den sie quasi zur Vertragsunterzeichnung zahlen müssen. Nur deswegen funktioniert das ganze Jahr. Wenn die Leute wirklich die Total-Cost-of-Ownership berechnen würden, über zwei Jahre, dann würden sie vielleicht eh zu anderen Ergebnissen kommen. Aber so funktioniert der Mensch an der Stelle offensichtlich nicht.
Ich bin da voll pingelig. Ich hab ja noch einen O2-Selekt-Vertrag gehabt. Wir werden nicht mehr von denen gesponsert. Ich kann das wohl ablösten, oder? Und die haben immer angerufen, und haben mich immer vollquatsch, ob ich nicht irgendwie einen anderen Vertrag will. Und ich hab denen erzählt, ja, aber ich hab ja hier ab 100 SMS, dann kostet die nur 1 Cent, und ich hab hier Sekundenabrechnungen und so. Und hab denen alles erzählt, was bei mir cooler ist, als das, was sie mir anderen wollen. Dann haben die gesagt, ja, schönen Tag noch, und haben aufgelegt, freiwillig. Und seit einem Jahr haben die nicht mehr angerufen. Dann dachte ich mir, irgendwas ist doch da voll. Wenn die nicht mehr anrufen, das kann doch nur sein, dass der Vertrag, den ich jetzt hab, so beschissen ist, dass sie mir gar keinen anderen geben wollen, weil sie verdienen schon genug damit. Also hab ich jetzt gewechselt nach O2O. Und zahle jetzt gar nichts mehr im Monat. Hab aber jetzt Minutenabrechnung, aber ist egal, wenn man nichts mehr zahlt und ich telefoniere eh nicht so viel.
Wie, man zahlt nichts mehr?
Keine Grundgebühr.
Na, du musst doch für Internet zahlen.
Ja, das ist ja nochmal sowieso extra. Das hatte ich ja vorher auch extra. Das sind diese 10 Euro für 200 MB.
200 MB? Damit kommst du aus?
Na, ich hab überall WLAN. Also wollt man keinen WLAN.
Ich hab meinen Bedarf nicht, ehrlich gesagt, schon lange nicht mehr nachgerechnet.
Also ich hab hier meinen Telefon, die Einstellung von einem Telefon zum nächsten übernommen und ich hab das jetzt auch schon seit Anfang 2008, also jetzt bald drei Jahre, und ich hab noch nicht mal einen Gigabyte an hier.
Aber das wird doch irgendwie sehr schnell nach Updates. Bist du 100% sicher?
Sehr sicher. Weil die Zahl war ja...
Was, in drei Jahren nicht mehr als ein Gigabyte verbraucht?
Ernsthaft?
Also für mich geht das in der Garantie nicht. Ich hab da schon irgendwie Podcasts geladen ohne Ende.
Da steht hier Send 22, Receive 285 und ich hab definitiv mehr verbraucht.
Dann hast du mal resettet irgendwann. Ja klar, du hast doch irgendwann mal resettet beim neu installieren.
Megabyte.
Ja, aber letztens beim iPhone 4 hat er frisch von vorne angefangen. Ich hab meine Daten immer übernommen. Huckel glaubt ja nicht an... An drüber installieren.
Naja, okay, versteh ich.
Ich bin ein installer.
Ja, aber dann sind meine SMS weg. Das kann ich, das geht gar nicht.
Oh, ich lese gerade. Das neue O2-Carrier-Profile Kill-Tethering. Also ich meine, wenn O2 das bringt, das wollte ich nämlich eigentlich auch schon ansprechen. Jetzt scheint das wohl schon bestätigt zu sein.
Ich hab's ja auch schon gehört. Das ist nicht gut, Jungs.
Nee, dann gibt's nämlich richtig auf Arsch.
Aber es ist eigentlich doch sowieso... Naja, die Sache ist die. Also jetzt, für Leute jetzt sowieso, die nicht Telekom sind, also die, die das so aus Italien, England und sonst woher haben, da sind ja diese Carrier Profiles drauf. Da ist aber gar kein Carrier Profile drauf für O2 Deutschland. Das heißt, dafür wird das Default Carrier Profile genommen. Und bei dem Default Carrier Profile kann man sich ja einstellen, was man will, auch APN-mäßig und so weiter. Das heißt, wenn die demnächst mit so einem Software-Update, was dann kommen könnte oder müsste oder irgendwie so, wenn dann das O2 Carrier Profile für Deutschland kommt und man nicht mehr davon wegswitchen kann, heißt das, dass man gar nicht dran vorbeikommt, dieses scheiß Profil zu nehmen.
Was meinst du damit, man kann nicht mehr wegswitchen davon?
Na ja, wenn das iPhone erkennt, da ist jetzt ein Carrier Profile für O2 Deutschland, dann nimmt es nicht mehr das Default Profile.
Na, also hier steht gerade bei FSDKlog, dass das irgendwie so OVSR kommt mit, hier irgendwie neue Einstellungen möchten, die das aktualisieren. Könnte natürlich auch sein, dass mit dem nächsten iOS-Update dieses Profile auch schon mitkommt.
Das wäre voll der Scheiß, weil...
Aber richtig.
Ich will dieses Tazerang natürlich behalten, auch wenn ich es noch nie benutzt habe, doch einmal. Wurde auch richtig teuer. Bei Oma nämlich. Und weil dann müsste ich ja doch wieder einen Jailbreak machen, um das zu fixen. Das ist aber auch wieder scheiße, weil dann ist mein Telefon wieder halb offen. Dann laufe ich ja wieder mit runtergelassenen Hosen durch die Straßen.
Dann seid ihr die O2-Opfer, nämlich plötzlich. Und ich lache mit meinem Vertragsinkludierten Tethering, weil die Telekom-Kunden dürfen upgraden, habe ich gerade auch noch gelesen.
Dann lache ich aber auch weiter, weil du musst dafür ordentlich bezahlen. Aber ich denke, man kann es wahrscheinlich Jailbreaken, diese Datei ändern und den Jailbreak wieder drüber installieren, damit sie wieder weg ist und die Datei bleibt so, weil es ist im Backup und man spielt ihr da wieder ein.
Ich fände das auf jeden Fall extrem scheiße. Weiß bloß noch nicht so richtig, was ich dagegen tun kann.
Naja, erstmal abwarten.
Zu E-Plus wechseln, ist ja wohl nicht gerade der Weg.
Es gibt keinen E-Plus mehr. Ja, irgendwie haben sie doch gesagt, unter E-Plus machen sie doch jetzt nichts mehr. Außer für Businesskunden oder sowas.
Ach so, echt?
Die haben noch das Privatkundengeschäft eingestellt und machen das jetzt unter ihrer Base-Marke. So hab ich das zumindest verstanden.
Wie heißt dieser französische Film?
Wie?
Der französische Film? Fail Base?
Base Moire oder wie heißt der?
Fick mich.
Würde ich doch so nie sagen.
Naja, die Leute verstehen doch alle französisch, die Mobile-Mix-Firmen. Naja, was denkst du denn? Die sind ja alle so ungebildet, wie die Leute, die die Sendung machen. Jaja, also okay, seid auf der Hut, O2 kommt und will euer Internet klauen. Das ist mal die Aussage hier.
Hab ich mal gesehen. Du hast gelarnt hier in der Mobile-Mix-Sendung.
Jetzt wo du es gerade sagst, ich grübe die ganze Zeit. Ich hab nämlich eigentlich auch noch meinen alten Vertrag. Wie? Ich glaub die Penner, die berechnen mir den aber anders. Da muss ich glaube ich nochmal nachhaken. Ich hab noch einen VIAG Intercom Vertrag. Da war das noch VIAG.
Ich hatte auch meine Sim, stand noch VIAG Intercom drauf.
Ja, ich hab auch noch irgendwie vierstellige Nummer. Sozusagen. Von der Nummer, wo sie angefangen haben. Am Anfang haben sie die Nummern hochgezählt. Sozusagen bei 00000, also so Präfix 00000. Und dann hab ich irgendwie eine vierstellige. Und das ist...
Also 0179 00000 und dann vierstellen oder was?
Ja, da sind noch ein paar andere Ziffern davor, aber hinten waren sie halt 0 und dann wurde so hochgezählt. Und hier, wisst ihr schon, Freund, ich hab immer das erste, der ist glaube ich bei 3-stellig und...
Ich bin bei 4-stellig.
Wie lange ist deine ICQ-Nummer?
Ich bin einer von den ersten 3000 Kunden, glaube ich. Wann war das?
1990.
Viyak Intercom, wann haben die angefangen?
Viyak Intercom, komm erzähl's mir, Wikipedia, ich rufe dich, ich rufe dich Wikipedia. Das ist 1995.
Ich bin erst 1999 zu Intercom, vorher war ich bei Plus, aber die waren scheiße.
Jaja, aber die hatten diese grünen Telefone.
Türkis, war es nicht Türkis?
Dieses 90er Türkis, ja.
So, die Leute wollen jetzt wieder, dass wir über Macintosh reden, sie haben recht. Also, was soll man dazu sagen? Es gibt neue Tarife und es könnte alles schlechter werden auf O2.
Besser werden für die Telekom?
Aber dafür muss man sich seine Telefone nicht mehr irgendwie aus dem Ausland holen, das ist ja auch schon mal was.
Ja, aber hast du mal die Preise gesehen? 100 Euro teurer als im Ausland, immer noch.
Was, wie?
Bei O2?
Stehen da Preise?
Ja, wenn du die einzeln kaufst, ohne Vertrag, ohne alles, sind die richtig teuer.
850 Steine, oder was?
Das geht ja mal gar nicht.
Ich guck mal.
Da kann ich ja mit EasyJet nach London fliegen, wenn Telefonnummern zurückkommen und da bin ich immer noch was gespart.
Was ist denn nur da Preise? Ich seh gar keine Preise.
Ja, die wurden bestimmt irgendwo kommuniziert.
Ja, aber nicht auf ihrer Webseite. Na wie auch immer, das werden wir ja sehen, wie das ist, aber auf jeden Fall geht es. Also man hat sozusagen die Möglichkeit und ich schätze mal, O2 hat gegenüber Vodafone und der Telekom da schon einen Vorteil. Ob sie den ausgespielt bekommen, sagen wir dahingestellt.
Was ist denn... Wisst ihr zufällig, ab wann die Telekom sozusagen das Upgrade für Bestandskunden rauslässt? Ja, das so halt in diesen anderen Vertrag und dann mit Tethering und so.
Anfang November war glaube ich die Ansage und Anfang November...
Also ich würde mal behaupten, wenn das hier mit nach drei Jahren ist der Vertrag mit Apple, dann müsste es am 9. November sein, weil damals ging es am 9. November mit den iPhones los in Deutschland. 9. November 2007.
Ja, das kann durchaus sein, weil es war so in wenigen Wochen die Rede und Anfang November und ich denke mal so in dem Zeitraum wird's laufen.
Also hier iPhone 4 mit 16 GB kostet laut FSDKlog 679 Euro und mit 32 799.
Ja und in London kostet umgerechnet 720 und in der Schweiz sogar nur 680 oder so.
Naja, das muss dann jeder selber entscheiden, wieviel er bereit ist, für so einen Teil rauszuhauen. Das ist ja eigentlich ganz schön teuer, die Scheiße.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Da kriegt man ja ein iPad für.
Na, es kommt ja bald das 11-Zoll-iPad.
Also neulich, um mal gleich das Thema ein bisschen voranzubringen, neulich, als iTunes 10 rauskam, was kein iTunes X war, und dann diese lustige Nummer startete mit diesen Icons, ihr wisst schon, wo sie iTunes 10 Icon mit iTunes 9 Icon auf Twitter unterhalten hat, dass ich mir so dachte, naja, häufig war ja so ein Optikwechsel auch immer so ein bisschen der Vorbote für das nächste OS. Also gerade in iTunes. In iTunes waren ja sehr häufig irgendwelche Design-Elemente zuerst, weil sie da ja jeden Scheiß machen können, weil sie da jeden Scheiß machen müssen, wegen Windows, da ist eh alles ins Programm reingeklatscht. Und dann probieren sie das immer aus, wie das so ankommt, und häufig haben sie ja auch Dinge wieder revidiert, die da nie im US gelandet sind, aber manchmal eben auch schon. Und dann dachte ich mir so bei diesem Icon, mein Gott, vielleicht ist das ja jetzt auch schon so der erste Vorbote für 10.7. Also ich will das nicht behaupten, dass es sein wird, aber vielleicht muss man sich da schon mal aufs Schlimmste einstellen. Auf jeden Fall.
Aber vielleicht macht plötzlich auch alles Sinn.
Du meinst, endlich macht das mal Sinn alles?
Erkläre dich.
Vielleicht haben die ja da so ein Gesamtkonzept. Ich mein, das eigene...
Du meinst, Apple hat ein Gesamtkonzept?
Ja, ich bitte dich.
Das eigene ist so scheiße, da muss ja wirklich irgendwas Tieferes dahinter stecken.
Vielleicht sind die von iLife alle jetzt auch aus.
Was heißt, es ist scheiße? Also wenn man jetzt mal von gut und schlecht mal absieht, es ist vor allem eins. Es ist extrem simpel. Also es ist sehr minimiert auf das Wesentliche. Nämlich hier Ton.
Ja, aber ist ja voll falsch.
Weil auch hier Movie, hier Book, hier Everything. Hier iTunes University, hier Applications, hier Die es brennen. Hier ist Media und nicht New Music.
Ja, aber vielleicht haben sie irgendwie beschlossen, dass die Note immer noch sozusagen, wenn du die Reduktion weiter reduzierst, wie auch immer. Ich will das gar nicht bewerten. Die Ansage war noch klarer, noch emblemhafter sozusagen. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ikonifizierter. Vielleicht drückt das irgendwas aus. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall sieht es ja jetzt so aus, als ob wir nächste Woche die ersten Daten bekommen zu Mac OS 10.7, weil dieses Back to the Mac Event angekündigt wurde, zwei Tage nachdem sie ihre Record-Quarter annoncen werden. Also nächsten Montag ist wieder Kohle irgendwie angesagt. Ja, sieht ja ganz gut aus. Also ich schätze mal, wir werden da schlucken müssen, glaube ich, bei dem Quartal. Ach, wenn man sich so als anschaut, was so die ganzen Analysten, die ja in der Regel immer da drunter liegen, was die schon so von sich geben, also würde mich einfach überhaupt nicht überraschen, wenn mehr als vier Millionen Macs abgesetzt werden würden, worden wären in dem letzten Quartal. Das ist eine Menge. Wir hatten vor ein paar Jahren gab es mal eine Million pro Quartal. Das war schon ein gutes Ergebnis für Apple. Jetzt hat sich das irgendwie schon vervierfacht.
Da gab es doch schon Zahlen heute irgendwie.
Es gibt halt diese Analysten.
10,8 Prozent im US-Markt Anteil an Desktop.
Na ja, das ist alles so geschätzt. Nicht an Desktop, sondern an Macs. Ich glaube in die Zahl ja. Bin ich mir aber jetzt auch nicht so sicher, weil das iPad ja im Prinzip sozusagen in der Kategorie Notebooks und Netbooks viel mehr gehandelt wird. Aber das weiß ich nicht, stecke ich jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht drin. Ich habe da schon verschiedene Ansätze gelesen, auch dass quasi das iPad einen neuen Markt definiert, nämlich den der Tablet-Computer, in dem sich aber eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur ein Produkt befindet derzeit. Na gut, das wird man sehen. Anyway, zwei Tage nach dieser Verkündigung der Zahlen wird es also diesen Event geben und da gab es doch diese schicke Flyer jetzt, die man dann gesehen hat, wo so ein Löwe dahinter hinter dem Apfel war. Apfel dreht sich nach hinten, man sieht durchs Fenster Löwe, Löwe, Löwe. Ja, und was ist das? Das ist irgendwie Mac OS 10.7.
Die Krönung der Schöpfung, die größte Raubkatze auf dem Planeten, ja. Also jetzt ist wirklich, jetzt haben sie alles durch von schneller bis schicker bis, hast du nicht gesehen, jetzt kommt The King.
Ist der Löwe die größte Raubkatze?
Ich glaube, das habe ich mal gelesen, ja. Ja, also der ist nochmal, der hat nochmal ein paar Kilo obendrauf. Gucken wir nochmal alle schnell. Da wird nix mehr geglaubt. Nee, Moment, das Stahl wird es. Das klingt so nach gefährlichem Halbwissen.
Nach dem Tiger ist der Löwe die zweitgrößte Katze und damit das größte Land robt hier Afrikas. Tja, siehst du mal hier. Also ist es gut, dass wir noch Leute in der Sendung haben mit Grundbildung.
Also der Löwe nicht der größte, ja?
Tiger ist fett. Ich war neulich erstmal wieder im Zoo und Tiger ist einfach mal wirklich fett. Das ist wirklich groß. Mein Löwe ist nicht klein und will mit beiden nicht im Fahrstuhl sein, aber...
Aber der Löwe hat halt hier so irgendwie so noch seinen göttlichen goldenen Kranz ums Gesicht, ne?
Genau. Und jetzt frage ich mich, was ist sozusagen die Mähne von Mekko S107?
Ja, vor allen Dingen, Frage Nummer eins, also eigentlich ist es ja klar, dass es S107 ist, sie gehen jetzt nicht einfach auf irgendwas.
Nein, sie gehen nicht auf 11.
Und sie gehen auch nicht auf irgendwas anderes, sondern es ist S107.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Nein.
So grundlegend denke ich mal, wenn sie jetzt nicht...
Gut, also erstens...
Da werde ich echt überrascht, wenn sie sagen, wir machen jetzt hier römisch 11. Was ist denn das denn? Meco S... Also sie...
Nee, da würden sie irgendwas anderes sagen.
Meco S11, wie klingt das denn? Nachdem sie uns jetzt 10 Jahre lang damit getrittet haben, dass man das X10 aussprechen soll.
Warum? Weil irgendwann müssen wir jetzt 10...
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hab nie verstanden, warum...
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie darauf bestanden haben, dass man das X als 10 spricht.
Weil das Meco S9 war, Mann.
Ja, aber das heißt ja noch nicht, dass man das dann deswegen auch so sagen muss. Ich meine, dass das X sozusagen 9 ersetzt, das hätte ja als Botschaft schon vollkommen gereicht. Und jetzt hat man halt Meco SX und Version 10.6. So, da hätte man dann auch Meco SX Version 11 machen können.
Danach kommt Meco SY.
Und sie wenden, sie können auch diesen... Nee, da kommt Meco SY-Node.
Nee, aber irgendwann müssen sie halt mal was anderes machen. Sie können ja irgendwann das 10.9. Und danach können sie nicht 9.9 und 9.9.9 und...
Der Chat schlägt vor, hier Meco S... Meco S Flash. So nach dem Motto, ja, was wollt ihr denn? Wir haben doch Flash. Ja, okay, war jetzt ein bisschen unseriös. Wollen wir mal Feature raten? Was kommt? Bevor wir dazu kommen vielleicht. Warum jetzt?
War das mein Rechner?
Warum gehen sie jetzt raus mit einer Betriebssystemankündigung? Ich meine, sie tun nichts ohne Grund. Sie müssen das aus einem bestimmten Grund machen.
Das ist doch ganz klar, weil seit 10...
5?
Also seit Leopard, das war ja irgendwann Oktober 2007, ist schon lange her, und Snow Leopard war ja nicht so wirklich ein riesengroßes, fettes Update. Die haben ja so ein bisschen was anderes verkauft. Vielleicht kommt jetzt wieder...
Sie haben gesagt, sie hätten zero Features.
Vielleicht kommt jetzt wieder so ein riesen Ding, und die sind schon seit Jahren da am Machen.
Ja, das ist auch so.
Also sie haben ja genau...
Also du meinst, da kommen jetzt mehr Features als für den kurzen Zeitraum nach Snow Leopard, was ja letztes Jahr Oktober rauskam oder so. Also vor einem Jahr.
Ich meine, jetzt werden sie das previewen, aber sie werden es erst nächstes Jahr bringen. Wie lange ist jetzt Snow Leopard her? Wie lange ist es her, jetzt das Release?
Snow Leopard, letztes Jahr Oktober glaube ich auch.
Also vor einem Jahr.
Oder ganz Ende September raus.
Also ich rechne jetzt nicht mit einem Betriebssystemrelease, weil sie müssen ja ihre Developer noch drauf einstellen und pipapo. Das kann sehr wohl sein, dass das noch bis zur nächsten WWDC dauert. Andererseits... 2009 kam 10.06 raus. So, und wenn sie jetzt noch bis August 2011 warten, was zwei Jahre wäre...
Also ich mein...
Vielleicht verlinken sie die World Wide Developers Konferenz jetzt vor auf Weihnachten.
Also zum einen...
Die werden sich bedanken.
Zum einen ist halt genau auch die Sache, die letzte WWDC haben sie ja schon mal genau nur dem iPhone gewidmet und gar nicht dem Mac so. Das heißt, da ist sowieso noch so ein... So ein Loch.
Das ist ja auch im Titel jetzt schon, dieses Back to the Mac ist so weiter so. Und jetzt kommen wir jetzt über nichts, was vollkommen anderem sein soll.
Und dann, wenn man jetzt nochmal Revue passieren lässt, haben sie ja tatsächlich irgendwie das letzte Release eben so angekündigt von wegen, wir machen jetzt mal hier unten drunter so ein bisschen schicker für die Zukunft, damit irgendwie, ne? Also später im Release davon profitieren und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, vielleicht haben sie jetzt wirklich einfach irgendwie geilen Scheiß gekocht und lassen jetzt die Katze aus dem Sack.
Ja, aber warum jetzt? Also ich rechne damit, dass sie ein neues Facebook-Air rausbringen.
Hardware-Vorstellung für Weihnachten?
Also ich weiß es nicht, es ist nur lange lange her und die Gerüchteküche kocht schon lange und es wäre jetzt einfach mal Zeit für ein Update. So, es kommt ein neues Air, es wird gemunkelt, das Herz kleiner. Warum sollten sie das tun?
Warum? Weil alle Leute heutzutage irgendwie Twitter-Refik auf dem Mac haben und mit dem Finger nach oben scrollen wollen. Ist das noch nie passiert? Dass du auf dem Bildschirm tatschst und eigentlich ziehen willst mit dem Finger?
Wenn man ein iPad hat, dann passiert das in zunehmendem Maße, aber ich meine, dafür haben sie das iPad. Und das User-Interface vom Mac, ich meine, da bist du beim V-Tap.
Das ist ja eine ganz andere Liga.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das machen werden. Ich glaube, dass sie beim Mac OS X bleiben sie einfach bei diesem Gesten-Ding über Trackpad. Das ist irgendwie eine definierte Eingabe-Ohr. Das liegt auch da, wo die Hand ist. Dieses über den Bildschirm rüber reichen und dann irgendwie auf einen Bildschirm, auf so einem Wackel-Bildschirm von so einem Laptop rumtouchen.
Das ist einfach nicht ihr Ding. Brauchst auch nicht diese physische Tastatur nicht. Ich kann ja auf Software Keyboard total super tippen. Und dann machst du einfach hier die Unterseite auch. Mit dynamischer Tastatur- Umbelegung, den ganzen geilen Features.
Das glaub ich einfach nicht. Ich hab da jetzt auch selber keine Antwort drauf. Ich hab mich nur gefragt, warum jetzt? Und es muss ja irgendwas mit dem Zeitpunkt zu tun haben, dass sie jetzt irgendwas ankündigen. Was ich mir halt vorstellen könnte ist, dass sie eine Hardware rausbringen, die irgendwas Tolles Neues tut, aber deren Potential eigentlich erst dann sich vollständig erschließt und Sinn macht, obwohl du es jetzt schon kaufen möchtest, wenn du dann im Frühjahr Mac OS 10.7 dazu bekommst. Irgend sowas in diese Richtung gedacht. Vielleicht hat es ja was mit dem Fallsystem zu tun. Vielleicht hat es irgendwas mit dem vielleicht hat es was mit einem App Store zu tun. Vielleicht hat es was mit Facetime zu tun. Genau, das OS ist jetzt Kamera, Netbook, Mac OS, MacBook Air, leicht tragbar, Kamera, Facetime.
Also Facetime ist ja auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, weil eine Kamera und ein Mikro hast du in deinem Rechner eh schon drin.
Aber das könnten sie ja auch heute schon mit allen machen. Da brauchen wir jetzt keine neue Hardware für.
Ja, aber das ist ja bei Apple immer so, dass sie schonens auch was mit einer alten Hardware machen könnten, das aber einfach software-mäßig nicht freischalten, damit man die neue Hardware kauft.
Ja, aber dafür Also du hast auf jeden Fall einfach iChat und FaceTime.
Dann haben sie aber auch diese Software gleich mit dem Gerät. Hier geht es ja um eine Ankündigung. Wir erwarten ja wohl nicht ernsthaft, dass sie jetzt macOS 10.7 ankündigen, dass sie das nächste Wochen shippen. Das wird einfach nicht passieren. Schon gar nicht, wenn es viele neue Features hat, die die Developer erst alle unterstützen müssen, damit man auch wirklich was von hat. Es sei denn, das OS kommt mit dermaßen viel Build-In-Scheiß daher, oder sie haben Final Cut Pro und alles, was sie im Regal haben, gebundelt, was auch keinen Sinn macht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Vielleicht mit iLife, das neue iLife, was aber erst voll aus dem...
Dass auch so eine iTunes-Icon kommt.
Bitte?
Dass auch so eine iTunes-Icon kommt. Also iMovie hat so einen blauen Blöbel mit einer Kamera drauf oder mit einem Filmstreifen. Und Gerrit spendet eine Gitarre und... Nee, aber also iChat mit... iChat mit Facetime ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, ein Safe-Bet, oder?
Ach so.
Das ist doch low-hanging fruit. Haben sie eh schon drin, diesen ganzen Video-Schüssel.
Naja, also ich meine...
Und Facetime ohne Video wäre noch mal angesagt.
Also womit ich jetzt auf... In meinem Airprint wird sowieso den Weg jetzt mit einem 1065-Update finden. Das ist irgendwie ein No-Braner. Airplay wiederum müsste eigentlich auch noch drin sein. Auf dem iPad ist es ja so, wenn man sich diese Beta anschaut, was ich natürlich getan habe. Dann stellt man halt fest, dass...
Hätte man festgestellt.
Hätte man festgestellt, dann würde man feststellen, dass es sozusagen nicht in iTunes ist, so wie das bisher mit dem iTunes war, sondern es ist sozusagen im OS. Das ist sozusagen die Wiedergabe selbst dieser Film, dieses Filmoverlay, was immer kommt, wenn irgendein Programm Film abspielt, was auf dem iPhone den ganzen Bildschirm einnimmt oder was halt immer die Standard-Control ist, auf dem iPad, das hat halt dieses zusätzliche Airplay-Button-Teil. Und naja, wenn man sich so diesen Quicktime-Player anschaut, der auch schon extrem reduziert ist, ich könnte mir das halt vorstellen, dass sie das in Quicktime X einbauen.
Das wird auch mal Zeit, dass man auch seine Movies, also den Sound von den Movies zu so einer Express checken kann.
Ja, und vielleicht bauen sie ja auch Facetime überall ein, dass sozusagen jedes Programm das so benutzen kann, dass jedes Programm Facetime machen kann. Das weiß ich, ein Programm, was dir deine gescannten Dokumente per Telefon überträgt oder sonst irgendwas. Irgendwelche 3D, irgendwas Gerinnertes, irgendwas Spiele.
Also eigentlich find ich's ja schon ein bisschen peinlich, muss ich sagen. Weil du kannst halt, selbst wenn du dir ein externes Laufwerk holst, da gibt's halt keine Software, du kannst Blu-ray einfach nicht gucken. Und selbst wenn du in die Videothek gehst, mal ausnahmsweise und denkst, boah geil, jetzt irgendwie einen coolen Film, dann musst du halt Low-Res-DVD kaufen, äh ausleihen.
Ist dir schon aufgefallen, dass so eine DVD eine schwächere Auflösung als unser iPhone hat?
Also ich will, also ich komm manchmal in die Videothek, weil bei iTunes und so weiter gibt's ja auch immer nicht alles und in meiner coolen Videothek gibt's halt viel und der neue Scheiß, den haben die auf Blu-ray. Und ich muss dann sagen, ja okay, ich nehm die DVD. Und das Problem ist halt, ich will nicht die DVD. Ich will hier voll HD.
Shit.
Und Huckel geht nämlich zu...
Videodrome, die beste Videothek. Mindestens in Kreuzberg, wenn nicht sogar in der Stadt.
Gibt's Negativland noch? Na die beiden haben hier so...
Die beiden sind es genau. Das ist ein cooler Tipp, wer in Berlin wohnt und gute Videotheken haben will, Kreuzberg.
Videodrome, die ziehen übrigens gerade um. Schon wieder? Nee, jetzt erst mal wieder.
Negativland ist umgezogen vor einiger Zeit. Die sind jetzt in der Danziger Straße hier.
Die ziehen nun ein paar Straßen weiter. Aber ja, also irgendwie... Also ich finde, so langsam könnten sie einfach sagen, ja gut, hier kommt, jetzt könnt ihr auch Blu-ray abspielen. Aber ihr müsst euch einen Laufwerk selber kaufen. Laufwerk brauchen wir nicht ein.
Ja, aber da kann doch auch mal ein externer Player herkommen.
Muss doch nicht Apple machen eigentlich. Nee, also irgendwie müssen die ja diese komischen Krypto-Standards, keine Ahnung, was, also irgendwas, du brauchst in deinem OS halt den Support. Und alle, die...
Bist du sicher, dass der im OS sein muss?
Alle Laufwerke, die es gibt für einen Mac, also die auch auf dem Mac dann sozusagen Blu-ray mounten lassen, die sagen, Film gucken kannst du auch auf dem Mac, aber du musst es in VirtualBox oder in VMWare, Windows booten und damit dann gucken. Also es geht...
Ja, aber braucht das Laufwerk wirklich Support vom OS oder braucht es ein spezielles Abspielprogramm? Weil sonst könnte doch hier Nero für den Mac...
Also du brauchst halt irgendwie irgendwas. Egal, ob es jetzt nur eine digitale Unterschrift ist oder sowas, aber... Das geht halt nicht einfach so leider.
Du weißt doch, wie Oli Steve das genannt hat.
Also ich guck ja Blu-Rays. Kost mich halt immer zwei Tage die unterzuladen.
Sie haben halt gehofft, dass irgendwie, dass sie dieses HD auf Kaufmedium oder Leihmedium, also auf Scheibenmedium, dass sie das irgendwie ausgesessen bekommen. Und dass sie irgendwie es schaffen, mit ihrem Apple-TV-Kram da irgendwie dran vorbei zu haben. Na, wir reden gleich nochmal über Apple-TV. Ich würd sagen, es geht da sehr langsam voran.
Also der iTunes Store hatte ich ja auch schon mehrfach mein Unmut geäußert. Das ist halt auch echt noch weit, weit weg von irgendwie gehst in die Videothek, hast irgendwie einmal alles und ziemlich schnell vor allen Dingen.
Du bist nur schneller da und wieder weg. Aber irgendwie die eigentliche Auswahl-Experience, die lässt auch arg zu wünschen übrig. Aber vor allem ist die Auswahl halt schlecht. Da kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drüber, wenn wir über Apple TV reden.
Jetzt sind wir noch mal bei Mac OS 7.
Blu-ray.
Ja, könnte ich mir gut vorstellen. Ich weiß aber noch nicht, ob mir das gefällt, was da so auf mich zukommt.
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Also ich denke nicht, dass das nur eine exklusive Geschichte ist, wie jetzt auf dem iPhone. Du kannst nur da drüber. Aber was halt generell einfach ein Fail ist, auf Mac immer noch, ist dieses ganze Installieren und Deinstallieren. Was auch immer sie sich jetzt haben einfallen lassen über die Jahre mit Disc-Images und Auto- und Self-Mounting und Tralala. Und du musst ja auch nur noch Dreck und Dreck machen. Ihr kennt das. Wenn ihr mit neuen Usern irgendwie mal ein Mac ausprobiert, das peilt einfach keiner, dass man das Programm-Icon auf die Applikationen ziehen muss. Das landet dann irgendwie im Sidebar, im Finder oder bleibt einfach im Downloads-Folder liegen oder auf dem Desktop.
Wir sind jetzt da angekommen, wo Windows schon immer war.
Die Leute hatten schon immer keine Ahnung von Computern. Das wird sich auch nie ändern.
Früher hattest du ja auch mal deinen Installer bei Mac OS.
Das darf man ja auch überhaupt nicht voraussetzen. Man sollte auch überhaupt keine Ahnung haben von Computern, um sie vollwertig zu benutzen, benutzen zu können. Das ist bloß erforderlich. Deswegen haben wir jetzt hier in unserem Nerd-Szene auch immer diesen albernen Guru-Status, der uns aber letzten Endes auch nur schlaflose Abende bereitet hat, wo wir irgendwelcher anderer Leute merkwürdigen Fallsystemprobleme gefixt haben.
Du kannst ja schon Leute voll beeindrucken, indem du denen sagst, ja dann Bute doch einfach mach, dann geht's und dann sind die schon voll happy.
Das hab ich auch schon vor 20 Jahren gemacht. Das ist nichts Neues. Ja, aber eigentlich ist das...
Oh, jetzt haben wir hier unser Trade Secret verraten. Unsere Multimillion Dollar Support-Verträge.
Das war's.
Alle wertlos.
Na ja gut, aber jetzt... Also ich meine ja, es ist halt nicht so App Store so wie beim iPhone, dass das sozusagen die einzige Quelle ist, aber schon dieses Ding mit der Software-Download kommt von Apple, das Ding installiert sich, das Ding deinstalliert sich, das Ding updated sich. Ja, das Ding updated sich und meinetwegen, also nicht meinetwegen im Sinne von das will ich so haben, sondern das was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was es unter Umständen bedeutet, dass das Ding quasi dann auch auf die Seriennummer des Gerätes oder zumindest auf dein Apple-Account, ne, Geräte meinen sie nicht machen, aber ist natürlich auf dein App-Account. Genau, dass da sozusagen dein DAM damit drin ist, aber du hast natürlich dann auch sofort einfach den Vorteil, anf. dass eben das Programm mal nicht easy peasy verändert werden kann. Ich meine, das hast du jetzt auch bei einem Download eines signierten Programms nicht, nur dass du eben vorher nicht weißt, was du runterlädst. Ich meine, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie leicht eigentlich so eine Tretmine zu legen ist heutzutage, ja, und auch in zunehmendem Maße gelegt wird, ist natürlich so ein trusted Channel durchaus so ein Ding.
Ja, also das ist ja auf jeden Fall die Sache, aber immer wenn du jetzt so nach Programmen suchst, dann landest du ja nicht mehr bei Version Track oder Mac Update, sondern bei Softpea oder irgendwelchen komischen hast du nicht gesehen Seiten und für irgendwie Normal-User sehen die glaube ich auch alle gleichwertig, vertrauenswürdig aus. Also so ein Distribution Channel kann ich mir schon auch durchaus vorstellen, aber ich könnte mir halt auch vorstellen, dass da viele... Also es gibt ja sowas schon, ne? Gibt's ja hier, wie heißt das? Bodegas. Das ist so ein App Store für Apps, für Mac irgendwie. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie überhaupt noch gibt, aber bestimmt. Bodegas. Und aber eigentlich hatten wir ja schon mal vor ewigen Zeiten in einer Folge angesprochen, was ja das eigentliche Feature dahinter ist, was wir haben wollen, Sandboxes. Dass du die halt, die App da irgendwie klickst und die erstmal in so einem Sandbox-Dingsbums läuft und wenn du sagst, ne will ich nicht, dann ist die auch komplett wegspurenlos, komplett self-contained und eigentlich...
Das hätte ich auch gerne.
Das wäre echt das killer Feature.
Also dass auch irgendwie die App so hochkommt und dann so, ich glaub bei Android haben die das sogar, hat mir mal jemand gezeigt. Die haben ja heute unseren Android-Fanboy hier irgendwie nicht.
Na Sandboxing gibt's ja auf macOS 10, das ist ja technisch vorhanden.
Naja, aber so ein Sandboxing, wo die App dann sagen kann, hier also hör mal zu, hier, bin neues Programm, ich würd gern auf dein Adressbuch zugreifen, ich würd gerne TCP in out haben und ich würde gerne... Haben die auch sowas? Ja, sowas. Wo ich das halt so ein bisschen bestimmen kann, was ein Programm darf. Weißt du, wenn ich wieder so ein Hacker-Tool runterlade, was nur mir eine Liste sortieren soll, dann soll das kein Netzwerk machen.
Die Leute klicken dann immer auf Ja, die klicken so lange auf Ja, bis das Programm endlich das tut, was es soll.
Hier, aber das ist mir egal, was andere machen.
Das machst du auf deinem iPhone aber auch nicht. Aber das eigentliche, was du haben willst, ist ja, dass das Programm selber in der Sandbox ist und nicht irgendwo anders sich hinschreibt, nicht irgendwo anders hin installiert. Und das ist ja okay, wenn es dann irgendwie komplett self-contained ist und du... Also, weißt du, jetzt ist ja so, du startest das Programm...
Voll auf dein Adressbuch zugreift und dir alles rausschickt, wenn du das auch verhindern kannst.
Ja, na gut, Apples Weg ist Upstore-Approval.
Aber das hast du doch mit der Firewall auch.
Testing und Monitoring, das ist sozusagen ihr Ding. Weil letzten Endes, ich meine, was hilft dir das, wenn du das Ding sagst, ich will auf dein Adressbuch zugreifen? Ja, nein. Wenn du nein sagst, dann kannst du das Programm nicht benutzen, dann kannst du es auch gleich löschen.
Na ja, kommt halt darauf an, was das Programm ist.
Ja, weil kein Programm ist, ja, das weißt du aber nicht. Also, ich meine, da hat der User keine Ahnung davon. Kann sein. Was das Programm nun braucht. Man muss davon ausgehen und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch in der Regel so, dass wenn irgendeine Ressource ihm nicht gegeben wird, dann ist das wie ein Pfeil, wo du nicht die Read-Permission drauf hast und dann bricht es halt einfach ab.
Auf dem iPhone ist ja auch so mit den Locations. Kannst du sagen, ne hier, du nicht.
Ne gut, aber das kannst du ja auf dem Mac jetzt auch schon.
Mach mal dein Mikro ein bisschen höher, du atmest da so ein bisschen sehr rein.
Und dann hast du ja hier diese Firewall, also die ist jetzt ja nicht besonders toll, die vom Mac. Na doch, ich kenne Leute, die die benutzen.
Ich hab schon mal von Leuten gehört, die schon mal einen gesehen haben.
Mein Kollege benutzt das und da fragen ja die Programme tatsächlich oder dann sagt dir die Firewall, ich darf jetzt das Programm XY irgendwie raustelefonieren. Also das macht genau diese Firewall, dein Boy. Ich hab Little Snitch von der ASIC sowieso.
Rein telefonieren meinst du jetzt. Firewall ist nur rein telefonieren. Also die Firewall vom Mac bezieht sich nur auf Verbindungen von außen. Little Snitch bezieht sich auf Verbindungen von innen. Aber als Bordmittel gibt es nichts, was von innen nach außen blockt.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist ja so die alte, das alte Problem, also so richtig Sicherheit hat halt immer so einen Preis, ne? Also in Sachen Usability-Ansorge. Genau. Nicht drüber nachdenken. Sicherheit gibt's halt eh nicht.
Genau, und deswegen hat Apple halt dieses Modell beim iPhone, was ja an sich auch ganz gut funktioniert. Ja, ich meine so die Anzahl der Fälle, wo jetzt wirklich mal ein Programm Rogue ist, ist überschaubar. Und vor allem haben sie ja auch noch eben diese Not-Aus-Taste. Sie könnten, wenn denn mal wirklich irgendwas ganz fies läuft, aktiv werden und dem iPhone sagen, dieses Programm schalt's mal aus. Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt genauso auf Mac kommt, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie eben Fortschritte machen. Ist der Store hin oder her? Mir persönlich wäre es schon lieb, wenn sie überhaupt dieses Problem Installation, Deinstallation einfach mal gelöst bekommen. Dass einfach mal es klar ist, dass wenn ich sage, Photoshop weg, dass ich wirklich nur irgendwo sage, Photoshop weg. Und dann meint wegen seiner mich noch zehnmal fragen, ob ich das wirklich, wirklich, wirklich meine, will und er es wirklich, wirklich tun soll. Und mich über alle möglichen Konsequenzen aufklärt, die das haben könnte. Ihr Computer könnte schneller laufen, mehrere Gigabyte Platz gewinnen. Wenn ich das dann sage, dass es dann weg ist, aber nicht nur Slash Application Slash Adobe Photoshop Ordner Tralala mit ihrem ganzen Schnuddelratz, was sie da haben, sondern auch irgendwie Slash Library Tralala und keine Ahnung, Colonel Traber hier und so weiter. Dass es einfach weg ist. Und dass du auch deinen eigenen User-Bereich davon cleanen kannst. Dass du auch sagen kannst, alle Dateien, die mit diesem Programm im Zusammenhang stehen.
Der atmet auch.
Darth Vader, mach deinen Rollklaut von oben weg. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Dass es einfach weg ist. Weg im Sinne von weg. Oder vielleicht auch weg archivieren. Möchtest du die Settings dieses Programms behalten, dass wenn du später nochmal installierst, dass du eben mit denselben Settings arbeiten kannst. Aber eben nicht die Cache-Files und nicht die Temporary-Files und nicht die Tralala-Files. Das einfach mal besser unterschieden wird zwischen dem, was diese Programme eigentlich tatsächlich auf deiner Platte hinterlassen. Programme, Bibliotheken, Preferences, Caches und Templates oder keine Ahnung, also irgendwie so Files, die man sich so macht, so Settings, die man sich so macht, die so wiederverwendbar wären. Das ist irgendwie alles ganz, wäre einfach gut.
Also, nächstes Feature, was wir sozusagen auf der Liste haben, Sandboxing oder Installation, Self-Containment, da könnten sie toll was machen. Also, Apple hat vor geraumer Zeit, als sie gesagt haben, ZFS ist doof, wollen wir nicht mehr, haben sie gesagt, wir suchen jetzt einen Filesystem-Engineer, wo der auch irgendwie, auch bei uns im Podcast war es zu hören. Dann haben sie halt nach einem gesucht und ich hab kürzlich mal geguckt, also das Job-Hiring ist auch tatsächlich mittlerweile verschwunden. Das heißt, sie haben da jetzt wohl einen Filesystem-Engineer und vielleicht ist ja ein großes Feature genau eben dieses.
Welches?
Ein neues Filesystem.
Sie müssen da was machen. Mindestens müssen sie es verbessern. Also es geht nicht. Also eins von diesen großen Features muss auf jeden Fall drin sein.
Ja, und Filesystems.
Mindestens Snapshots. Also ich will einfach Time Machine X mit Snapshots. Ich will nicht, dass das Stunden dauert, bis irgendwie so ein Backup erzeugt wird.
Vielleicht haben sie sich hier ein Filesystem eingekauft von NetApp.
Du meinst ZFS eingekauft, sich die Lizenzen geholt.
Nein, nein, nein. ZFS ist ja jetzt Solaris Oakel. Und es gibt auch hier diese Filerfirmen hier, EMC Quadrat und NetApp. Die beiden großen Konkurrenten für ZFS sozusagen. Also sie es halt businessmäßig machen und die gleich die passende Art wieder zu verkaufen. Und die haben ja auch Filesysteme, die übrigens noch viel mehr advanced sind als ZFS teilweise. Und da kann man bestimmt auch sich was einkaufen.
Vorstellbar.
Glaube ich aber auch nicht, aber es wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, aber sie werden natürlich nichts nehmen, was jetzt wirklich so eine Kommerzlizenz hat, was sie nicht selber open source raushauen können.
Not invented here.
Nicht so sehr not invented here, aber ich meine, ihr Darwin ist open source und das soll sicherlich auch so bleiben. Und das Fallsystem gehört da einfach mal dazu. Und sie müssen da einfach in control sein. Also gerade weil das für ihr iPhone so wichtig ist, Apple wird keine Technologie nehmen, wo sie nicht die Chance haben, das voll unter Kontrolle zu haben. Ich kann mir auch durchaus vorstellen, dass er mit seinem Busen-Freund Larry Ellison da schon lange am Schnackeln ist, die da ja irgendwie an Butter FS irgendwie drehen. Am Ende ist das dann auch ein Marsch.
Butter FS ist ausgestiegen schon vor ewigen Zeiten.
Ich dachte, die entwickeln da noch dran.
Nee, die haben da mal mitgemacht oder das auch losgetreten haben sich, aber da ist schon lange, lange zurückgezogen.
Na gut, bin ich schon wieder nicht abzudehnt.
Larry hat sich ZFS eingekauft, so scheiße war Butter FS.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie sich ja auch wieder geeinigt. Ich meine, Larry gehört ZFS, das passt doch alles irgendwie nicht zusammen. Butter FS geht auch nicht, das ist GPL. Das Butter FS kann es nicht sein.
Und das ist auch noch lange nicht, also es ist weit entfernt von brauchbar.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber auf jeden Fall kann man sagen, dass wenn Blu-Ray ein Back of Heart ist, dann ist Half-S Plus auf jeden Fall auch ein Back of Heart. Und das, also...
Na ja, auf Heart eigentlich gar nicht die Features fehlen. Funktionieren tut's ja.
Aber es beschweren sich alle darüber. Also alle sagen, es ist scheiße.
Also ich finde, es funktioniert jetzt erst mal von der Reihenfunktion, also von dem, was es verspricht. Das tut es. Da finde ich, ist es sehr stabil.
Das war einmal im Vierteljahr oder so auch das Disk-Utility von CD Start ist, und mal Repair Disk und Repair Permissions kriegst und so.
Ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern, weil ich das letzte Mal ein Fallsystem-Problem hatte.
Repair Permissions ist ja nicht ein Fallsystem-Problem.
Das Repair Disk, das ist ja schon öfters, weil wenn du zum Beispiel hart ausschalten musst, danach ist ja dann irgendwie schon mal Bogo State.
Da gibt es Journaling. Journaling ist jetzt nicht das Ende.
Lass mal laufen in deinen Disk-Checker, mal sehen, was er alles findet. Also ich mach das jedes Mal nach so einem Hard Reset und jedes Mal ist da auch irgendwas.
Aber man kann es auch ohne Hard Reset machen.
Ja gut, aber dass da irgendwas angezeigt wird versus, da ist ein wirkliches Problem. Das sind ja nochmal so zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten. Naja. Also es ist irgendwie unklar. Tatsache ist, es gibt bestimmte Features in ZFS, die finde ich einfach extrem wichtig auch für das, was Apple tut. Und dazu gehören für mich Snapshots, Integrität mit Chexum, dass man einfach mal seiner Daten sich sicher sein kann und so eine Sachen wie De-Duplication. Ich meine, allein De-Duplication, das würde so viel bringen, das würde so viel Platz sparen. Insbesondere beim Kopieren von riesigen Dateien. Du hast da irgendwie dein Gigabyte Movie und dann machst du davon eine Kopie und dann änderst du da ein paar Metadaten an der Seite, wieder ein Gigabyte weg. Und das hast du dann halt mit so De-Duplication, hast du das halt einfach mal nicht. Dann hast du da irgendwie ein Megabyte vielleicht zusätzlich noch weggeholzt an Metadaten und das war's. Und das ist einfach ein Feature, das braucht so eine professionelle Workstation, die für Medienarbeit ausgelegt ist und wo Platz immer ein Problem ist. Ich meine, die Festplatten werden größer, okay. Die SSDs sind sehr teuer. Sie haben schon bei 10.6 ihren Footprint extrem gesenkt, wenn auch nicht mit genau diesen Maßnahmen, aber auch mit Features im Fallsystem. Sie haben HFS Plus explizit halt da platzsparende Features hinzugefügt. Aber das ist halt alles nicht auf dem Level, wie das eben bei ZFS ist. Deswegen, ich denke einfach, sie müssen da was tun. Ich weiß natürlich nicht, ob sie mit 10.7 was schon tun werden, aber sie müssen was tun. Und noch wichtiger finde ich Snapshots. Es muss einfach möglich sein, jederzeit einen Knopf drücken zu können und zu sagen, so wie jetzt das gerade ist auf der Platte erhalten. Damit ich da in Ruhe ein Backup von mache.
Also Time Machine wäre auch ZFS, wenn man es kombinieren würde, das wär's.
Das wäre so schnell und das würde so wenig Platz verbrauchen, dann vor allem auf dem Backup-Medium. Stell dir mal vor.
Aber wie wir schon oft gesagt haben, auch in dieser Sendung, wenn es genau um dieses Thema ging, mit genau den selben Anmerkungen. Das ist nicht neu, ich weiß.
Das heißt, da muss irgendwas passieren, auch wenn es nicht zentral ist. Genau, also Steve. 10-7. Ich hab noch was, was ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass es eintreffen wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es nächste Woche erzählen wird, aber ich denke mal, es wird der Fall sein. Ja doch, ich glaube auch, er wird es erzählen. Er wird erzählen, dass es komplette 10-7 mit C-Lang gebaut wurde.
Da bin ich mir sicher, ja.
Sure short sagt man, ne?
Das glaub ich auch. Sie werden komplett auf C-Lang umsteigen, auf den neuen Compiler.
Hier LLVM und Klang soll man ihn ja nennen, oder?
Ja, können Sie vergessen.
Klang.
C-Lang. Kling. Kling.
Nee, nee, nee.
Wobei das ist jetzt kein Feature, aber das ist halt so eine Eigenschaft. Sie werden damit unter Umständen nochmal Performance-Gewinne erzielen können mit ihrem LLVM-Kram und auch mit ihrer Compilation. Wie sehr sich das bemerkbar macht, ich weiß es nicht. Ja, und das andere große Ding neben Filesystem und Snapshot und so weiter und Verbesserungen in der ganzen Backup-Geschichte meiner Meinung nach ist halt Syncing. Da müssen Sie irgendwie mal eine Antwort für finden. Ja, also ich hab jetzt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten extrem umgestellt auf Programme, die sinken übers Netz, übers Internet. Und das ist so anders auf einmal alles. Das ist irgendwie, ich kann jederzeit an einen anderen Rechner springen. Ich kann zwischen meinem iPhone, meinem iPad, meinem iMac, meinem MacBook. Ich kann immer hin und her schalten und ich habe immer denselben Datenbestand. Unterschiedliche Syncing-Subsysteme, unterschiedliche Ergebnisse, lalalala. Das ist alles noch nicht so das Goldene, aber es ist im Vergleich zu, du hast deine Daten immer nur auf einem Rechner. Es ist einfach enorm und ich finde, dass sie da irgendwas bringen müssen. Dass irgendeine OS-Infrastruktur da sein muss, um das einfach mal auf einen anderen Level zu holen, um einfach mehr Programmen das zu ermöglichen und vor allem nicht nur irgendwie Syncing, mit so Files auf Web-DRV-Servern, die man dann mal lesen kann und so. Ich probiere das zum Beispiel gerade mit OmniFocus aus. Ja, okay, machen die über MobileMe, haben da irgendwie eine Dateilinke und so. Aber gehst du an einen anderen Rechner, startest das Programm, da kommt auch so, ja, ich muss jetzt deine ganze Datenbank wegschmeißen und gegen das ersetzen, was auf dem Sync-Store ist. Ich denke mir so, ja, okay, I trust you, ja. Schmeiß weg, so. Das ist nicht das, was ich mit der Syncing freute. Es ist so, dieses MobileMe Syncing im Bereich Adressbuch zum Beispiel, das ist so die Granularität. Du änderst da was, speicherst das irgendwie ab, dann nehme ich irgendwie mein iPhone in die Hand, gehe in den selben Datensatz und da ist diese Information. So muss das laufen und so muss das einfach immer funktionieren. Ich denke, hier, letztes Mal haben wir ja auch schon darüber geredet, hier so Syncing, Fallsystem Syncing auf Basis von Git. So diese, diesen Grad an Hardening und Bulletproofness.
Bulletproofing. Syncing auf jeden Fall auch. Nach wie vor, also wir sind ja, das sind ja unsere heißen Themen hier sowieso seit eh und je.
Game Center bauen sie ein.
Vielleicht.
Syncing auch. Fallsystem auch.
Ja und dann ist es Mac OS, iTunes OS. Genau.
Sind wir fertig mit den sieben?
Ich ja.
Mehr, auf mehr kommen wir nicht. Wir haben irgendwie, the big point haben wir irgendwie nicht, oder? Die bauen da irgendwas entspannisches ein.
Das ist wieder typisch Apple, wir wissen mal wieder von nichts.
Einmal habe ich es geraten, das große Ding. Diesmal würde ich auch gerne raten.
Das war aber noch vor dem Krieg, oder?
Das war ein Time Machine.
Ja, das stimmt, war der Recht.
Das habe ich vorausgesagt.
Da hat er sich wahrscheinlich auch drei Tage lang gefreut.
Da freue ich mich heute noch drüber.
Aber wo er gerade hier iTunes gesagt hat, ich habe letztens festgestellt, ich habe zu Hause hier so ein, wie heißt das Ding? Firefly Media Server. Und bei dem alten iTunes war es so, dass schon, wenn du von Kabel auf WLAN gewechselt hast oder du kurz kein Netz hattest, dann hat das iTunes die ganze Liste von dem Firefly Server weggeschmissen und du musstest sie neu anwenden, neu laden und das ganze Kram und wieder auch den Song starten usw. Und das neue iTunes, wenn du da so was machst, der schmeißt dir die Liste nicht weg, sondern behält die und connectet sich neu in dem Umblick, wo du einen Song abspielen lässt. Du musst dich da nicht mehr so kümmern, das ist voll cool. Das ist ein Auto-Reconnect-Feature. Sehr praktisch.
Dieses iTunes 10 ist tatsächlich auch besser geworden. Es ist schneller geworden. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es schnell ist, aber es ist weniger langsam. Und das ist teilweise auch besser. Es sind immer noch diese absurden, modalen Dialoge, die da hochkommen. Ich mich echt frage, was das soll.
Ich wollte letztens mal wieder eine CD brennen hier. Ich hab ja meine ganze Musik als Loslist. Dann brenne ich davon auch CDs. Und da gibt es gar keinen Button mehr für. Du musst jetzt hier so einen Kontext-Click machen, damit du mal eine CD brennen kannst. Das findet doch wieder kein Schwein. Vor allem da die Mäuse von Apple keinen Kontext-Click können. Das ist eigentlich so von Hause aus. Musst du es ja erst einstellen.
I'm an iBook Flipper.
I'm an writes.
Es gibt keinen Burn-Button mehr?
Nee, ich musste da irgendwie eine Playlist machen und dann einen Kontext-Click.
Burn-Button?
Hab ich da überhaupt immer schon mal Burn... Glaubst du nicht ein Burn-Menü?
Ich hab immer auf den Burn-Button geklickt.
Burn-Playlist-to-Disc. Was ist gerade ein Burn-Button?
Rechts unten oder mal rechts oben früher.
Dieses Nuklear-Zeichen hier, so gelb, schwarz, weiß.
Aber in der letzten Version war es auch nur noch so ein rechteckiger Button.
Ja, aber jetzt ist er gar nicht mehr da. Aber es geht noch.
Die wollen weg von den Scheiben. Die wollen weg von diesem Brennen.
Das ist bei der vorigen Version auch schon aufgehört. Da sind ganz viele Sachen, die sind zwar noch da, aber jetzt alle viel versteckter, die wollen es gar nicht mehr. Auch dass man die ID3-Text ändert und da dann rumspielt, ist alles in irgendwelche kontextsensitiven Menüs gewandert.
Ich tune mich.
Erstmal ein paar LSD-Tröpfchen auf die Zunge.
Ja, ich höre.
Wir gucken hier erstmal zu, wie der Dinge ins Gesicht träumt.
Und, Kneip.
Wenn ihr Spaß dran habt, anstatt hier mal was Sinnvolles beizutragen. Ich zähl mal zu Ende, dann erzähl ich was über Apple TV.
Das war fertig jetzt mit dem iTunes, oder?
Tja, was soll man dazu auch noch sagen?
Und, ich hab's halt getwittert, ich weiß ja manchmal gar nicht, ob man Sachen nochmal erzählen soll, wenn man ja alles eigentlich schon immer getwittert hat. Dieses C01-Update hat das mit dem Firefly-Media-Server auch wieder repariert.
Also, ich hab ja ich hab gerade beide Apple-TVs zuhause im Test. Das neue hab ich mir mal geschoppt und das alte hab ich mir von Bugs geliehen. Und, naja, ich hab damit ja noch nicht so viel gemacht gehabt bisher, ist schon eine Weile her. Und es ist, es ist, ach, das ist wieder so ein trauriger Apple-Moment, muss ich sagen. Also zunächst einmal so zur Hardware. Das neue Apple-TV ist natürlich gegenüber dem alten Apple-TV geiler, ja. Also diese analogen Ausgänge, ja, das ist noch gleich Y, UV, den ganzen Kram. Gut, da mögen die Leute noch Bildschirme gehabt haben, die kein HDMI haben, aber jetzt auch voll HDMI zu setzen und diese Stecker wegzulassen, das ist definitiv sinnvoll. Das Teil ist irgendwie klein, es wird nicht mehr so heiß. Das Apple-TV war ja auch immer scheiße heiß, aber irgendwie, mal abgesehen von dem Stromverbrauch, den das vielleicht ankündigt, kann einem das ja auch irgendwie egal sein, solange es sich anfängt zu brennen.
Aber es brannte auch wohl nicht.
Also bei mir nicht. Nicht, dass ich wüsste. So, das Ding ist, dass das neue Apple-TV einfach ein anderes Gerät als das alte Apple-TV ist. Und zwar in seinem Konzept, so wie es sozusagen so kommt. Weil das Alte war nämlich im Prinzip so eine Art Standalone-Mediengerät, was sich gegenüber einem Mac auch wie ein iPod verhalten konnte. Das heißt, du konntest ja das Ding über Wireless-Syncing, das ist sozusagen das einzige Gerät, wo über WLAN ein Syncing möglich gewesen ist, was ja uns heute noch auf dem iPhone, also unter iOS versagt bleibt. Obwohl es diese Funktionalität ganz offensichtlich gibt und warum sollte es sie auch nicht geben? Ich meine, was man über USB machen kann, das kann man auch über IP machen, das ist nicht so das Problem. Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben sie das halt nie gemacht. Oder bisher noch nicht gemacht. So, das Neue. Apple TV glänzt vor allem durchs Weglassen. Du kannst da nichts mehr kaufen, was nicht verwundert, weil wir nur noch 8 GB Speicher und keine Festplatte. So, ok, da kann ja auch irgendwie noch drauf verzichten. Das heißt, wenn du was kaufen willst, musst du es halt von deinem Mac machen. Dann hast du es halt auch gleich da, wo du sozusagen dein Backup und so weiter hast. Das macht auch irgendwie total Sinn. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, wenn du jetzt so Serien, Season Passes und so ein Kram kaufst. Aber im Prinzip, du hast es dann halt auf dem Mac und kannst es dann eben per Streaming übertragen. Was ja auch in Ordnung ist, wenn die Qualität stimmt. Das Ding ist nur, dass während du bei dem alten Apple TV halt so ein iTunes rangehen konntest, wie so eine Remote, in dem du so eine Pin eingegeben hast und so ein Pairing machst, geht das jetzt halt nur noch über Homesharing. Das heißt, das muss dann eben alles Homesharing aktiv sein und muss unter einem Account laufen. Hast du jetzt in deiner Familie mehrere iTunes-Accounts, dann musst du dich sozusagen auf einen dieser Accounts...
Oder Thwaitas...
.muss sie auf einen iTunes-Account einigen mit dem alle deine Rechner Homesharing machen. Also du hast irgendwie User A, User B und das ist halt so. Wir können auch den Dennis hier noch so ein bisschen... Ein bisschen mehr expandern hier. Schön langweilig, was ich hier gerade erzähle.
Naja.
Das neue Apple TV macht irgendwie 720p. Was ich jetzt noch nicht getestet habe, ist, wie das so wirklich im Verleih so richtig läuft. Weil ich hab nämlich neulich auf dem alten Apple TV mir was leihen wollen. Hab mal so einen Film geliehen, so richtig schön hingesetzt und so. Und jetzt leihen wir uns mal was. Und jetzt gucken wir uns mal einen Film an.
Für deine Kids, die wollten wie immer König der Löwen gucken.
Nee, die sind erstens noch nicht so alt, dass ich ihnen irgendwie Spielfilme vor die Nase setze. Aber du hast halt so, wenn du so im Elterndasein bist, dann ist es einfach so eine Ressource, wie zwei Stunden am Abend mal nicht totmüde sein und Zeit haben, sich entspannt aufs Sofa zu setzen, das ist Gold wert. Und genau da, finde ich, spielt halt so ein Apple TV voll seine Kraft aus, weil du kannst dich halt kurzfristig entscheiden, was zu leihen. Ich würde da nie in die Videothek latschen. Weil bis du dann die Reise gemacht hast, ja, da ist der Slot dann auch schon wieder weg. Das ist einfach so richtig so ein Impulskauf. Das gemacht, so Impuls leihen. Und dann fängt er an, das Ding runterzuleihen. Und dann fängt er an, das Ding runterzuleihen. Und mal so, ja, jetzt ist ja schon so viel da, jetzt kannst du auch schon anfangen anzugucken. Und dann mach ich so, okay, alles klar, mach mal Play.
Das ist doch richtig so, kannst den Film aussuchen, kannst drücken, gehst in die Küche, machst wieder ein Bier klar oder Tee oder halt auch immer und suchst dir noch eine Decke für den Couch und so, machst dir da bequem und bis dahin hat er genug geladen und kannst loslegen, oder?
Theoretisch.
Zehn Minuten, 15 Minuten bis er loslegt oder?
Nö, hat noch nicht so lange gedauert, es ging relativ fix.
Echt noch schneller.
Ja, aber es war dann leider total ein Megafail, weil er mir dann erzählt hat, dass der Download, den er gerade anfing, leider schon abgelaufen ist und ich mir, das ist ja sozusagen die 30 Tage, die ich jetzt Zeit hätte, mir den anzugucken, dass die halt schon überschritten sind. Noch während er das runterlädt, erzählt er mir ernsthaft, das sei jetzt...
Gegen eine Uhr falsch und das Ding hatte vorher kein Netz?
Ich hatte sowas auch schon mal.
Das Ding hat Internet, das hat alles, was es braucht.
Und was habt ihr dann gemacht?
Ich hab dann alle möglichen Kombinationen mit, er ladet es erstmal ganz runter und spielt es dann ab und nochmal 3, 4, 5 mal neu geladen. Dieses Gerät ließ sich einfach nicht dazu überreden, den 4-Euro-Film, den er mir da geladen hat, anzuzeigen. Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen, hab aber sehr wohl eine Rechnung dafür bekommen.
Echt?
Hab mich dann beschwert, hab irgendwie gesagt, hier Report und Tralala, da ist was nicht in Ordnung und ihr habt ja wohl den Arsch offen und ich will meine 4 Euro zurück. Sonst kauf ich mir ein Windows-Rechner. Keine Reaktion.
Das haben sie mir wohl nicht geglaubt.
Echt, die haben sich nicht gemeldet?
Nein. Also ich muss sagen, an der Stelle total unappeliges, mega schlechtes Service-Ding. Funktioniert nicht, berechnet und dann auch noch keine Response, keine Gutschrift, nichts. Das ist jetzt irgendwie schon zwei Wochen her. Fail. Ganz groß, ganz groß von links nach rechts drüber geschritten. Also ich weiß auch nicht, was ich davon halten soll und es hat mich so sehr schockiert, dass ich mich jetzt noch nicht mal getraut habe, nochmal so einen zweiten Leihvorgang anzustoßen. Weiß ich nicht, aber es sind ja auch immer wieder 4-5 Euro. Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock hier irgendwie 100 Euro zu lassen, nur um festzustellen, dass es überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Gut, ich werde es jetzt mal mit diesem neuen Apple TV ausprobieren. So, was ist jetzt das Blöde da dran? Das Blöde an dem neuen Apple TV ist, dass das Teil ohne einen Computer keinen Sinn macht. Und da sind wir wieder genauso wie bei dem iPad, was auch ohne einen Computer keinen Sinn macht, weil du kannst es nicht in Betrieb nehmen. Und auch dieses neue Apple TV taugt sozusagen ausschließlich dazu, dir Filme auszuleihen. Was ja in Ordnung wäre, wenn es funktionieren würde. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es meistens funktioniert. Oder wenn zumindest die Auswahl okay wäre. Aber die Filme, die du da kriegst, das ist einfach so wenig und so viel schäbiges Zeug. Ich weiß, dass es nicht an Apple liegt und dass Apple das sehr gerne tun würde. Nur das ist sozusagen die Realität dieser ganzen Online-Geschichte. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, ich will jetzt diesen Film gucken.
Und ich will diesen Film in Englisch gucken.
Genau.
Was auch noch so ein Problem ist.
Ich erzähl das ja auch schon seit drei Podcasts. Genau diese Sachen. Na ja, Filme scheiße bei iTunes Store. Du hast dir wahrscheinlich noch nie einen Film ausgeliehen.
Ich hab auch noch nie Musik bei Apple gekauft.
Ich schon. Nämlich seit es dieses tolle Programm namens Fischen gibt.
Da können wir gleich drüber reden. Wenn ich das iPad mit der neuen Beta-Software schon ausprobiert hätte, dann hätte ich festgestellt, dass es nicht funktioniert mit dem Airplay.
Mit der Beta.
Ja, das ist derzeit alles neu.
Aber da gibt es nur Leute, die haben festgestellt, dass es funktioniert.
Wirklich?
Also Leute, googeln in das V-Chat und finden da nur diese blöde Mac OS ab zum Video-Telefonieren.
Ich glaube, letztes Mal hatten wir hier jemanden, der gesagt hat, es geht.
Ich hab das mit dem Apple TV nicht hinbekommen. Vielleicht wird sich das auch bald bessern. Also ich meine, okay, das können sie ja wohl nicht ankündigen, dass es irgendwie nicht geht. Ich meine, ja, momentan Audio-Only-Schratt. Das heißt, es geht nicht. Das ist doch das, was ich meine. Wenn sie da so einen Film abspielen und ein Audio war auch irgendwie mit Delay und so ein bisschen war fishy. Also das ist alles noch im Werden. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was Sache ist. So Medien, Fischen.
Fischen.
Fischen, jetzt kommt übrigens ein Hacker-Trick. Da war ich ja echt erstaunt. Da hab ich ja geguckt.
Ja, also Fischen ist erstmal so ein Programm von Rogue Amoeba, die auch schon Airfoil und andere tolle, nützliche Tools bauen. Und das Fischen ist ein Tool, um... F-I-S-S-I-O-N. Um verlustfrei AAC-Files zu editieren und zu schneiden und so weiter. Und MP3. Und MP3 auch. Ja, also so ein Stapel. Aber es ist halt der einzige, der AAC auch lossless kann. Also die anderen Tools können wir alle nicht. MP4, AAC, Foo. So, und jetzt hat das Programm halt einen richtig blöden Nachteil, sozusagen. Wenn du dir jetzt nämlich Musik aus dem Store kaufst und dann so einen Track aus dem Store mit deinem DM Watermark editierst. Nee, aber mit Watermark. Also da steht ja drin Purchased by Tim Pritlav und so weiter. So, und wenn du jetzt mit Fischen dieses File editierst und dann wieder abspeicherst, dann ist diese Information leider weg.
Oh, wirklich? Das ist ja scheiße.
Wie leider.
Na ja, also da hast du dir jetzt deine Musik gekauft und da steht jetzt dein Name drin. Da ist man doch stolz drauf. Da ist man doch stolz drauf, ja.
Wenn du jetzt diese Musik weiter gibst an deine Freunde, dann können die ja, wenn die in die Metadaten schauen, gar nicht mehr feststellen, dass sie das von dir haben. Das ist doch traurig.
Es geht aber nicht, es geht nur mit den Plus-Dateien aus dem iTunes, oder? Mit denen, die kein DM haben, sondern wo nur der Name drin steht.
Aber mich wundert das ja so ein bisschen, weil dieses Fischen ja eigentlich angetreten ist, sozusagen die Datei verlustfrei zu bearbeiten.
Da ist dir wohl ein Fehler unterlassen. Genau, aber...
Aber wartet, wartet, wartet, aus dem Store gibt es doch gar keinen Losless.
Was? Nein, also wenn du sonst MP3 oder sowas editierst oder so eine Files, dann macht er den Output wieder sozusagen nochmal encoded. Also du kannst halt... Also es gibt halt Tools, wo du nicht diesen komprimierten Scheiß editieren kannst. So und den kannst du da editieren, ohne dass er dann nochmal neu encoden muss.
Also das benutze ich immer wieder mal. Was ich finde, so MP3-Mitschnitte hast von Livesendungen, wo noch der Anfang und das Ende, was nicht dazugehört, dann kannst du halt einfach in Fischen reingehen. Du kannst es nicht nur abschneiden, du kannst es auch richtig Einglendungen, Ausblendungen, Überblendungen, Crossfades und so weiter machen. Das ist alles sehr elegant. Und das ist eine gute Software. Ich hatte da nur einen Crash mal mit. Das war gleich nachdem ich es gekauft habe, der erste Start und so. Und seitdem arbeitet das irgendwie total.
Ja, die machen auch gute Updates da. Ich hatte das schon ein paar Mal so in der Trial-Version mir gegeben und dann letztes Mal wollte ich Musik kaufen, die es nur im Store gab bei iTunes in der besten Qualität zu sagen. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, Gimmie. Und dann wollte ich die natürlich auch ein bisschen bearbeiten und habe die das dann mit Fischen gemacht und hab dann den Verlust des Watermarks in Kauf genommen.
Also Rock Amoeba ist ja eine tolle Bude, muss auch sagen, ich finde die ganz toll. Hab ich aber glaube ich schon fünf Mal erzählt. Ich glaube, es gibt keine Company, von der ich so viele Programme gekauft habe. Mal kurz mal schauen. Eins, zwei, drei, vier. Genau, die haben sechs.
Das ist auch von denen, ja?
Ja, die haben sechs kommerzielle Programme und davon habe ich vier gekauft.
Also ich muss sagen, Airfoil und dieses Audio Hijack Pro, die finde ich auch cool. Ja, ich habe mir zwar noch nicht gekauft, aber das sind so die, von denen ich mir am ehesten aufkomme.
Genau, und diese Sendung wird ihnen gerade live über das Internet gesendet mit einem weiteren Produkt von Rock Amoeba, nämlich Nicecast. Das ist nämlich überhaupt der einzige MP3-Streamer, den es eigentlich gibt auf dem Mac. Was ein echtes Problem ist, leider tun sie da nichts mehr dran. Ich habe den schon mal geschrieben, was denn so wer und so, aber es gibt alle Juliare mal ein Update, wenn so ihre Extensions sich geändert haben, diese noch gerne optional dazu installieren, um da irgendwie Hijacking zu machen. Aber leider tut sich da wenig und es ist auch ein bisschen featurearm. Ich meine, es funktioniert sehr stabil und gut und tut erst mal so das, was es sagt, aber es müsste halt mehr können.
Da frage ich mich also wieso, ist das nicht, was zum Beispiel QuickTime Broadcaster lösen sollte, so ein Problem, oder ist das, ein Icecast ist so ein eigenes Protokoll, oder was ist da?
Nein, Icecast ist einfach nur das Programm und es macht halt das, was Icecast macht. Also es macht halt MP3 über HTTP einfach Connection auf MP3 rüber, fertig, auf der Tod. Ohne viel Voodoo. QuickTime Broadcaster macht halt diesen ganzen RTSP-Wahnsinn und so weiter, so richtige Streaming-Protokollen, das ist ja alles sehr ehrenhaft, plus es benutzt halt kein Schwein, weil das irgendwie alles viel zu kompliziert ist. Deswegen geht ja Apple jetzt auch selbst beim Streaming auf HTTP, auch dieser ganze Airplay-Kram, das ist halt alles HTTP-Streaming. Und es ist einfach schade, dass es nichts anderes gibt. Ja, also erstmal ist es schade, dass man nur MP3 sozusagen machen kann, es ist schade, dass man da auch diese ganzen Meta-Informationen nicht alle setzen kann. Zum Beispiel gibt es da so ein Public-Flag, was ich gerne an- und ausschalten würde, weil das hier bei Xenim irgendwie eine Rolle spielt. Da ist ja sozusagen jetzt hier nur für mich eine Anpassung vorgenommen worden, weil ich das halt verwende. Weil wenn man da das Public-Flag anschaltet, dann posten sie sozusagen das gleiche in ihrem bekloppten Streamverzeichnis. Das ist immer so diese Illusion, dass Streaming immer gleich bedeutet, dass man 24 Stunden Internet-Audio- Musik-Radiosender macht.
Also hier wird gerade im Chat ja von der Firma Kawauso, was offensichtlich japanisch ist, wenn man auf die Webseite geht, Laudio-Cast, Ladiocast empfohlen. Aber Ladiocast ist in Asien.
Das ist eine Verarschung, Mann.
Echt?
Na, Ladi-O?
Nee, es gibt's echt. Ist hier bei Apple auf der Seite sogar gefeaturet.
Ladi-O wie Radio?
Ja, ist halt weil Asiaten wahrscheinlich. Aber das Programm gibt's hier, ja, tatsächlich.
Audio Mixing, Ask Us To, Source, Klein Software. Oh, Don't Make Internet, Audio Stream.
Ja, aber die Webseite sieht so ein bisschen.
Ladi-O. Ah, sehr gut. Macht sogar H-I-A-A-C. Schicko, okay, davon wusste ich noch nicht.
Ich dachte, das ist Verarsche. Ach, der hat es ja andersrum gemacht.
Version 0.9.2 ist ja immer sehr vertrauenserweckend. Trauen die sich nicht, mal eine 1.0 zu releasen?
Ja, das ist schlimm, oder?
Ist doch Fallkeit vor dem Kunden.
Ladiocast.
Man lernt nie aus. Gibt es das schon lange?
Naja.
It's live in der Sendung am besten switchen. Ja, gut, also wir haben auf jeden Fall jetzt Fischen auch mal erwähnt. Ein bisschen in den Audio-Sorte hinfischen.
Der Chat wird anspruchsvoll hier, ich soll mich bedanken.
Was sagt die Liste?
Die Liste sagt, dass ich... Moment, mir fällt an dieser Stelle etwas ein, was gerade passt. Vielleicht weiß ja der Chat da auch schon Rat, ich glaube es gibt keine Lösung, aber ich dachte mir, ich spreche das hier mal an. Und zwar ist das so ein grundsätzliches Problem, das ich hier habe mit Macintosh-Audio-Devices. Auf dem Mac kann ja jedes Audio-Device mehrere Kanäle haben. Und so ein normaler Audio-Port hat halt zwei. Links, rechts Stereo. Das heißt, das ist Kanal 1 und Kanal 2. Aber wenn du jetzt so ein Firewire-USB-Interface anschließt, oder ich hier mit meinem IP-basierten Teil, dann hat halt so ein Audio-Device eben auch mal mehr. 10, 16, 20, 30. Je nachdem, wie viele Stecker da rein und rausgehen. Dann hast du nochmal ADAT, kommt nochmal 8er zu. Es können halt einfach sehr viele sein. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass man, wenn man so ein Interface hat, was eben mehrere Ports hat, dass man gerne eben die einen Ports für das eine, die anderen Ports für das andere verwenden würde. Jetzt gibt es aber extrem viele Programme auf dem Mac, die keine Vorstellungen davon haben, dass ein Audiodevice mehr als zwei Kanäle hat. Du kannst da mal den Audiokanal auswählen, aber er nimmt sozusagen immer nur Kanal 1 und 2 und nicht etwa 3 und 4, 5 und 6 oder was auch immer. Ein paar können das. Meistens die, die sowieso schon sehr in dieser ganzen Audiowelt irgendwie mit drinstecken. Aber sowas wie Skype zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt mein konkretes Problem, wo ich sagen würde, ja, Skype, benutze du doch mal hier Kanal 7 und 8 von diesem Audiodevice für deinen Output und Input, bitte auch 7 und 8 oder 9 und 10.
Du willst virtuelle Audiodevices.
Genau, ich will ein virtuelles Audiodevice. Es gibt ja auch noch schlimmere Programme wie iTunes zum Beispiel, wo man überhaupt keinen Audioport einstellen kann, sondern wo man nur die Möglichkeit hat, über den default Systembus zu spielen. Was auch wirklich mal, da mach ich noch nicht mal hall an. Ja, ich meine, was soll denn das bitte? Und ein Audioprogramm, wo man auch nicht mal sagen kann, wohin.
Aber ist das nicht so...
Ich reg mich auf. So, jetzt hab ich überlegt, jetzt gibt es ja, es gibt ja so virtuelle Geschichten. Erstmal gibt es in Meco S10 dieses Aggregate Device. Klingt jetzt erstmal ganz toll, hilft aber überhaupt nicht weiter, weil alles, was du damit tun kannst, ist, du kannst zwei Soundtreiber nehmen und zu einem zusammenführen. Du kannst aber nämlich bestimmte Kanäle rausnehmen und andere drin lassen. Oder überhaupt irgendwie flexibel die Reihenfolge von irgendwas einstellen, sondern kannst nur den einen oder den anderen nehmen, du kannst die in eine Reihenfolge bringen. Und dann nimmt er halt alle Kanäle von dem ersten und dann alle Kanäle von dem zweiten und so weiter. Das heißt, du kannst da eigentlich dieses Problem nicht mit lösen. Dann gibt es sowas wie Soundflower. Was so eine ganz einfache, kleine Open Source-Geschichte ist. Das macht, da kannst du so einen Textfall editieren und damit schaffst du dir so virtuelle Sounddevices. Wenn du da draufschreibst, mit einem anderen Programm davon lesen kannst und du kriegst halt gelesen, was der andere draufschreibt. Also wenn du irgendwie mit Programm XY auf Sounddevice sowieso recordest und ein anderes schreibt da drauf, dann schreibst du sozusagen direkt in dieses Programm rein. Das ist auch ganz super für viele Fälle, aber das ist halt vor allem für dieses, ich will abgreifen, ich will mich irgendwo als Input hinein indizieren und du kannst da auch Devices machen mit mehr als zwei Kanälen. Aber was du halt nicht machen kannst, ist, dass du so ein Sounddevice machst, so ein virtuelles, wo du sagst, Kanal 1 und 2 sind der und der Kanal von dem Device und Kanal 3 und 4 sind der und der Kanal von dem Device. Ich weiß, dass es auch nicht ganz einfach ist, weil, wenn du jetzt mehrere Sounddevices aggregieren willst, dann rennst du in diese Problematik mit Timing. Weil du hast dann unterschiedliche Clocks und so. Das heißt, das wird auch so einfach nicht machbar sein. Aber ich wär schon ganz zufrieden, wenn ich nur so einen virtuellen Soundtreiber hätte, der einfach nichts anderes macht als ich bin Kanal 7 und 8 von dem anderen Device. Der sich sozusagen einfach als Kanal Skype Out, also als Soundtreiber Skype Out installiert, ist aber tatsächlich von meinem Firewire Device Kanal 7 und 8 und reroutet das einfach dahin. Mehr nicht. Große Frage. Gibt's sowas schon? Kann das jemand mal hacken, bitteschön?
Jack OS X wird hier gerade genannt.
Also meines, also last time I checked, ist Jack irgendwie so eine ganz eigene Welt, die jetzt sich nicht auf Systemebene abspielt. Also meines Wissens kann es das nicht. Aber ich darf mich auch gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Also wir rufen jetzt sozusagen nach...
Tim Thet.
Galactica.
Meine V has sich schon wieder desyncht. Ich wollte doch.
Du wolltest mal was für Entwickler machen?
Nee, ich wollte sagen, wir brauchen Entwickler dafür.
Ja, jetzt können wir auch zu Microsoft kommen, wenn du das Thema schon ansprichst.
Aber ich wollte doch gar nicht.
Sondern? Was wolltest du denn machen? Wir können uns doch weiter über Hardware unterhalten oder über Fallsysteme? Erklär doch mal diese Sachen mit diesem Trim.
Ja, mache ich, aber ganz vies. Vorher schieben wir noch eine Runde ZFS rein. Da gibt es nämlich Breaking News.
Ah, das ZFS-Update. Für ZFS muss man so noch so einen eigenen Jingle machen.
Irgendwas, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da Audio gibt. Jedenfalls bei ZFS, da wurde der Crypto Support committed letztens. Das heißt, die bei Oracle für Solaris, keine Ahnung, 11 oder was auch immer da demnächst kommen sollte, wird es das geben. Und irgendwann rutscht auch der Source raus, weil die haben ja so ein bisschen ihren Source-Release da geändert, glaube ich. Aber irgendwann tun sie den wohl raus. Vielleicht ein bisschen Verzögerung. Das heißt, der kommt dann auch bei den Open Source-Typis an. Linux macht ja inzwischen auch auf ZFS. Und dann gibt es Native Crypto-Support. Da braucht man sich nicht so eine Crypto-Block-Devices unten drunter machen, so eine virtuellen, sondern da macht das ZFS das selbst. Das ist voll toll.
Was für ein Crypto kann man da einschalten?
Ich denke, weiß gar nicht, ob die da verschiedene Sachen...
Wird mich nicht überraschen. Ich meine, braucht man noch mehr? Eigentlich nicht.
Also die hatten eine AIS 128, 192 und 256.
Und gibt's da auch so Performance-Angaben, was das so frisst?
Nee, ich hab noch nicht so richtig was gesehen. Ich hab letztens so einen Artikel gesehen, aber da stand irgendwie so was von, wenn du einen richtig schnellen Rechner hast, dann macht sie es eigentlich nicht bemerkbar. Das kann ich nicht so richtig glauben, deswegen kann ich das...
Bei normalen Festplatten.
Ja, wenn du da so einen Super-Rate hast und ich hab schon Leute gesehen, die mit einem Gigabyte pro Sekunde wegschreiben. Also da sind ja diese Foren, wo da Leute aus Firmen sind, die was weiß ich nicht, da für Storage-Systeme haben, die schreiben mit einem Gigabyte die Sekunde weg. Und da schaffst du es auch nicht, das so schnell... Obwohl, wenn du keine Ahnung noch so einen 16 oder 32 Core-System da am Start hast, dann können die parallel die Blöcke wegkoden. Das kann schon sein.
Das ist ein sehr parallelisierbarer Vorgang.
Weil hier Checksumming hier so mit Hash, mit MD5 und Zeug oder Ch1, was die da machen, das machen die ja schon. Und das funktioniert ja auch. Und außerdem gibt es noch Krypto-Hardware. Das heißt, wenn der Key erst mal generiert ist, weil das ist ja immer so eine teure Sache, dann ist AES selbst, wenn es die Hardware macht, das flutscht ja wie Sau. Und das wird glaube ich bei Solaris auch supportet, diese Krypto-Hardware.
Es gibt ein ebliches in den i7 AES Hardware Acceleration drin.
Ja, die haben da irgendwelche Kommandos für AES eingefügt, die da möglichst gebraucht werden.
Zum schneller decrypten vor allen Dingen.
Ja, das sind die ZFS News.
Das waren echt News. Dann machen wir doch gleich weiter hier mit dem Trim-Kram.
So jetzt trimmen, okay.
Das letzte Mal hatten wir das auch angesprochen. Ich hab das alles nicht verfolgt. Können wir vielleicht nochmal kurz diese Problemlage erklären? Wir haben jetzt irgendwie SSDs. Was ist das Problem und warum gibt's keins?
SSDs haben hier Flash. Und so, die sind so aufgebaut, dass die können da nicht einfach so drüber schreiben, sondern man muss sich das fast so ein bisschen wie bei, wie früher auch schon, wie bei so einem Eprom. Man muss die erstmal löschen und dann schreibt man rein. Dieser Löschvorgang, der dauert ein bisschen. So, damit aber dein Fallsystem nicht, also dein Datelesen nicht voll langsam ist, und Flashs wissen wir ja, dass die nicht langsam sind, also auch beim Schreiben nicht, werden die vorgelöscht. So, jetzt ist aber die Sache, du schreibst da irgendwie deine Platte voll mit Daten und mit Musik, hast irgendwie die 100% voll, und dann löscht du die Hälfte wieder, weil war irgendwie doch Schrott und willst wieder voll schreiben, dann weiß der Controller in diesem Flash nicht, dass diese Blöcke mit den alten Daten, dass du die eigentlich gelöscht hast, weil heutzutage wird ja nicht gelöscht, indem da wieder was überschrieben wird oder so, sondern es wird ja nur das... Liegen gelassen. Das wird liegen gelassen und das Bit, was anzeigt, ob der Block in Benutzung ist oder nicht, das wird geändert. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie hieß denn dieses... die Bitmap, genau. Da wird irgendwie das gesetzt. Davon weiß aber diese Hardware überhaupt gar nichts, weil die hat kein Verständnis von Filesystemen und HFS oder irgendeinen anderen, die wissen das einfach nicht.
Und dafür gab es dieses Trim Instruction.
Und dafür gibt es dieses Trim Instruction.
Das kann...
also Trim ist halt so ein SATA-Command, glaube ich, auf SATA-Ebene. Der sagt dann dem Controller hier folgenden Block, den haben wir gelöscht, du kannst den schon mal vordelieten, damit, wenn wir den wieder beschreiben wollen, damit es flott geht, dann weiß er schon mal Bescheid, das nennt sich halt Trim. Und den haben die, keine Ahnung, vor ein paar Jahren eingeführt, hat ja alles eine Weile gedauert und so, weil das war halt ein Problem. Und ich glaube, bei Windows, Vista oder das danach, hier 7 wird ja auch unterstützt, bei Mac OS überhaupt gar nicht, bei Linux weiß ich nicht und bei FreeBSD haben sie ihn vor einer Weile eingebaut. So, deswegen könnte man jetzt sagen, Trim ist eigentlich eine voll tolle Sache und ist eigentlich auch eine voll tolle Sache. Aber, erstens gibt es ihn auch urständlich, da sind wir wieder beim Stich, wo wir vorher waren, dass Apple halt die Sache einfach mal aussitzt und so wie es aussieht, haben sie Glück gehabt, weil die modernen Controller heutzutage, die machen das ein bisschen anders. Und zwar haben die, ich schuße das jetzt mal so grob zusammen, die haben 10% mehr an Blöcken, als die eigentlich angeben, dass sie die hätten. Also wenn du so einen, keine Ahnung, 50 Gigabyte Flash hast, dann haben die in Wirklichkeit halt noch 5 Gigabyte da so hintenrum liegen, wo nur der Controller von weiß.
Das sind dann die, die 120 Gigabyte und nicht 128 haben. Naja, diese Intel-Platten, die haben ja keine 2 hoch irgendwas Größen.
Das könnte sein, aber das machen die auch, weil da welche kaputt gehen. Auf jeden Fall haben die halt so Reserveblöcke. So und die werden von dem Controller dafür benutzt, dass wenn du jetzt ganz normal, du hast da deine Files drauf und du, also auf belegte Blöcke und du schreibst was Neues drüber, also das Filesystem dazu, Filesystem-mäßig betrachtet. Sag mal, du hast da Block 500, da ist schon was gewesen und du schreibst noch mal was oben drüber. Dann macht der Controller das jetzt so, dass er diesen Block in Wirklichkeit woanders hinschreibt, nämlich einer, der schon leer war. Aber er weiß, du wolltest eigentlich auf Block 500 schreiben.
Also ist der leer.
Also ist der leer. Also er merkt sich das sozusagen von selbst, indem er immer die alle woanders hinschreibt und aber weiß, wo du drüber schreiben wolltest und dadurch weiß, dass es definitiv jetzt gelöscht ist. Weil eigentlich hast du den ja überschrieben. Also ist der alte weg.
Verstehe.
Und so machen die das jetzt. Also der Controller denkt halt einfach ein bisschen mit. Und deswegen brauchen wir diese Stream-Commandone nicht mehr. Das können aber wohl nur so die neuesten Festmatt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was immer so Wikipedia-Artikel und die ganzen Reviews, die man so liest, was die halt unter neu bezeichnen. Weil dann müsste man immer noch das Datum des Artikels irgendwie alles noch im Kopf haben. Aber ich denke mal so...
Gibt es einen Namen für dieses Feature? Also so für dieses Bereithalten. Ich meine, es klingt total sinnvoll, jetzt wo du das sagst.
Ja, ist auch eigentlich nicht so schwer.
Nö.
Aber Feature, also ich hab da keinen Marketing-Namen von gelesen, so. Aber so wird es heutzutage gelöst. Und es ist eh so, dass halt, seitdem die SSDs so rausgekommen sind, am Anfang waren die Kontrollen halt alle relativ lahm und waren nicht so cool. Also bei so einem Flash zum Beispiel, man sollte nicht, sagen wir mal, du hast da so eine Art, keine Ahnung, so eine Status-Datei für irgendein Tool, das das Tool immer wegschreibt, keine Ahnung, deine Position oder irgendein Scheiß, was immer in die gleiche Datei geschrieben wird. Und ZFS hat ja Copy-on-Write, also die schreiben ja nie oben drüber, aber normale Fallsystems, die schreiben auch wirklich immer über die Datei, über den gleichen Blog drüber, dann wär der Blog bei einem Flash, der wär irgendwann im Arsch, weil du darfst halt da nicht Millionen mal drüber schreiben. Und die moderneren Kontrollen haben dann eingeführt zu dieser Art Rear Leveling. Die haben halt die Blöcken immer wieder woanders hingeschrieben, damit es möglichst verteilt wird, über den ganzen Flash-Disc, damit die halt nicht so schnell kaputt geht. Das machen die inzwischen schon auch sehr gut und deswegen hat man halt so Probleme nicht mehr, dass da so schnell ein Blog kaputt geht. Also USB-Sticks und so, die machen sowas nicht, die sind halt einfach ganz blöd und schreiben immer über die gleiche Stelle, aber diese moderneren SSDs, die man so richtig zum Booten nimmt, die machen sowas. Und die moderneren Controller, die haben halt dann auch dieses Feature, dass das Trimmen nicht mehr so nötig ist.
Die moderneren, was auch immer irgendwie...
Was auch immer moderner ist, da muss man halt mal irgendwie gucken, aber so ist es halt.
The latest and the greatest.
Ich meine, wir regen uns ja mal auf, dass sie halt mit diesen komischen Buzzernames kommen, mit dem ganzen Marketing, Foo, Bar und Shit und wasse nicht, alles irgendwie, hier weiß ich schon, Vier Welt, Tier, Technik und so. Und wenn sie es nicht machen, dann fehlt es auch gleich, weil man ja über sein Produkt schon wissen will, was die nun schon so viele Features haben und was nicht. Ah ja, das ist das zu dem Tramp-Kommando.
Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich mal rauskriegen, welche Platten das jetzt wirklich betrifft und wie dieses Feature heißt. Und wir wissen das jetzt gerade mal nicht.
Wir wissen das jetzt gerade mal nicht.
Eure Gelegenheit in den Kommentaren aktiv beizutragen zur Wissensvermehrung. Genau, das wollte ich auch sagen. Ich frage mich natürlich, ob meine Krusche Reel SSD schon so ein Feature hat.
Na, das sind ihre Krusche. Wenn die Platte voll ist, also die SSD, dann sind ja alle Blöcke beschrieben und der Controller kann dann sozusagen nicht mehr sofort auf so einen Block schreiben. Wenn es dann langsamer wird, dann hat er das Feature nicht. Ganz einfach.
Also mach mal deine Platte voll.
Dann musst du nämlich ein Reformat machen, der Platte sagen, ist alles wieder leer, dann kannst du wieder loslegen und das alles schicken.
Gibt es nicht einfach so ein Trim-Tool, was man starten kann, was einfach mal durch die Bitmap durchgeht und der Platte sagt, hier ist alles leer?
Das gab's irgendwie. Da haben mich ja per Twitter auch alle gefragt, wie dieses Ding denn nun heißt. Und dann hab ich aber per Wikipedia herausgefunden, dass man es ja nicht mehr braucht. Und keine Ahnung. Ich hab halt kein Flag.
Garbage Collection ist dein Name, behauptet der Chat.
Ja, das wird umgangssprachlich so genannt, aber ob das in der Bewerbung dieser Produkte auch benutzt wird, weiß ich nicht. Hab ich nicht gesehen bisher.
Entfernt unnötige Dateien automatisch. Ohne, dass du sie vorher löschen musst.
Mit praktischem Gummiband.
Okay, Garbage Collection, könnte Sinn machen, das so zu nennen.
Ja doch, dieses Disk-Tool, so hieß es genau. Ich glaube, ich hab das Tool auch einmal verlinkt per Twitter.
Disk-Tools?
Ja, das heißt irgendwie so, glaube ich. Ich hatte gar keinen Flash, weil gerade einer fragte. Mir ist das immer noch alles zu teuer. Und wenn ich sehe, was die da kosten, ich will mir ja nicht so einen billigen SSD kaufen, sondern ich würde mir halt hier den geilen Scheiß kaufen. Und da zahlst du locker für, keine Ahnung, 160 Gigabyte 600 Euro. Sodass du in beide Richtungen 250 MB die Sekunde hast, sonst ist mir zu teuer, da warte ich noch.
79,99 Dollar, da kriege ich ja schon eine SSD für.
Naja, 16 Gigabyte.
Worauf ich noch hingewiesen wurde in dem Zusammenhang von einem Hörer, die Größe. Es gibt ja auch so Platten, die haben so 4 Gigabyte oder andere Größen an Cache mit drin.
Habe ich auch drüber gelesen, das sind diese Hybrid-Discs.
Von Samsung gibt es zum Beispiel welche.
Und C-Gate.
Ja, aber langsam, langsam hast du, was ich herausgefunden habe ist, dass sie es 2007 mal so ein bisschen probiert haben. Und die meisten haben es aber wieder aufgegeben, weil es war irgendwie in den Schuss und in den Ofen.
Aber ich habe gelesen, dass jetzt zum Beispiel diese C-Gate-Modelle schon irgendwie sozusagen so einen guten Kompromiss zwischen...
Ja, du musst immer auf das Datum von diesem Artikel gucken.
Der war von kürzlich.
Also mir ist jetzt von ganz guten Ergebnissen berichtet worden, die jetzt vielleicht nicht auch ein paar sind mit einer vollwertigen SST. Das hängt ja auch so ein bisschen davon ab, wie du arbeitest. Ich meine, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass du so viel, wenn du 4 GB im Cache hast, ein SSD. So, dann hängt es so ein bisschen davon ab. Ich meine, alles, was du regelmäßig startest, bist du an einer bestimmten Größe, passt da vielleicht noch komplett rein. Wenn du natürlich regelmäßig so viele Dinge startest, dass mehr als 4 GB bewegt werden, immer, dann mag das schon nicht mehr ganz so effizient sein. Aber ist das wirklich so? Ich meine, so Programme und so, die mögen fett auf der Platte liegen, aber das heißt nicht, dass beim Start wirklich alle Ressourcen auch gelesen werden. Auch dein Mail-Programm, das macht irgendwie erstmal den Index auf. So, der liegt dann im Cache, aber nicht die ganzen Mails.
Ja, aber ich meine, du hast ja auch einfach, du hast ja nicht vergessen, dass bei der SSD auch constant Read-Speed und constant Write-Speed einfach extrem viel höher ist, als bei einer Notebook-Platte jetzt.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass das jetzt toller ist als eine SSD, aber es ist ein guter Kompromiss. Du musst nicht dein Laufwerk ausbauen, um eine SSD zu haben, hast aber trotzdem noch diese Kapazität. Du kannst dir eine 500 GB Platte kaufen, die quasi mit deinem Subset von Sachen, mit denen du häufig arbeitest, einfach schnell ran, an den Start kommt, weil das einfach immer im Cache liegt.
Wahrscheinlich werden die ja eh noch größer mit 16 GB und 32 GB Flash-Sensor in der nächsten Zeit noch.
Theoretisch verspricht das ja auch eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Platte so sich mal häufiger schlafen legt. Wobei ich jetzt heute nochmal mit jemandem gesprochen habe, der meint so, kann ich nicht feststellen. Und dann sind das auch gleich wieder 7200er Platten, die sind dann auch gleich lauter. Also wie man es dreht und wendet.
Man will SSDs.
Genau.
Terabyte-SSDs in ein Notebook.
Es wird aber hier nochmal ein anderes Tool genannt. Nicht Disk-Tools, sondern Disk-Tester.
Hier irgendeins davon habe ich getwittert. Aber ich habe ja noch mal keine SSD.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Immer noch nicht.
Recondition-Command brings your solid state drive SSD-Backup in Performance. Recondition-Command.
Na ja, der geht halt in diese Bitmap, guckt an, welche Blöcke belegt sind und welche nicht. Und die, die nicht belegt sind, trümmt, dann weggetrümmt. Genau.
Hier Digiloid-Tools, Disk-Tester. Was kostet das? Kostet das auch 80 Dollar?
Buy-and-Down-Mode.
Ist eine 64-Bit-Applikation.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Ja, 40 Dollar, wird ja immer billiger. Der bietet 20. Hier meint einer, seine Platte geht wirklich schlafen, der hat wohl so eine Platte.
Ich hab mal geguckt nach diesem Hybrid-Tools und ich fand's eigentlich auch ganz gut ab. Ich hab aber irgendwie nur Reports von 2007 gefunden.
Ah, ich höre, hier ist auch noch ein toller Link, der mir sagt, dass meine Real SSD meine C300 Platte Garbage Collection hat. Es geht alles über das Internet. Oh, es geht alles über das Internet!
Wir haben übrigens immer noch nicht 500 Game Center Friends, wollte ich an dieser Stelle sagen.
So viele Hörer haben wir auch gar nicht.
Was?
Wie?
Ach so, Live-Hörer meinste. Ja, aber später, also, Jungs, wenn die Sendung rauskommt, da klickt das schon ganz schön, wenn ich finde, diese Leute, die nicht live hören, die sind nicht so richtig mit bei der Sache. Also ich finde, die könnten mal... Nee, wirklich.
Die Leute live hören sind aber auch nicht so mit bei der Sache hier.
Doch, doch, also als wir das hier live angekündigt haben, da hat das hier geklingelt beim Gänsehund.
Stimmt.
War am ersten Tag gleich 50 Leute. Also es ging ab wie nix. So Podcast-mäßig, so runterladensmäßig, haben wir doch viel mehr Hörer. Zehnfach, zwanzigfach, irgendwie so. Das heißt, es müsste zehn- oder zwanzigfach mehr klingeln auf meinem Phone. Und da ist nicht so wirklich viel passiert.
Ich hab ja noch einen Zweite Hall.
Das ist so das Modell Klo. In die Kloschüssel direkt reinsprechen.
Eigentlich müsste man das hier mit der Wiimote, mit Bewegung machen. Umso mehr man das Ding bewegt, umso mehr heilt.
Jetzt wo dein Studio nicht mehr so heilt, gibt es den Software-Hall.
Das könnte ich sogar machen, fällt mir dabei ein.
Jetzt wo dein Studio nicht mehr so heilt, gibt es den Software-Hall auf Tastenbrock.
Ja, so ist das. Erst wenn man keinen Hall im Raum hat, kann man selbst Hall machen. Deswegen, ne? Man soll mir das Mikrofon wegnehmen, ich sabbel komisches Zeug. Leute, das wusste ich aber auch schon vorher. Deswegen macht er doch die Podcast. Ja, genau. Man kann aber behaupten, er wäre nicht gewarnt worden. Thema!
Technik.
Ich hab vorhin nicht in den Chat geguckt, als ich von diesem Treiber geredet habe. Vielleicht gab es ja schon eine Antwort.
Also hier gibt es wirklich diese Hybridplatten aktuell.
Diese ganze Trim-Diskussion ist sozusagen Bogus.
Inzwischen schon.
Womit wollen wir weitermachen?
Guckst du auf die Liste, Mann.
Ja, ich hab da viel auf der Liste.
Guckst du auf Liste?
Vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Hardware, wo wir so hier bei Hardware sind. Ich hab die Tage hier beim Hörerstammtisch, den es ja hier immer gibt, einmal im Monat. Also nicht vom Bobamex, sondern von CHE, aber da kann eigentlich auch jeder kommen.
Na?
Ein Kindl 3 gesehen.
Chris Kindl 3?
Das kann nur einen geben. Chris Kindl 3.
Oder Berliner Kindl.
Amazon Kindl.
Krieg ich noch einen hin?
Dennis.
Sag mir nicht, dass du nicht weißt, wovon ich rede. Bist du auch so ein E-Booker?
Was?
Ach so. Bist ja nicht schrammenlos vorbeigegangen. Auf jeden Fall ist das dieses Gerät, was jetzt gemeinhin so als der iPod des Lesens bezeichnet wird. Wo auch was dran ist. Ich muss auch sagen, also Kindle 3, Kindle 3 in dieser Leder-Tasche mit Lämpchen.
Leder-Tasche mit Lämpchen? Ich hab das, verfolge das nicht, will diese I irgendwie da nicht.
Ich hab das nämlich auch nicht verfolgt. Ich will das auch nicht, aber ich hab mittlerweile ein paar interessante Use-Cases gehört, wo das wirklich sinnvoll ist. Also erstmal, der Kindle 3 ist ja schwarz und nicht mehr weiß. Das ist schonmal eine sehr gute Entscheidung. So wie auch iPad irgendwie schwarz umrandet ist, macht durchaus Sinn. Und du kannst dann bei Amazon noch so eine Leder-Tasche dazu kaufen. Da steckt er dann irgendwie so drin, wie so eine Hülle. Sieht aber wertiger aus als, sagen wir mal, diese iPad-Hülle von Apple. Und dann ist da sozusagen noch ein LED-Leselicht integriert. Also, dass sie sozusagen kein eigenes Licht haben, kompensieren sie dadurch, dass sie mit dieser Tasche auch gleichzeitig so eine herausziehbare und sich dann automatisch in der richtigen Position befindliche weiße LED, die dann auf den Screen draufleuchtet, mit in diese Tasche integriert haben und die bezieht ihren Saft auch aus dem Kindle. Also der Kindle steckt da sozusagen auch noch, ich weiß gar nicht wie der Connector war, also irgendwas steckt an dem Kindle, sodass eben diese Lampe den Saft vom Kindle bekommt. Keine Ahnung, wie sehr das sich dann auf die Stand-by-Zeiten von diesem Gerät auswirkt. Auf jeden Fall so macht das dann durchaus Sinn. Weil es ist erschreckend weiß, dieses Display. Vielleicht wirkt das jetzt auch nur so dadurch, dass es in einer schwarzen...
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt hier so ein Inkpaper, das keine Selbstverleuchtung hat, damit man es in der Sonne sehen kann, und bauen dann die Lampe wieder außen dran.
Na, es ist halt wie Papier. Das ist ja das Argument schon immer gewesen. Und muss sagen, das sah auch wirklich hier sehr gut aus. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die jetzt in der Auflösung noch mal irgendwann zugelegt haben. Ich hab mir das jetzt schon länger nicht mehr so wirklich angeschaut. Klar, so mit diesem Seitenwechsel und so weiter. Ich finde das immer noch nicht so sexy. Und das ist halt nicht das Device, mit dem du dir irgendwie einen Videofilm anschaust. Aber dafür ist es ja auch nicht gedacht, weil mittlerweile ist das Teil von Preis her in Regionen vorgestoßen, wo es eben vorher nicht war. Das ist jetzt irgendwie 180 Euro. Naja, ich glaube 250 Euro musst du wohl noch anlegen, wenn du so eine Tasche noch mit dabei haben willst. Wie auch immer. Und da dachte ich mir so, na wenn das iPad sich so ein Retina-Display zulegt, dann könnte da aber auch noch eine Menge gehen. Weil das ist irgendwie das, was mir derzeit wirklich noch fehlt. Also gerade jetzt mit dem iPhone 4, da kommt einem das iPad automatisch total alt vor. Das ist erstaunlich.
Also es ist super cool so zum Klicken.
Es wird super antik, ne?
Aber Lesen, ne.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, ob sie es schaffen, da die Auflösung zu verdoppeln. Weil das müssten sie eigentlich bringen.
Ist das nicht... Also diese iPhone Displays ist doch hier so IPS-Display-Technologie, ne? Und hier so Computer, so große Displays mit IPS gibt es ja nicht.
Doch, wir haben auf dem MacBook auch eine IPS.
Ich glaube eben nicht. Also es hat mir nämlich letztens jemand im Club gesagt und dann habe ich auch nochmal nachgeguckt und es steht auf jeden Fall nicht in den Tech-Specs, dass diese Displays IPS-Technologie enabled wären.
Dass sie sich mit dem schräg raufgucken?
Naja, ich weiß nicht genau, was IPS jetzt eigentlich...
Im Crane-Switching. Es sorgt auf jeden Fall dafür, dass es, ich kann dir die Technik nicht erklären, aber es sorgt dafür, dass du eben deutlich besseren Einblickwinkel hast.
Das ist alles?
Also dieser 27 Zoller hier zum Beispiel, der hat das.
Aber das hat nichts mit der Auflösung zu tun, dass nur IPS-Displays auch mit mehr Auflösung klarkommen.
Also mir wird das jetzt irgendwie neugierig.
Also warum gibt es keine großen LCD-Displays, die eine höhere Auflösung als 150 oder so was haben?
Na umso mehr Pixel, umso komplizierter, also umso höher ist halt die Fehlerrate.
Die Fehlerrate?
Naja, du hast ja immer einen gewissen Ausschuss bei der Produktion. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat. Am Anfang war das ja immer, also große Displays waren vor allem deshalb teurer, gar nicht mal weil es mehr Fläche ist, sondern weil du mehr Ausschuss hattest. Weil du häufiger was produziert hast, wo halt so viele Pixel im Arsch waren, dass du das ganze Display wegschmeißen musstest. Und umso weniger Pixel du eben produziert hast für einen Bildschirm, umso höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da eben kein kaputtes dabei war und dass du nicht das ganze Display wegschmeißen musstest. Deswegen waren die kleinen Displays schon immer rentabler, nicht nur von der Fläche her, sondern eben von der Produktion her. Ich weiß nicht. Ja, das ist jetzt...
20 Jahre.
Es hat sich ja auch verbessert. Ich meine, so dieses Problem mit irgendwie tote Pixel, weiß ich nicht, das war am Anfang, als das anfing, da war das so ein richtiges Thema. Neuer Computer, erstmal gucken, ob alle Pixel heile sind, mehr als drei Pixel kriegst du neun. Hast du zwei tote Pixel, kriegst du keinen neun. Na ich schon.
Ich auch.
Man konnte dir die damals aber auch noch wegmassieren. Und, konntest du deine wegmassieren?
Einen, der direkt in der Mitte war. Da muss man einfach so lange drücken, bis er weg ist. Kann natürlich schiefgehen, aber da ist ja eh schon kaputt. Aber ich hab ja am Rand noch welche, die gehen nicht weg, aber die sind mir auch schon seit Jahren, die fallen mir gar nicht mehr auf. Aber ich hab was viel Cooleres. Ich hab ein Pixel und das ist kein toter Pixel, sondern, ich kann jetzt dem Hucke ja mal vorführen, mal gucken, ob das jetzt geht hier. Geht natürlich jetzt nicht, warte mal, ich mach mal hier. Ich hab einen, ich glaube, das ist...
Ein Inverter Pixel.
Ja, das ist der rosa Punkt, der da ist. Und das Witz ist, genau jetzt, siehst du es, was passiert? Und zwar, ich glaube, dass es kein toter Pixel ist, sondern die Pixel sind alle okay, sondern das ist ein kaputter Grafik... Also ein Bit in einem Grafikmemory kaputt ist, weil wenn ich mein Fenster bewege, dann kopiert er sich und das werden immer mehr und mehr und mehr. Also weil wahrscheinlich ein Kopiervorgang stattfindet von dem Rahmen an, wo alles hin. Und beim Auslesen, der liest immer wieder das Gleiche aus, obwohl er eigentlich was anderes reinschreibt. Und dann werden immer mehr Pixel kaputt. Und das ist sehr witzig. Ich kann hier so rummalen, indem ich meine Fenster hin- und her schiebe. Nix, das ist der Rahmen, der kaputt ist.
Und dann ist das jetzt, solange bis du rebootest, so?
Äh, nee, also wenn dann...
Also irgendwie verschwinden die auch wieder?
Die verschwinden wieder, wenn jemand da so ein Flasch in den Grafikspeicher macht. Aber jetzt hier bei bestimmten... Der zeichnet jetzt halt nicht neu, sondern macht hier so ein Blitting im Grafikspeicher und dann bleiben die Punkte halt irgendwie da.
So, und wir waren jetzt bei Kindle und wir wollten eigentlich iPads mit höheren Auflösungen haben und dann sind wir straight abgebogen auf Dennis Pixelfehler und Tim hat sich in der Zwischenzeit schon wieder seinem Mischpult gewidmet. Und jetzt müssen wir alles wieder zusammenkriegen.
Ja, ich guck grad nochmal, wie das mit diesem IPS ist. Also beim iMac ist tatsächlich IPS angegeben, beim Macbook nicht, das stimmt.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch die Live-Recherche in der Wikipedia starten, was das eigentlich überhaupt mit diesem IPS auf sich hat.
Ja, Mobile Macs, der Podcast, wo Experten zu euch sprechen, die auf alles eine Antwort wissen, dass man kurz in der Wikipedia nachschlagen. Live Action ist das sozusagen. Live Wikipedia Research Action. Ja, wir sollten uns als Audiobuch für die Wikipedia anpreisen. Wir lesen da mal vor, wa?
Hörbuch reloaded.
Wir machen hier aber nur Cherry-Picking, ne?
Ja, wir suchen uns nur die besten Seiten von der Wikipedia aus. Das ist ja die eigentliche Dienstleistung.
IPS ist ja wie Windows, da gibt's Super IPS, Advanced Super IPS, Horizontal IPS, Enhanced IPS und Professional IPS. So wie Advanced Super IPS.
Gibt's auch Ultimate?
Nee, Ultimate gibt's noch nicht. Also jedes Jahr kam irgendwie so ein neuer Ultimate, hast du nicht gesehen, Very Advanced.
Very Super Advanced.
Apropos... Kindle schon fertig oder wie?
Ja, zum Kindle... Also ich kann zum Kindle nicht viel sagen. Ich meine, ich finde das nach wie vor uninteressant. Das ist halt toll. Für mich... Ja, für mich auch. Ich lese ja schon wenig Bücher und wenn, dann brauche ich irgendwie ein großes PDF auf meinem 27 Zoller, wo ich irgendwie markieren kann und Copy und Paste machen kann und meine Bookmarks setzen kann und das irgendwie da habe, wo ich das meine Dropbox schmeißen kann, auf allen Devices habe. Das Buch, was ich gerade halt irgendwie... Das Fachbuch, was ich gerade lese, das Referenzmanual, was auch immer. Deswegen, also da bin ich einfach nicht der Kunde dafür, aber es gibt natürlich Leute, die lesen einfach wie Blöde. Ich habe jetzt hier vor kurzem einen Podcast gemacht über Segeln bzw. Weltsegeln, also Weltumsegeln, wie auch immer. Also um die Welt herum. Segeln! Segeln auf jeden Fall! Und wenn man dann so 15 Tage auf dem Atlantik ist, so viele Bücher kannst du gar nicht mitnehmen. Also da fehlt dir einfach der Platz auf so einem Boot. Also abgesehen vom Gewicht ist das einfach ein Platzproblem.
Absolutely incredible!
Da musst du dann sozusagen so eine Bibliothek dabei sein, weil das ist ja auch total öde. Du bist ja auf dem Atlantik, du siehst irgendwie zwei Wochen lang noch nicht mal ein Schiff. Also nichts. Außer wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Vögel. Es sei denn zufällig Zugvögel. Nee, auch nicht. Auf dem Atlantik. Es liegt auch kein Vogel. Vielleicht ist es mal ein Wal oder so, oder Delfine. Aber...
Also die lesen dann auf Hochsee?
Ja, also mein Freund Jumd, der meinte irgendwie, was sollste sonst machen? Und liest dann halt, ne?
Ich würd wahrscheinlich einen neuen Flight-Control-Rekord machen.
Du kannst ihn ja auch nicht sammitten.
Du würdest Minecraft spielen.
Stromverbrauch ist aber auch noch so ein Thema, so auf Hoher See.
Gibt's Solarzellen?
Hat er nicht.
Was?
Ja, gibt's auch Dieselmotor und so.
Dann ist der Kindle auch irgendwann leer.
Ja, aber der Kindle hält halt länger als jetzt ein iPad.
Ja, aber Solarzellen wirst du schon brauchen auf seinen ganzen Navi-Shit und so.
Er hat Wind und er hat halt irgendwie viele Akkus und Tralala. Da muss er immer den Podcast anwenden. Da äußert er sich sehr ausführlich zum Energiewertengen.
Ich hör ja keine Podcasts.
Ach so. Ach, muss mal reinhören. Manchmal gibt es auch ganz interessante Sachen.
Ich hab ja mal einen gehört.
Wow, mal einen.
Ich hab mal einen gehört.
Bisher hab ich nur einen einzigen gehört.
Und das war der mit dem Häuserbauen mit Ron.
Ja, und? Na bitte.
Also nicht immer so, aber...
Energiesparhäuser.
Die gegenläufige Wärme-Umtauschpumpe hat mich fasziniert. Hab ich mir gleich mal durchgelesen.
Das ist schon...
Da hat einer mal nachgedacht.
Ja, also der Segelpodcast, der hat auch definitiv Geekfaktor gehabt. Ron Junge ist ja auch alter Geek.
Ja, so, weiter am Thema, im Text.
Ich habe eine schwere Podcast-Woche vor mir und reise mal eine Woche lang durch Germanien und werde irgendwie ein Shitload an Sendungen aufnehmen für alle möglichen Projekte. Und unter anderem bin ich dann auch in München.
Ist das jetzt ein Mächt-Thema?
Ja, naja, so ähnlich.
In München gibt es einen Apple Store.
Erstens gibt es in München einen Apple Store, da kann ich mal wieder mein aktuelles Set an kaputten Head-Sets austauschen. Dann will ich mal den Genius-Bar da mit meinem Apple iMac-Problem und diesem Umschalten und dem Audio konfrontieren, von dem ich immer noch glaube, dass es entweder ein Firmware oder ein OS X oder beides Back ist. Bevor ich jetzt hier anfange, irgendwie große Fehler-Bugreports zu schreiben, was ich zwar auch noch mal machen will, aber ich einfach noch nicht dazugekommen bin, dachte ich mal, teste ich mal wieder so ein bisschen den Real-Life-Support. Das macht immer Spaß. Aber deswegen fahre ich nicht hin, sondern ich fahre unter anderem hin, um mir hier mal die Live-Sendung von Bits und so anzuschauen, die da laufen wird. Ich habe ja auch schon ein paar Mal live gemacht. Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie die anderen sich so schlagen. Und naja, dann ergab sich das durch Zufall eigentlich, dass da noch so eine Konferenz läuft, die ich ganz interessant fand. Und zwar, das dürfte dich, Huckel, interessieren.
Ich haue gebannt.
Ja, jetzt muss ich kurz mal gucken. Diese Konferenz heißt Decoded. Und das ist eine Tageskonferenz vor Code and Design. Und da geht es sozusagen, wie sagen sie hier, Design Code Culture. Hier geht es sozusagen mehr um Visualisierung und so Hacking. Also da kommt auch so viel Arduino, Tinkering und dieser ganze Kram. Aber eben auch so Info-Statics, Infographics, Visualisierungsaspekte. Ist auch ein sehr interessanter Zeitrahmen. Das spricht da unter Umständen für etwas jugendliche Ausrichtung, geht irgendwie um 15 Uhr los und endet dann irgendwann so tief in der Nacht. Es hat also schon fast so Kongress-Feeling, wobei es noch deutlich später anfängt. Und da sind dann so einfach Programmiersprachen als künstlerisches Werkzeug, generative Gestaltung, Datenvisualisierung, Informationsästhetik, Games, dann Arduino und so weiter. Also da spielt da alles eine Rolle. Ich kann nicht sagen, wie das ist. Ich werde da auf jeden Fall mal reinschauen und mir das mal angucken. Das Ganze ist in der Freiheitshalle. Es gibt auch noch Tickets. Ja, vielleicht hat ja jemand Lust, da irgendwie sich das anzuschauen. Wie gesagt, ich kann nichts darüber sagen, wie cool das ist. Von außen betrachtet klingt das auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Gerade so für Leute, die vielleicht in diesem Bereich Visualisierung, Programmierung etc., Bastelkram unterwegs sind. Und ich vermute mal, dass da sich auch eine Menge Macintosh treffen werde.
Ja, also an der UDK, hier digitale Klassen, sind ja auch alles Mac-User, die mit Arduino und so weiter rumhantieren.
Da geht richtig was.
Das sieht so aus, als wäre das sozusagen die Zielgruppe auch.
Genau, dürfte dich ja dann von daher auch interessieren. Also ich bin gespannt, was da ist. Auf jeden Fall mal was anderes. Irgendwie mal nicht so eine reine Programmierer oder Hacker-Nummer.
Und du machst mal Witze und so mit?
Nee, ich mach nicht mit.
Und wo machen die live? Wir machen auch live. Wir machen jede Sendung live.
Ja, live also on stage. Damit hast du mich jetzt erwischt.
Nein, nein.
Warte mal, das ist hier. Wo ist denn das? Ich vergesse das jedes Mal wieder. Obaanga Theater. Was das auch immer für eine Location sein mag. Ich war da noch nie. Keine Ahnung. Na ja, da findet das halt irgendwie statt. Ich hab das jetzt auch ein paar Mal gemacht. Und muss sagen, wenn man irgendwie mit dem richtigen Equipment rangeht, dann kann man das auch machen.
Und Themen sind egal, hauptsache, dass es nicht stimmt.
Ich weiß nicht, worum es geht. Ich meine, es wird eine Bits und so Sendung sein. Das heißt, sie werden sich einfach die aktuelle Themenlandschaft vornehmen und auseinander pflücken, wie sie es immer tun. So, ich bin gespannt, wie die Jungs sich auf der Bühne schlagen.
Im Theaterpodcasten?
Also ich hab neulich ja auf der Art der Elektroniker so ein Podcast aufgenommen.
Die wollten sich nicht auflösen.
Erstens hab ich das nicht gesagt, sondern Max und zweitens war das ein Witz.
So, du hast auf der Ars gepodcastet auf der Bühne.
Genau. Ja, hab ich gemacht. Na, habt ihr nicht gehört? Das ist...
Oh, den hab ich... Den hab ich wohl verpasst.
Na, das ist doch hier der CCC und die Öffentlichkeit hab ich den genannt.
Ah, ich hab ihn gesehen, aber nicht gehört.
Mit Atod und mit Vic. Und ja, das war ganz nett und vor allem, also ich hatte das schon mal gemacht auf der Republika mit Peter Glaser, das war aber ein bisschen fail, weil ich erstens nicht mein eigenes Equipment hatte, sondern sozusagen nur da so, wie man eben da so auf der Bühne normalerweise ist, gesessen habe, ohne Kopfhörer und das war der Feind, das habe ich sozusagen erst danach begriffen, weil wenn du das ohne Kopfhörer machst, dann ist das einfach ganz anders, da entgleitet dir das anders. Da hast du einfach nicht diese Nähe, die du eben mit Kopfhörern hast beim Aufnehmen eines Podcasts. Und das habe ich dann auf der Ars richtig gemacht, also mit meinem mobilen Equipment, das heißt, wir saßen so mit den Hetzels, so wie wir jetzt hier sitzen, auf der Bühne und da merkt man eigentlich gar nicht, dass man Publikum hat. Man weiß es, man sieht es auch, aber man ist einfach genauso im Gespräch und deswegen war das eigentlich eine relativ authentische Sendung. Also wenn man die jetzt so hört, abgesehen davon, dass halt ab und zu mal eine größere Menge so beim Joke mitlacht und am Ende ein bisschen mitklatscht und so weiter, merkst du das eigentlich gar nicht, dass sozusagen da noch mehr da sind. Theoretisch hätte man da auch noch mit einem Zusatzmikrofon arbeiten können, vielleicht sogar auch müssen, aber das sind immer so die Sachen, die einem immer erst danach einfallen. Naja gut, aber das ist ja alles nicht das Thema von Mobile Max. Hier geht es ja nur so um langweilige Apple-Scheiße.
Und unseren neuen Namen, den wir noch nicht preisgeben.
Da habe ich übrigens drüber nachgedacht. Ich habe ja gesagt...
Weißt du einen?
Wir haben uns doch... Wir haben doch schon einen neuen Namen. Wir verraten ihn noch nicht. Kliffhänger. Nächstes Season.
Schalten sie auch das nächste Mal wieder ein. Wenn wir dann endlich den neuen Namen bekannt geben. Oder vielleicht auch erst in der Sendung danach. Weiß ich da was von? Nee. Du weißt eh nichts. Wir weinen dich ja generell eigentlich nicht ein. Wir hören ja immer auf zu reden, wenn du hier reinkommst. Stimmt.
Du warst ja hier eben. Ich habe ja draußen gewartet eine halbe Stunde. Du bist einfach nicht rausgekommen, nicht losgefahren. Ich dachte, dass wir die bei euch ja nichts einfühlen. Dann ist mir so spontan eingefallen, Apfel und Birnen. Eigentlich heißt das ja Äpfel und Birnen.
Ja.
Aber erst gehen ja eh nicht. Deswegen Apfel und Birnen und das passt auch wieder, weil es ist ja nur eine Apfelfirma, es sind viele Birnen.
Nächsten oder übernächsten?
Ich hab gerade abgeschaltet. Ich fänd ja irgendwas gut, was irgendwie auch irgendwie MM ist. Dass man irgendwie seinen Kürze nicht ändern muss.
Naja, wir werden sehen.
Dieses Max, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Naja, nicht so wichtig. Aber hier die anderen, die anderen würden hier, ne? Gutes Thema.
Genau, es gab heut noch keinen.
Dieses Gerücht fand ich ja geil, das Microsoft Adobe kauft, um irgendwie besser gegen Apple bestehen zu können. Irgendwo hab ich das auf so einer Webseite gelesen und hab mich fast nicht mehr eingekriegt vor Lachen. Das war eine großartige Idee. Ich meine, das wäre wirklich die Rettung, wenn Microsoft Adobe kauft. Dann wären wir sie beide auf einmal los.
Nee, ich glaub los wird man ja nicht so schnell. Es gibt halt...
Durch solche Maßnahmen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das Problem ist ja, also Adobe, die machen zwar auch Flash, aber die machen halt auch so Software, die es sonst nicht mehr so gibt. Also es gibt halt keinen Photoshop, keinen Illustrator, keinen InDesign-Konkurrenten.
Weil sie alles gekauft haben, haben sterben lassen.
Genau. Und deswegen werden die so lange, dass das so bleibt, auch da bleiben. Egal wie, selbst wenn die sich irgendwie in Ruinen wirtschaften oder so, es geht einfach nicht, dass Photoshop solange nicht eine Alternative da ist. Und ich prange ja schon seit... Scheiße, der Hive funktioniert nicht, wenn man die braucht. Warte. Ist die Batterie alle oder was? Die geht immer aus.
Dann musst du mal eins und zwei drücken.
Ja, das mein ich die ganze Zeit hier.
Und dann geht's aus?
Hey Jungs, wir waren jetzt bei Adobe und bei Microsoft.
Sehr überzeugend. Du hast nur noch 2% Batterie, gib mal her, ich mach dir mal neue Batterien rein.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich sprang ja seit Jahren an, dass es da keine Alternative gibt, aber es gibt halt auch keine. Es traut sich auch keiner mehr irgendwie jetzt nochmal, dass dieses Wahlrost zu schlachten, ja.
Das Wahlrost namens Photoshop?
Ja, oder InDesigner Illustrator. Es traut sich keiner mehr. Es gibt keine große Firma, die sagt, das muss jetzt mal gemacht werden, wir machen das jetzt mal, hier ist unser Konkurrenzprodukt.
Also, wenn Microsoft Adobe kaufen würde, dann weiß ich, welche Firma das tun würde. Apple.
Also, ich muss ja sagen...
Ja, natürlich, ich meine, wenn sie befürchten müssen, dass Microsoft als nächstes ankündigt, dass es Photoshop jetzt nur noch für Windows 11 gibt.
Aber das machen sie nicht, sie machen auch Office für Mac und so. Das können die sich alle gar nicht erlauben.
Ja gut, aber Office für Mac und was macht Apple iWork? Ich weiß, das ist noch nicht...
Das ist nicht, das kannst du Apple und Birn vergleichen, ja. Also, für so ein Marketing-Hoschi oder so eine Büromietze kannst du halt nicht, kannst du nicht so ein iWorks...
Also, das Pages, das bedient sich ausreichend schlecht, um genau so ein Word zu essen.
Ja, aber die interagieren halt, also diese Welt von so Marketing-Leuten und von so Business-Developern und so weiter und dieser ganze Käse, die leben halt in diesem MS-Office. Die können nicht anders, die brauchen das. Das gehört halt dazu und deswegen...
Ja, 100 Prozent, jetzt hast du wieder Heil.
Herrlich.
Haben wir ja ein schönes Abschiedslied hier.
Microsoft, Adobe und...
Red mal weiter.
Ja, du hast mich mit dem rumgeforscht.
Entschuldigung.
Es gibt keinen Photoshop-Ersatz. Ja und Apple macht das nicht. Also ich mein irgendwie so gut jetzt vielleicht Final Cut und so, so was ist, aber...
Okay, ich wollte darauf ja auch gar nicht hinaus, weil ich glaube nicht im Traum daran, dass Microsoft Adobe kaufen wird. Wenn sie das tun würden, dann wären sie wirklich heftig bescheuert. Aber vor allem diese Behauptung, das würde beide Firmen eine bessere Position bringen, um gegen Apple vorzugehen, das ist natürlich wirklich albern.
Aber wer hat das denn geschrieben?
Ja, Zeitschriften, Tech-Analysts, halt diese Leute, die irgendwie immer...
Das lohnt sich schon deswegen nicht, Windows hat ja hier dieses...
Silverlight, ja die sind ja beide gleichscheiße drauf. Also ich meine, die verfolgen ja beide denselben bekloppten Weg.
Silverlight ist cool.
Ja, Silverlight ist aber im Prinzip dasselbe wie Flash.
Ja, ist schon eigentlich auch was ganz anderes, aber sie benutzen es erstmal so wie Flash. Du hast ja da halt hier diesen ganzen Dotnet-Kram drunter, das heißt, du kannst da halt schon irgendwie deutlich mehr machen mit deutlich unterschiedlicheren Sprachen unter anderen Mitteln, als jetzt mit Flash.
Ja gut, aber es ist nach wie vor nicht The Web.
Aber eine interessante These war ja, dass zum Beispiel die Applikation auf den Windows Phone 7, aber das weiß ich nicht, weil ich mich mit Windows Phone 7 überhaupt nicht beschäftige, aber weiß das der Flash, der Chat, ob nicht die Applikationen da sogar in Silverlight auf dem Windows Phone 7 gehackt sind oder ist das Mono alles nur so straight? Windows Phone 7. Ich will so eins haben. Ich will mal klicken.
Das sind wir jetzt schon beim richtigen Thema?
Nee, ich war noch hier bei Microsoft und Windows Phone 7 und dem ganzen Kram, ja. Bitte schön.
Hast du das Werbevideo gesehen?
Ich hab das Werbevideo heute präsentiert bekommen von Robert, das muss ich auch kurz an dieser Stelle sagen, der jetzt auf Twitter ist, Future of Robert, den ich schon ein paar Mal erwähnt habe.
Dein Arbeitskollege.
Wir grüßen Robert. Wir grüßen Robert, genau, der braucht auch ein paar... Grüßt den schon, Robert! Der braucht auch ein paar Follower, könnt ihr gleich mal klicken hier.
Wozu braucht er die?
Da heißt er auch Future of Robert, glaube ich.
Mach den fertig, Jungs.
So, jetzt Dennis, bitte schön. Hat Robert mir gezeigt, hab ich heute gesehen.
Ich muss ja nochmal verteidigen, weil manchmal in unseren Kommentaren, da sind ja Leute, die sagen, wir wären ja irgendwie so böse Apple-Fanboys und so weiter, aber ich meine, hey, habt ihr mal auf den Titel unseres Podcasts geguckt?
Next.
Nee, aber dieses, ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen offen und man guckt ja auch mal, also Microsoft, die tun ja mir fast schon so ein bisschen leid und dann ist man ja auch mal ganz locker. Und da hab ich mir diese Werbevideos von denen angeguckt für das Windows 7 und dachte, mal gucken, was die jetzt da so für schick Werbung machen. Und es war auch alles ganz schick aus. Also das Werbevideo müsst ihr euch natürlich selber angucken, ich erkläre das jetzt nicht. Aber so sieht ganz schick aus, bis man dann feststellt, dass die Leute, die man dann in dem Video sieht, ja anscheinend gar nicht mit einem Windows 7 Phone rumrennen, sondern das sind alles Konkurrenzprodukte, sollen zumindest welche sein, die Microsoft sozusagen negativ darstellt, weil man zu viel Zeit damit verbringt. Und die Botschaft ist, dass man ja mit dem Windows 7 Phone nicht mehr so viel Zeit mit seinem Phone verbringen würde, oder müsste, besser gesagt. Und also ich glaube, ich hab noch nie so, gibt's so richtig so Werbung, wo man die Konkurrenzprodukte die ganze Zeit sieht, dann sagt die sind scheiße und dann nur so im Text irgendwie oder im Voice-Over irgendwie sein eigenes Produkt anbietet. Also seit wann macht man denn das?
Hi, I'm a Mac and I'm a PC.
Ja, aber die stehen sich ja wenigstens gegenüber. Und betteln.
Ja, es ist eigentlich...
Und das noch ein bisschen satire und so, aber die bei Microsoft, die meinen das ja ernst.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was die Botschaft sein soll von diesen... Also ich meine, sie zeigen ja nun gar nichts, was jetzt irgendwie da besser ist. Also sie behaupten irgendwie, ja, ihr sollt jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit auf eure Telefone an, auf eure Smartphone gucken, weil da ja vielleicht interessante Sachen drauf sind. Und übrigens, wir wollen euch dasselbe verkaufen, was auch so Telefone, wo man draufgucken ist. Also ich meine...
Schneller rein und schneller raus, das hätte er nicht geschoben.
Ja, also was, ich verstehe nicht, was bitte jetzt an diesem Windows-Phone so bahnbrechend anders sein soll, was man da nicht...
Doch, also man kann ja jetzt so offen lassen, weil wir haben es ja alle noch nicht gesehen, dass es irgendwie voll toll ist und voll super sein wird und wie hieß das Wort? Ich hab's am Schlangen nicht mehr gehört. Ach, Herr iPhone Killer hieß es früher. Dass es der nächste iPhone-Killer ist, kann ja alles sein. Aber ich mein, es kommt einfach mal nicht rüber in dieser Werbung. Ne, wie auch? Und ich meine, man macht heutzutage Werbung, wo man zeigt, dass es natürlich das aller-tollste, coolste Gerät ist und so weiter.
Es macht ja Apple auch immer so, also alle schummeln ja was, was das Zeug ist, es ist ja alles nur Wahrnehmung und so. Aber das kriegt Microsoft anscheinend nicht auf die Reihe. Und ich meine, wen bezahlen die denn da, dass die sich so eine Werbung aufquatschen lassen?
Aber sie hat mit seinen Verhältnissen die Werbung.
Aber die fand ich wirklich...
Ja, da ist ihnen mal was gelungen irgendwie. Und dann so, oh Gott! Das könnte was taugen!
Schnell einstellen!
Ich meine, beim ersten Mal dachte ich auch so was. Das ist so ein Scheiß, aber so...
Ja, die hatte irgendwas.
Also wenn man das so durchgezogen hätte, dann wäre die Kugel.
Ja, aber dieser arschwackelnde Bill Gates, da hab ich mich auch schon gefragt, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Irgendwann werden diese Folgen, die unveröffentlichen, die werden irgendwann nochmal mit Internet auftauchen. Und dann werden wir das endlich erst wissen.
Das wird Kult werden.
Ja, und dann werden sie total heulen. Oh Gott, hätten wir die mal geschaltet, dann wäre alles anders geworden. Aber sie haben einfach nichts zu zeigen.
Genau, sie haben nichts, also vielleicht kommt das ja noch wieder, das ist ja so der Anfang, aber da hätte man es auch ein bisschen spannender gemacht, oder? Da wäre viel mehr entstanden. Aber so, alle anderen Telefone sind scheiße, weil die Leute zu viel draufk Weil die Leute sie benutzen wollen die ganze Zeit.
Ja, so irgendwie, die sind so gut, dass die Leute daran kleben, wo die Hochzeiten verpassen. Ja, und wir bringen jetzt ein Phone, wo das nicht so ist.
Genau, unser Phone ist so scheiße.
Es klingt so ein bisschen wie der Spruch mit dem Zoom. Ich meine, wahrscheinlich dieses Windows-Phone ist ja eigentlich irgendwie Zoom-Phone. Welcome to the Social.
Die großen Fails von Microsoft, die kriegt man ja gar nicht mit, weil das geht so schnell, du merkst es gar nicht. Wie hieß... Kinn hieß es, glaube ich. Drei Monate hat es gedauert, bis die es wieder gecancelt haben.
Nee, das hat keine drei Monate gedauert. Ich glaube, das hat nur drei Wochen gedauert.
Nee, das waren, glaube ich, drei Monate.
War es drei Monate?
Aber es ist auch schon so schnell gecancelt, dass man das... also, ich meine, ich hab's kaum mitbekommen. Dass ich nicht mal in der Aufgeregt so schnell was wieder weg. Ich meine, das ist erst mal eine Leistung. So, heute hab ich aber jetzt genug für Microsoft gebästigt. Ich finde die... also, ich bin ja wirklich... Also, eigentlich tun sie ja so ein bisschen leid. Doch, die sind irgendwie gar nicht mehr die Bösen und kriegen aber immer noch auf den Deckel.
Ich finde, die waren einfach schlecht genug so lange, dass sie einfach noch lange bluten dürfen.
Doch, ein Ding muss sie noch loswerden.
Wenn es nach mir geht, können die noch 10 Jahre in der Hölle schmieren.
Erst heute wieder. Ich hab dann noch so ein Windows XP, muss ich ja sagen, ist ein bisschen alt und ab und zu bräuchst du einen Scheiß. Und ich hab da ein CD-Rom-Laufwerk angeschlossen per USB-R. Und da war eine CD drin. Und da hat er gleich los erzählt. Alles voll toll. Also, er hat's gleich selber erkannt. Ich musste das machen.
Was hat er denn installiert? Den Treiber für die CD? Oder was auf der CD war?
Das, was auf der CD war. So, jetzt, genau, du bist schon auf der richtigen Fährte. Den Treiber, also, während er schon installiert, von dieser CD, von, ja, kommt noch so ein Fenster hoch und sagt, da ist eine neue Hardware und der Treiber wurde installiert und ich soll jetzt neu starten. Während aber eigentlich das, was auf der CD ist, also es funktioniert eigentlich schon längst alles.
Und dann denkt man, was ist denn das für eine Scheiße? Ja, aber es ist ja auch jetzt Windows XP. Das muss jetzt schon, das ist jetzt ja auch schon echt an den Stopp. Ich kann mir alles nicht mehr gehen.
Echt nicht.
Ja, aber doch, ich kann. Ja, ich werde das demnächst mal upgraden.
Ja, das gibt jetzt schon wieder so fünf Einträge irgendwie im Blog.
Noch nicht mal eine Hand gehabt und schon...
Ja, und überhaupt ihr Dose...
Mit dem Telefon.
Ihr habt doch keine Ahnung von Windows.
Mit dem Telefon?
Mit dem Telefon, ohne das Telefon, wir haben einfach keine Ahnung und das steht dann im Blog.
Ich hab ja gesagt, es kann sein, dass das der nächste iPhone-Killer ist und so, aber die Werbung bringt's halt nicht.
Das wird nicht der nächste iPhone-Killer, nichts wird der nächste iPhone-Killer.
Jetzt kriegen wir Blog-Einträge.
Ja, nichts wird der nächste iPhone-Killer, weil einfach keiner auch nur im Ansatz so aufgestellt ist wie Apple.
Da gab's übrigens, das haben wir auch der Robert hier vorhin gezeigt, da gab's irgendwie so eine...
Der alle wissende Robert sollten wir ihn nennen.
Future of Robert, das Orakel. Robert, das Orakel. Der meinte, der hat so eine Seite mir gezeigt, wo irgendwie Smartphones before iPhone, dann waren halt irgendwie diese ganzen Palms und diese Mikrotastaturen und eckig und überladene Interfaces, dann iPhone und dann, wie ich weiß, ist danach alle rundgelutscht, alle so in diesem iPhone-Format, alle irgendwie so, wieso, no? Dann war halt so die Message, okay, jetzt so sehen EPCs aus, dann kam das iPad, wir sehen jetzt wohl in der Zukunft die Dinge aus.
Ja, hab ich auch gesehen.
Ja, diese Seite. Robert liest nämlich auch sehr viel Daring Fireboy. Wir werden jede Folge von Mobile Max ein paar mehr Details über Robert preisgeben.
Und sein Schalz macht das nächste Mal ein.
Wenn es heißt, neue schmutzige, intime Details über Robert.
Dann sind ja mal morgen Fragen, ob er heute so um 20.00 nach 10.00 lauter Game Center Friends bekommen wird.
Naja, Follower hat ja jetzt noch nicht viele neue, ne, ist immer noch bei 9.00. Also ich bin noch ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Du hast ja noch nicht erzählt, was so interessant ist an Robert, nicht wahr? Man folgt ja jetzt einfach nicht nur, weil jemand sagt Folge. Die Zeiten sind ja wohl vorbei, ja?
Ja, das stimmt, aber na einer könnte ja schon mal klingen. Robert hat auch noch nichts getweetet. Also ihr geht da auch noch kein großes Risiko ein, wenn ihr da klingt. Also es fließen ja hier und da ein paar Sachen von Robert, die ich von Robert so aufschnappe, auch mit ein. Aber wie nicht, das ist ja auch.
Okay, kommen wir wieder zu Technologie hier. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir hier noch was hätten.
Ja, nehme ich.
Apple Data Center.
Ja, tolle Geschichte fand ich auch.
Das wird ja jetzt langsam fertig, sagt man. Wo war das? North Carolina? Irgendwo, wo noch ein altes unbenutztes Atomkraftwerk rumstand und strombillig war. Und dann haben sie sich jetzt da irgendwie diesen Klotz hingesetzt. Ich kann jetzt die Zahl nicht nennen, wie groß das ist, aber wahrscheinlich ist es groß. Und ja, alle fragen sich, wozu das sein könnte.
Naja, die brauchen halt jetzt für irgendwie Geo-Data-Fu, für ihr Mobile-Max-Fu, für Facetime-Fu, für alles Fu.
Für Facetime brauchen sie keinen Datacenter.
Aber für Geo-Fu und für Mobile-Mii.
Okay, sie brauchen dafür auch...
Und für ihren Store und für Ping und für...
Also du meinst einfach natürliches Wachstum, da steckt jetzt kein besonderes Produkt dahinter.
Naja, Moment, das könnte ein Faktor sein. Sie haben jetzt auf jeden Fall erhöhten, also auch immer mehr Web-Cloud-Bedarf, sag ich mal. Ja.
Denen händelt doch aber Ackermai.
Nen, nicht nur. Manche Sachen willst du halt selber haben. Also auf Ackermai hast du keine Business-Logic und so.
Ja, du kannst keine Teilnehmer vermitteln mit einem Content Distribution Management. Das ist nur gut, um dicke Falz zu pushen.
Ja.
Aber wenn man sowas von einem Ort irgendwie auf der Welt machen wollte, dann lieber nicht auch ihre Server zu Ackermai rund um die Welt verteilen.
Naja, sie haben natürlich, die Datacenters in vielen Ländern.
Ich meine, der gehört da 5% oder so von Ackermai.
Ja, aber Ackermai ist Content Distribution. Es kann ja einfach sein, dass sie einfach Storage brauchen.
Also sie brauchen irgendwie...
Primary Content, der einfach überhaupt erstmal irgendwo ist. Ackermai kopiert ja nur dein Content überall hin und macht ihn schnell verfügbar. Aber du brauchst ja erstmal einen Ort, von dem das wegkopiert werden kann. Und du musst ja auch irgendwo deine ganzen logischen Systeme laufen lassen. Deine Java-Server, deine Mobile-Mii-Infrastruktur.
Mobile-Max-Infrastruktur.
Und wenn sie halt jetzt wirklich da mit iTunes-Streaming anfangen, wo ich mir immer noch nicht so richtig sicher bin, ob das nun wirklich kommen wird. Ja, ich will jetzt mit Syncing nicht anfangen. Also ihr habt ja auch keine gute Theorie, ne?
Ne, außer dass sie halt... Vielleicht, ich meine sie... Tja, es ist echt... Was macht denn Google mit ihren Data-Centern? Storage.
Ah, die speichern unsere Daten.
Ne, speichern, ne?
Ja, sie drohen auch immer ganz kräftig, was sie alles schon wissen und was sie theoretisch alles der Welt sagen könnten, aber sie sagen es keinem, weil das würde ja nur Erreger bringen. Sie meinen ja, dass sie mit ihren Suchergebnissen etc. im Prinzip die Börsenkurse vorher sagen können.
Ok, hast du mal bei Google nach Pre-Sale gesucht?
Ja.
Rausschneiden. Ja, der tägliche Dataismus. Auch hier im Podcast. So, wir waren gerade bei Datacentern und haben keine schlauen Thesen.
Ja, wir können das einfach skippen, mal gucken, ob der Chat eine gute These hat.
Steve Jobs Follower.
Was?
Müssen da gespeichert werden.
Unsere Game Center Friends.
Ach, wir werden sehen. Keine Ahnung, kommt bestimmt.
Ja, ich hab hier noch einen Rand.
Also mich würd's nicht überraschen, wenn wir bei der 10.7 Vorstellung dann wissen, wozu wir das Game Center brauchen.
Game Center? Datacenter?
Ja, genau.
Ich hab hier noch so ein bisschen Rand und Feedback von der letzten Sendung.
Diverses.
Das machen wir am Ende. Leserbriefe immer am Ende.
Du bist gut.
Feedback ist mehr als Leserbriefe. Muss hier gerade mal meine Notizen sortieren. Also, habt ihr schon mal die Maps-Applikation auf dem iPhone gestartet?
Noch nie.
Mach das mal.
Echt? Tatsache, ich hab da eine Maps-Applikation.
Wahnsinn.
Da kann man nämlich sich die Welt anschauen. So, und dann zoomt er jetzt mal irgendwie raus.
Raus?
Raus, genau.
Viele Leute wissen übrigens nicht, dass man mit einem Zwei-Finger-Click rauszoomen kann.
Also man kann mit einem Zwei-Finger-Click irgendwie rauszoomen.
Wie weit soll ich rauszoomen?
Bis du so andere Kontinente siehst, würde ich sagen. So weit mal rauszoomen.
Guck mal, jetzt seh ich hier den Mond sogar.
Den Mond? Auf dem iPhone?
War ein Spaß.
Ich seh gar nichts, bei mir lädt grad die Karte wieder ab.
Ja bei mir auch nicht.
Ja, weil dein Netz hier braun ist.
Warum ist mein Netz braun?
Weil jetzt ist mein ganzer Arm braun, weil bei deinem Netz hier noch nie irgendwas gestimmt hat.
Das ist diese bekloppte Time-Capsule, ich glaub, die ist irgendwie, die ist wieder durch. Die will jetzt irgendwie kein Netz mehr.
Wir sind ja eh in der Rahn-Sektion angekommen von daher.
Okay, was wolltest du jetzt erzählen? Erzähl uns doch, was du uns erzählen wolltest.
Man kann nicht über die Datumsgrenze hinweg scrollen. Wenn man in diesen Maps über Neuseeland hinaus nach rechts geht, dann stößt es an. Also die Erde ist eine Scheibe. Die geht von rechts nach links. Rechts ist Japan und Neuseeland. Und links ist irgendwie Alaska. Und du kannst nicht Russia von dort sehen. Also das ist völlig beknackt. Und dann hab ich mal so ein bisschen geforscht, welchen Tools das sonst auch noch irgendwie so geht. Das ist zum Beispiel Open Maps, was ich gerne benutze übrigens auf dem iPhone. Weil das mit Open Street Map Daten arbeitet und weil es auch relativ gut funktioniert. Also weil es sich so ähnlich verhält wie das normale Maps. Aber du kannst halt auch Karten runterladen und offline sozusagen das verwenden, was ganz praktisch ist. Und ja, da schlussest du aber auch gegen die Datumsgrenze. Warum auch immer. Das Einzige, was das nicht tut, ist das andere. Bei Google Earth wäre es auch wirklich ein bisschen peinlich, wenn das so wäre. Was war ich jetzt gerade? Wie heißt das andere Tool? Warte mal. Nicht Open Maps, sondern... Ach Gott, jetzt hab ich vergessen. Wie heißt denn dieses andere Open Street Map? Off Maps. Genau. Bei Off Maps geht es nämlich. Also es gibt halt solche Sachen. Aber warum jetzt ausgerechnet Apples Maps-Implementierung nicht in der Lage ist, über die ganze Welt zu gehen? Ich meine, in dem Moment hatte ich wirklich ein Bedürfnis. Ich habe eine Insel gesucht im Pazifik, die halt irgendwie da in der Nähe von der Datumsgrenze ist. Und dann wirst du einfach komplett bekloppt. Also du kannst da nicht richtig dir irgendwas angucken. Das ist irgendwie... Ich glaube, da gibt es sogar irgendeine Insel, die ist in der Mitte geteilt.
Das ist natürlich dann richtig bekloppt, ja.
Ja, es ist total bekloppt.
Das geht mal gar nicht.
Wir prangeln das an.
Wir prangeln das an, genau. Das ist einfach mal...
Wir sollten den Pranger überhaupt als Element hier anführen.
Ich stelle mir vor, irgendwelche Windows-Groupies finden das jetzt raus, weil sie diesen Podcast hören.
Und sagen, bei Bing Maps geht das aber.
Ja, und dann stehen wir da.
Mit runtergelassenen Hosen.
Aber total. Und dann sind wir nicht mehr die coolen Kids auf dem Schulhof und dann werden wir verprügelt. Dann kriegen die anderen, die hübschen Mädchen und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Und wer ist schuld?
Dennis.
Nein. Steve.
Steve.
Steve ist schuld.
Das geht also gar nicht.
Ok, nächstes Thema.
Ich hab noch ein paar schöne Tools. Eins hab ich schon erwähnt, aber ich hab's neulich mal wirklich gebraucht. Nee, da bin ich nur drauf gekommen mit dem Podcast. Das ist nämlich dieses Language-Switcher.
Auf dem Mac. Das ist für eine bestimmte App irgendwie die Language-Switch, die man startet.
Weil nämlich diese beschissene Pages von iWork, von Apple, diese Firma schon wieder.
Die das auch schon mit dem Internet nicht können.
Ja. Die sich jetzt auch in Textverarbeitung macht. Und diese Pages, finde ich ja, also ich finde es eigentlich nicht schlecht, wenn sie nicht so, aus meiner Sicht, ein paar katastrophale grundsätzliche Fehler gemacht haben. Und einer dieser katastrophalen, grundsätzlichen Fehler ist, dass, wenn du das auf einem auf Englisch eingestellten Environment startest, dann kommt es halt nicht nur in Englisch hoch, sondern auch die Templates sind dann alle in Englisch.
Und da kommt es dir dann in Englisch hoch.
Und das steht dann aber in diesem Dokument drin. Und wenn du das halt nicht willst, kannst du halt nicht sagen, dass du dann doch lieber irgendwie ja, Deutsch bzw. dass es überhaupt nicht so hardcoded ist, sondern dass sich das dann, was weiß ich, irgendwie automatisch übersetzt oder irgendwas. Dann ist auch alles irgendwie auf Englisch eingestellt und Englisches Dictionary und Englisch Englisch überall. Das heißt, es gab einen extremen Bedarf. Ich will nicht auf mein System auf Deutsch umstellen. Vielleicht mach ich es irgendwann nochmal, aber eigentlich will ich das halt eigentlich gar nicht. So, aber dann kann man halt diesen Language-Switcher nehmen und da kann man halt nicht nur temporär ein Programm in einer anderen Sprache starten, sondern du kannst eben auch für ein Programm einstellen, dass du es immer in dieser anderen Sprache starten willst. Das heißt, mein Pages kommt jetzt immer deutsch hoch.
Bäh.
Damit man da ordentlich Deutsch-Texte schreibt.
Aber ich kann das ja nicht haben, ne? Diese deutschen Übersetzungen. Also bei Mac OS ist es ja noch vergleichsweise okay, finde ich, aber eigentlich auch ganz schön schlecht. Also, ich kann das nicht. Ich kann das nicht haben, wenn die dann so mit ihren komischen Übersetzungen kommen. Ich hab jetzt kein Beispiel, weil ich alles in Englisch fahre und auch aus Überzeugung, aber...
Du willst das nicht.
Ich will das nicht, nee. Das Problem ist dann nämlich auch, dann setzt man sich an so einen Rechner, der auf Deutsch eingestellt ist, und dann findet man auch auf einmal gar nichts mehr.
Ja, weil dein Rechner nicht in Deutsch ist.
Ist wahrscheinlich am Ende auch gewöhnungsvoll.
Aber wie heißt denn das Tool? Nochmal.
Language Switcher heißt das. Ganz einfach.
Ich glaube, im Terminal konnte man es über das Open Command einstellen. Irgendwo habe ich schon mal gelesen, weil beim Software-Test, wenn du eigene Software schreibst, dann willst du die ja auch mal so testen und so testen. Und du willst ja nicht immer dein Gesamtsystem umstellen. Und da gab es irgendwie einen Trick, wie man es auch mal irgendwie so kurzfristig in aller Sprache davon kommt.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass das so eine legale Locale-Setting ist, was im OS aktiviert wird und was vielleicht auch noch im Open Command-Line zur Verfügung steht.
Also da gibt es ja so spontan jedenfalls keine Option dafür, und die hinterher HIP steht.
Beim Open Command?
Ich werde langsam müde, Leute.
Ja, dann mal schnell weiter zum nächsten Tool. Minecraft.
Ja, Minecraft.
Was geht ab?
Was geht ab mit diesem Minecraft? Ich saß letztens im Club und da saß der Andreas rum.
Ist das überhaupt Apple-relevant?
Doch, es läuft auf Mac. Na ja, es ist halt ein Spiel in Java geschrieben. Aber es läuft auf Mac. Fand ich schon ganz gut. Das ist jetzt nur so gerade so ein Spiel, was gerade durch die Gegend hyped. Also es gibt es schon eine ganze Weile, aber irgendwie sind gerade sehr viele Nerds auch da drauf hingeblieben und es geistern im Twitter immer mehr Minecraft-Witze umher. Heute hat Joel einen Ort getweetet zu diesen chilenischen Bergrettern, die jetzt gerettet wurden und so viel verpasst worden haben und jetzt muss ich ihnen erstmal Minecraft zeigen. Kann man nur verstehen, wenn man dieses Spiel zumindest mal gesehen hat. Aber...
War noch nicht so langweilig gewesen da unten.
Worum geht's denn?
Naja, das ist halt so, das Genre heißt Sandbox-Game. Kennst du Dwarf Fortress? Das ist so ein ASCII-basiertes Spiel. Und das geht halt darum, du baust dir da halt so deinen Fortress aus. Und baust Fallen für Zombies oder Monster. Und kannst halt Dinge kombinieren. Also so... Sachen bauen. Also in Minecraft ist es halt so, du fängst halt so an und hackst dann in so einem Berg rum und sammelst irgendwie Holz ein und so weiter. Und dann kannst du aus dem Holz Bretter machen, aus den Brettern kannst du Stöcker machen, dann kannst du aus Stöckern und Steinen dir eine Scheinschaufel machen. Mit der Steinschaufel oder mit der Steinhacke kannst du dir neue Rohschlaufe abbauen, kannst damit neue Sachen craften, dann kannst du dir eine Werkbank bauen. Auf der Werkbank kannst du wieder tollere Sachen bauen und dann geht es halt so weit, dass du auch elektrische Leitungen hast. Und dann hat einer tatsächlich auch ein 16-Bit-Alu-Adira in Minecraft mit Kupferleitungen, mit allem, so Pipapo gibt es auf YouTube, ein riesen Areal bebaut und hat einen fetten Datenbus und dann so kleine Holzschildchen aufgestellt. Und wenn du hier die Fackel hinstellst, dann ist das Addition und wenn du hier die Fackel hinstellst, ist das verodert. Ja, hat einen Computer geworden. Der hat auch ein Buch geschrieben, für Studenten, wie man so simple Schaltkreise normal baut. Und der hat wohl als Anschauungsobjekt das in Minecraft nachgehakt. Und dann gibt es halt so einen Typen, hab ich heute gesehen, der baut die Hände...
Das ist eine riesige Gegend in dem Spiel. Du biegst gar nicht durch, wenn du mit deiner Figur an einem Schalter stehst. Also es ist so, als wenn ganz Kreuzberg irgendwie eine Alu wäre. Du kannst gar nicht so weit gucken, wie dieses Ding reicht.
Und jetzt hab ich heute gesehen, ein Video, da baut einer die Enterprise, das Raumschiff Enterprise in 1 zu 1 Scale in diesem Minecraft nach. Aus so einem Mal einen Meter Blöcken, aus Stein und was auch immer baut, der sich da in so einem riesigen Dock, was er sich da hingezimmert hat. Das muss Wochen, Monate dauern, ja. Er meint ja, er hat es in einer Nacht gehackt, das glaube ich auch nicht. Und er läuft dann so, und das ist ja alles so einigermaßen in richtiger Proportion. Und dann siehst du halt dieses Raumschiff vor dir, und es ist einfach episch groß. Und er hat das so mit einmal einen Meter Blöcken gebaut. Es triggert so einen ganz speziellen Spieltrieb. Und das Witzige eigentlich noch daran ist, jetzt denkst du dir, ok, Alu-Adira, ok, Rohstoffe hacken, ok, du kannst irgendwie Dinge bauen. Dann gibt es noch Tag-Nacht-Zyklus, 10 Minuten Tag, 10 Minuten Nacht. Und jetzt ist noch die zusätzliche Schwierigkeit, nachts gibt es halt Zombies und Spinnen und so. Und die greifen dich dann halt so an. Das heißt, nachts musst du halt irgendwie dich verstecken.
Und ich hab gehört, wenn du da zwei Zombies hast, die können nur mit einem Pfeil schießen oder so was, ne?
Ne, es gibt welche, die schießen mit Pfeilen.
Genau, wenn du schaffst, dass der eine Zombie, wenn der auf dich schießt, aber außersehen dadurch einen anderen Zombie trifft, und wenn er das viermal macht, also wenn sozusagen ein Zombie den anderen abschießt, obwohl er eigentlich dich treffen wollte, wenn er den viermal trifft, dann fällt da eine Schallplatte und dann kannst du dir einen Musikautomaten bauen.
Du kannst ja eine Jukebox craften auch aus einem Diamanten und irgendwie neun Steinblöcken oder Holzblöcken, keine Ahnung, und dann gibt's da Schallplatten, und du kannst ja auch Schallplatten generieren, die du dann in deine Truhe steckst und so.
Ich hab gehört, es gibt nur zwei Schallplatten.
Ne, du kannst aber mit so einem Tool, die auch aus MP3s Schallplatten machen, die du dann da spielen kannst. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es halt so ein echt interessantes Spiel, und es ist halt ein Indie-Developer, also auch Indie-Game-Szene, das heißt, es hat so einen Typ alleine gehackt. Und das ist in der Alpha-Phase, und der macht halt kontinuierlich Updates, und in der Alpha-Phase kostet es halt 10 Euro. Du kannst eine Gratis-Variante spielen, wo du halt nur bauen kannst, und nicht craften und nicht kombinieren, sondern...
Was genau kostet 10 Euro? Wir reden ja nicht von so einer Multi-User-Welt, wo jetzt alle in derselben Welt sind, sondern jeder...
Du hast auch einen Multiplayer-Mode. Also du kannst auch zu mehreren in New York dir aufbauen, wenn du Bock hast auf einem Server.
Aber es gibt noch nicht so World of Minecraft.
Nee, aber es wird wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen. Also es gibt halt dann in der nächsten Version, soll es halt auch möglich sein, dass ich, wenn ich in meiner Welt alleine bin, kann ich dir halt irgendwie sagen, invite, hier komm mal in meine Welt, bauen wir mal zusammen irgendwie die Enterprise fertig. Auf jeden Fall, was wollte ich sagen, genau, und für 10 Euro kriegst du halt die Version der latest in greatest development Stand, also der letzte Stand, den er da so released hat, mit allen Features und so weiter. Und die gratis Variante ist halt ein älterer Stand, wo man auch nur bauen, also nur alle Klötze zwar hat, aber nichts kombinieren kann. Also du kannst da keine Jukebox bauen, sondern du kannst halt nur aus den Brecken, die es gibt, eine Enterprise bauen. Aber Schalter und so ein Kram gibt es halt nicht. Und Zombies auch nicht und so. Das heißt, in der 10 Euro Version kriegst du halt die ganzen coolen Features. Kannst auch kleine, gibt's auch so Leute, die haben sich...
10 Euro bist du sicher? Ich hatte was von 5 gehört.
Nee, jetzt ist es bei 10 und wenn die voll wird, also wenn es final release ist, soll es 20 kosten. Aber der hat jetzt schon mit dem Stand, wie es jetzt ist, für 10 Euro, hat er 2 Millionen Euro schon eingenommen. Also es boomt auch gerade richtig.
Das hab ich auch gehört. Der Typ ist einfach scheiße reich auf einmal, weil er irgendwie mit dem Programm voll den Nerv getroffen hat.
Und hier auch die Leute gehen halt voll ab. Also es gibt halt natürlich die Mindpedia, wo alle Recipes zum Craften drinstehen und so weiter. Und die meinten halt irgendwie, letzten Monat hatten wir 4 Millionen Views per... also 4 Millionen Views im Monat. Und dieses Jahr geht's so auf 60 Millionen. Also gerade hyped das Ding.
Wenn er sich jetzt mal noch eine schicke Engine einkaufen würde, damit es auch gut aussieht, weil hast du ja mal die Grafik angeschaut, wie das aussieht.
Das ist ja absichtlich so. Also es hat halt so diesen Charme von alten...
Vom 64er.
Ja, reicht ja offensichtlich.
Naja, das an dieser Stelle mal erwähnt, damit auch der Hype jetzt die Werte Mobile-Macs-Hörer erreichen kann. Und während sie dann Minecraft spielen, können sie dann schön alle Podcasts...
Dann hört uns ja keiner mehr zu jetzt hier.
Doch, wir machen eine Minecraft-Schallplatte, die sie dann in ihrer Tube-Pod... Hey, neues Publishing-Format hier für Mobile-Macs gibt es jetzt auch als Minecraft-Schallplatte.
Okay, super. Super Ding. Ja, ich hatte ja hier letztes Mal... Ich hatte ja letztes Mal diese Geschichte erzählt von dem Blinden, der sich ein iPhone gekauft hat und auch ein Mac gekauft hat. Und hatte ja mal gefragt, ob es denn nicht irgendwie Leute gibt, die da irgendwie was mitmachen. Und ich hatte schon vor längerer Zeit mal geguckt und da gab es irgendwie wenig. Aber dann hat sich tatsächlich jemand bei mir gemeldet, der macht einen ganz eifrigen Podcast über iPhone für Blinde. Und da habe ich auch mal wieder gelernt, was, da habe ich wieder einiges gelernt über Aufwand treiben und so weiter. Jetzt suche ich gerade hier wie ein Bekloppter gerade die URL, da ist sie auch schon. Und zwar, das Ganze ist auf einer Webseite, die heißt blindzellen.de.
Und, wo haben wir das jetzt hier?
Safari, piss die Wand an! So, HTTP.
Gott sei Dank sind hier alle Wände abwischbar.
Heute ist es aber auch wirklich hier mit dem Internet, das ist aber auch wirklich so eine Sache, ne?
Ja, 2010.
Hier funktioniert gerade wieder gar nichts.
Ein Mobile-Max-Minecraft-Server wäre toll. Hier meint gerade auch einer, ich bin auch gerade am Inselbauen während des Hörens, also. Es gibt auch bei den Mobile-Max-Hörern Minecrafter.
Okay, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall hier blindzellen.de, man merkt schon den doppelten Witz. Da geht es halt um Podcasts für Blinde. Teilweise wo es so um Internet geht und wo es auch ganz speziell um iPhone geht. Zum Beispiel der Commie, commie.podcast.blindzellen.de. Übrigens auch per Telefon abrufbar. Sehr sinnvoll. Und naja, ich habe mir da irgendwie mal ein paar Sendungen angehört und der beschreibt einfach ein Walkthrough mit VoiceOver mit dem iPhone. Also wie es sozusagen ist, bestimmte Programme zu benutzen und vor allem bestimmte Programme zu benutzen, die so scheiße programmiert sind, dass VoiceOver überhaupt keine Chance hat, irgendetwas auseinander zu halten. Weil einfach die Programmierer vergessen haben, diese Metadaten zu liefern. Also ich habe mir irgendwie die Folge angehört, wo er dieses Dragon Dictate, glaube ich heißt das, diese Diktat Software fürs iPhone, mit der man sehr anständig tatsächlich Spracherkennung machen kann. Ich habe es jetzt selber noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich habe das im Podcast ja live gehört. Wo er dann irgendwie durchmarschiert, der Chord. Und da kommt man aus dem Kopfschüttel und manchmal nicht mehr so richtig raus. Also VoiceOver liest einem sozusagen die Buttons vor und dann kann man das irgendwie auswählen. Und es hängt aber sozusagen davon ab, wie die Programmierer in den Metadaten diese Buttons auch benannt haben. In dieser Software heißen alle Buttons gleich. Und er macht sich einen riesen Aufwand, dann sozusagen genau mit welchen Tricks man jetzt doch noch die Buttons durch langsam von rechts nach links rüberstreichen und der wievielte Button dann welcher Button ist. Und den und den und den drücken, um dann sozusagen zu dem eigentlichen Ergebnis zu kommen. Und auch so dieser Konflikt, dass man nur das eingebaute Mikrofon benutzt für Diktat. Ja, sozusagen du aber gleichzeitig Voice-Over benutzt, wo dein Telefon spricht und dann sozusagen gleichzeitig wieder Audio innen erzeugt, etc. Und all diese Sachen werden da umschifft. Aber was mir auch nochmal bestätigt wurde, ist, dass wohl Voice-Over auf dem iPhone einfach ganz hervorragend funktioniert. Ich hatte überlegt, den hier noch kurz dafür zu machen, aber das hat hier einfach mit den Vorbereitungen nicht gepasst. Aber ich werde mich des Themas auf jeden Fall noch mal annehmen, weil da ist irgendwie doch eine ganze Menge zu holen. Aber ich hatte jetzt einfach ein bisschen zu wenig Zeit, mich darauf einzulassen. Aber wer iPhone-Software entwickelt, das ist wirklich das, was ich auch nur durch das Anhören von zwei Episoden gelernt habe. Wer iPhone-Software entwickelt, auch wenn es nicht speziell für Blinde ist, aber wenn es irgendwas ist, was für Blinde einfach in irgendeiner Form interessant sein könnte. Und das ist natürlich erstmal auch jede Software, wenn es jetzt nicht vielleicht gerade Bildbearbeitung ist oder sowas. Aber achtet darauf, dass eure Software mit VoiceOver gut zusammenläuft. Das ist irgendwie, glaube ich, kein großer Marsch. Man muss halt einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass die Metadaten, dass die Buttons richtig beschrieben sind und so weiter, dass ein Audio-Interface, dieses automatische Audio-Interface von dem iPhone, in der Lage ist, diese Programme richtig vorzulesen, wenn man das eben über VoiceOver benutzt. Und das ist verhältnismäßig eher ein Draufachten. Man muss es ja nicht wirklich explizit unterstützen, sondern man kriegt das ja quasi for free. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass man damit sozusagen einfach nochmal eine extra Kundschaft sich erschließt, die ansonsten einfach verloren gegangen wäre.
Genau, um euch geht es.
Ja, ich hab ja auch nochmal ein bisschen geguckt, weil wir wissen ja alle, dass Alex die einzige Stimme ist im Text-to-Speech-of-Mac, die Englisch einigermaßen sinnvoll beherrscht. Und natürlich jetzt so wir als deutscher Podcast, deutschsprachiger, da hab ich halt auch nochmal ein bisschen geguckt, auch zusammen mit dem Robert im Übrigen, was es denn also gibt. Und da gibt es halt tatsächlich auch deutsche Stimmen, aber die sind nur zu kaufen und die kosten auch richtig doll Asche. Und es gibt auch eine Webseite, wo man sich selber eine deutsche Stimme machen kann. Da musst du dann halt so bestimmte Text-Snippets einsprechen sozusagen. Der zeigt dir mal so ein Snippet an, dann musst du das einsprechen, noch ein Snippet einsprechen und so weiter. Und damit kannst du dir wohl auch selber eine Stimme machen für Text-to-Speech. Allerdings, ja. Hast du das mal ausprobiert? Ja, aber ich hab dann nur mal aufgehört. Also es dauerte natürlich eine ganze Weile. Und ich wollte ja die deutsche Stimme eigentlich mal haben, aber die war weder irgendwie jetzt mal so als Ausprobierversion zu bekommen noch war halt, also die hat halt hunderte oder sogar in die 1000 Euro gekostet, die deutsche Stimme da. Das war dann doch so ein bisschen, also war nicht so ein Price-Point wie 29 Euro oder so, was dann so richtig schon ordentlichen Batzen auf die Theke legen. Was ein bisschen schade ist. Also ich hätte ja gerne schon auch mal eine Stimme, die Deutsch kann. Und selbst wenn hier, wenn man seinen Mac ja auf Deutsch hochfährt, hat man ja da auch Pech. Also da muss es...
1000 Euro ist echt ein bisschen viel für die deutsche Stimme.
Also für Blinde müsste das ja dann auf dem Mac eigentlich, also für Deutsch-Sprache... Das waren halt hunderte oder sogar 1000, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Ich habe das mir leider nicht notiert, aber ich glaube in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung gab es einen entsprechenden Hinweis.
Es gibt aber hier auch den deutschen LX für 35 Euro angeblich. Also es ist auf jeden Fall... Eigentlich gehört es halt dazu, finde ich. Wenn du auf Deutsch stellst. Also wie machen die das bei VoiceOver für den deutschen Mac?
Also qualitativ akzeptabel bestimmt sind ab rund 100 Euro verfügbar, heißt es hier.
Okay, dann machen wir es günstiger.
Da hat er schon mal was drüber geschrieben und das hier in den Kommentaren hinterlassen. Genau, hier Zepstral, dort kommen...
100 Euro für eine Stimme.
Ja, 100 Euro finde ich jetzt aber zumutbar. Ich meine, das ist... Wenn die gut ist, ist das jetzt sozusagen... Du musst überlegen, wenn du ein Windows dir kaufst, da kostet alle an diese Screenreader-Software, die sozusagen so eine Add-on-Software ist, die versucht sich, um diese ganzen Windows-Programme herum breit zu machen und das irgendwie so zugänglich zu machen, wie irgendwie möglich. Also was an einer ganz anderen Position auch ansetzt, als jetzt Mac OS X, was das quasi aus dem OS heraus macht. Da zahlst du halt schon mal allein einen vierstelligen Betrag, nur um diese Software zu haben, die sozusagen beim Mac kostenlos dabei hast. Das zahlst du gerne nochmal 100 Euro für eine Stimme.
Aber weißt du, macht denn dieser blindzellen.de, also hast du den mal gefragt, ob er sich damit auch Mac beschäftigt oder war das jetzt alles nur iPhone?
Er ist mir Abteilung iPhone. Es gibt noch einen Marco C., der sich wohl sehr intensiv auch mit dem Mac unterhält, aber da hab ich noch keinen direkten Austausch gehabt.
Also das fände ich ja eigentlich auch nochmal interessant, dieses Thema.
Ich auch, aber da war jetzt einfach gerade mal nicht dran zu denken.
Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall deutsche Stimmen, scheinbar auch für günstiger, als ich gefunden hatte. Und es gibt eben diese Webseite, wenn ich sie nochmal finde, oder ansonsten müsst ihr mal selber gucken, wo man eben selber sich auch eine Stimme generieren kann. Aber ich vermute, dass die nicht so toll an ist, das Ergebnis davon. könnt ihr ja in den Kommentaren hinterlassen, falls ihr es gemacht habt. Und dann berichten wir da auch von.
Irgendwie, ich erinnere mich noch an irgendeine weibliche Stimme, die irgendwie erwähnt wurde, die wohl ganz toll sei. Ich hab was den Namen vergessen.
Was immer noch gut ist, ist dieses AT&T Text to Speech. Also da bin ich echt überrascht, wie gut die Deutsch können. Da gibt es auch immer diese Webseite schon seit eh und je von AT&T Research Labs, keine Ahnung, Text to Speech. Die sieht auch so aus wie aus den 90ern. Einfach nach AT&T und Text to Speech oder ATT Text to Speech suchen. Und die haben, glaube ich, zwei oder drei deutsche Stimmen. Genau. AT&T Labs Natural Voices Text to Speech Demo. Und da gibt es Clara und Rainer. Und jetzt lassen wir doch mal von Clara vorlesen. Mobile Max, das klingt bestimmt total toll, ist eine tolle Sendung. Klingt so wie eine Beamtin bei der Personalausweisausgabe. Da musst du halt anders schreiben.
Musst du halt Mobile mit äh, genau, warte. B-A-I-L und dann M-E-C-K-S.
Ja Moment, ich hab's gleich.
Mobile, so können wir den Podcastern nennen.
Mobile Max, okay, let's go.
Wir können noch kurz Rainer nehmen, aber könnt ihr selber ausprobieren. Aber bei AT&T Labs kann man sich zumindest so mal Text in Deutsch...
Rainer.
Rainer gibt's auch noch.
Oder Robert.
Robert kann auch gut, oder?
Komm, jetzt noch mal Rainer.
Mobile Max ist eine tolle Sendung. Ja, das klang aber ein bisschen reserviert. Man kann schon ein bisschen mehr Empathie und Euphorie zeigen jetzt um unsere Sendung.
Aber die sind auf jeden Fall schnell. Zippst den Text ein, geht direkt los. Und gibt's auch französisch und so ein Kram.
Die Frage ist, wie kommt das mit Komma, Satzpausen etc. zusammen.
Aber die Seite kenn ich echt schon ewig. Also die gibt's bestimmt schon zehn Jahre.
Ja, ich kann mich auch erinnern. Irgendwann war das mal der heiße Scheiß.
Damals, als wir noch unseren Mac mit Open My Browser versucht haben zu befehligen.
Computer, what time is it?
Zum 16C3 oder irgendwo 18C3 saßen wir da unten im Nock und dann irgendwie war langweilig und dann irgendwie haben wir versucht Schacht zu spielen und Open My Mail und der hat das alles nicht verstanden. Wahrscheinlich wegen unserem grandiosen Englisch-Azent auch. Ja, deutscher Akzent, wohlgemerkt ja. Beim Englisch sprechen.
Sauerkrauts.
Das war wieder erwartungsvolle Blick. Tim, gib doch mal das Thema vor.
Taktgeber. Achso, da wählen wir noch die URL für das AT&T hier, bitte schön.
Also du hast ja hier neulich mal diese HBCI-Situation auf Mac.
Banking, Software oder ja. Also HBCI können ja alle nicht, außer die Saldomat.
Na, es können auch noch andere irgendwie, angeblich HBCI und ich habe sie jetzt mal so ein bisschen durchgetestet. Da gibt es halt HBCI, gibt es bei BankX angeblich. Das ist auch noch so eine Software, die definitiv aus alten Zeiten stammt. So kommt es sehr macOSig rüber. Also da läuft ja schon so ein leichter, kalter Schau bei den Rücken, wenn du das irgendwie runterlädst. Und auch wenn du startest und das ist auch so diese ganze Menüführung, das ist so alt. Also wirklich überhaupt nicht durchdacht und überhaupt nicht mit Workflow. Und es hat dann einfach auch prompt nicht funktioniert. Und ich habe komischerweise mit meinem Sparkassen- account extrem schlechte Ergebnisse. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt an der Sparkasse liegt. Dieses iOutBank, was wir ja schon mehrfach erwähnt haben, auf dem iPhone, das funktioniert ja ganz wunderbar und stellt sich irgendwie auf alles ein. Aber auf dem Mac sieht es einfach mal echt mau aus. Und dann mit Saldomat ging's, aber dieses Saldomat, ich hatte mir das mal angeschaut, das ist ja, das ist doch keine Applikation. Das ist irgendwie so, das hängt da oben in dieser Menüleiste und das ist kein richtiges Programm. Und das, was es auch tut, ist nicht das, was ich brauche. Ich meine, alles, was ich brauche, ist eigentlich, hole regelmäßig den Kontoauszug in einem Maschinenles und lege es in einem maschinenlesbaren Format ab. Punkt.
Na ja, ok, du musst manuell halt klicken, aber das maschinenlesbare Format kriegst du ja raus.
Ich drücke auch gerne return, aber diese Zumutungen, diese Programme da auf einem...
Also User Interface ist Schrott.
Dann gibt es irgendwie so Pekunia, das ist irgendwie so eine Open Source Software, die erstmal nicht ganz so schlimm daherkommt. So, da merkt man, da ist schon so ein bisschen Goodwill, aber es halt irgendwie zahlt halt keiner für. Dementsprechend auch irgendwie alles nicht zu Ende programmiert. Habe ich auch keine Kommunikation mit meiner Bank herstellen können. Und alle brechen immer nur ab mit, ja, Fehler.
Aber mit Saldo Mart ging es.
Ja, aber Saldo Mart tut irgendwie nichts sinnvolles. Das hängt da oben in dieser Menüzeile, da kann ich nicht irgendwie mal in so ein Konto-File reinladen und habe da so ein Dokument, wo dann irgendwie mein Ding drin ist, sondern es zeigt mir immer irgendwie an, wie mein Saldo ist.
Ja, und die kriegst du ja dann auch, den Konto auszukriegst du ja auch relativ flott noch angezeigt.
Ja, aber ich habe da auch keine Möglichkeit. Also erstmal kann ich damit nicht arbeiten wie mit einem Programm und zweitens kann ich nicht einfach die Daten maschinenlesbar machen.
Ich will einfach nur Konto auszuholen. Aber CSV zum Beispiel tut er ja raus, was so maschinenlesbar wäre, wenn das dein einziger Anspruch ist. Und ich benutze das ja Ich hab mich was übersehen. Ich glaube, das geht schon.
Ich weiß nicht, dass es mir überhaupt nicht gefallen hat.
Ich fand das einfach überhaupt nicht schön. Ich benutze das eben auch nur, weil es das Einzige ist, was so mit meiner Bank quatschen konnte auf Anip. Und ich schiebe das ja auch in dieses Moneywell rein, was auch nicht perfekt ist.
Der Timo hat neulich in so ein bisschen so irgendwie erwähnt, ich hab das schon wieder vergessen, es gibt irgendwie so eine Unix-Open-Source- Command-Line-Variante, die wohl für ihn ganz gut funktioniert hat und die dann auch so genau dieses, ich erzeuge XML, wohl hinbekommen hat. Ich habe das noch nicht testen können, ich hab jetzt auch grad den Namen nicht parat, aber das ist halt auch... Eigentlich ist es wirklich super schade, ich verstehe das auch nicht, da müsste eigentlich wirklich ein Markt für da sein, aber die meisten Leute wollen natürlich wahrscheinlich gleich sehr viel mehr haben, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal... Ja, ich meine auch, hier bei diesem Money-Rail, das ist halt auch so ein Trauerspiel, das ist halt auch so ein Typ scheinbar alleine, so eigentlich total gute Ansätze und so, aber doch immer noch mit Bugs und dann alle schreien HBCI direkt in dieser App und er sagt irgendwie, ne, ja, vielleicht, keine Ahnung, was, und der könnte einfach mal, die Leute würden es ihm aus den Händen reißen, ja.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch wirklich der Schmerz im Arsch, dieses HBCI. Ich habe übrigens vorhin, als ich noch mal...
Aber da gibt es doch auch Open-Source-Libraries für, die müssen das ja nicht mal selber coden. Also ich meine, es gibt auch Gnu-Cache und so und Gnu-Cache kann das doch auch, oder nicht?
Kann es das?
Ich bilde mir ein.
Das kann sein, ich weiß nicht genau.
Also Harald macht auch hier mit Gnu-Cache und unserem Club und dem ganzen Foo und dem ganzen Bar. Also ich dachte, bei Gnu-Cache ginge das. Gnu-Cache muss RQ-Banking.
Da muss man erst mal wieder X-Windows installieren.
Ja, aber ich sag nur, irgendwie wird es da schon Libraries geben, also man muss halt das Rad nicht.
Es gibt sicherlich irgendwas, was irgendwie funktioniert, aber es ist halt, sagen wir mal, jetzt aus der Macintosh- Perspektive mit, ich hätte jetzt gerne einfach mal die Kontuauszug-Punkt ab, indem ich einfach nichts anderes mache als, gib mir den Kontuauszug.
Robert ist ja übrigens auch so, ist ja unser Apple-Developer da in der Firma, und der macht das bestimmt. Robert, mach doch mal so eine ab.
Robert, du bist die Zukunft.
Rette uns mit einer Kontuauszug-Punkt ab. Für Tim, er bezahlt dir auch wie viel? Robert, flattern müsstest du mindestens.
Dann kann ich ihn, das ist nicht so das Ding.
Das ist ja nicht das Ding, wie man es nennt.
Na ja gut, HBCI heißt auch nicht mehr HBCI, habe ich gelernt, sondern das heißt jetzt Fintes, Financial Transaction Service. Offensichtlich war in HBCI doch zu doof. Und da gibt es jetzt irgendwie auch schon eine Version 4.0 und jetzt machen sie auch irgendwie XML. Sagt Wikipedia. Na ja, ich bin gespannt. Ich bin zu müde, ich kann nicht mehr.
Wie jetzt schlapp machen?
Alle Themen durch?
Nein.
Das geht nicht. Los, was nächstes Thema?
Nächstes Thema?
Nächstes Thema.
Wieso muss immer ich das nächste Thema sagen?
Weil du den dicksten Mac hier hast mit den meisten Themen auf dem Bildschirm.
Dein MacBook Pro irgendwie. Wieso hast du eigentlich einen 15 Zoll Rechner?
Das ist ein 17 Zoll. Aber das ist von Pavel, das Zerranste. Ach so. Aber meiner ist morgen wieder aus der Reparatur zurück. Ja, da kann ich dir ein nächstes Mal von berichten. Wird bestimmt spannend.
Benutzt ihr iStart-Menus auf dem Mac?
Nee, ich benutze das nicht.
Also ich habe das jetzt flächendeckend hier zum Einsatz gebracht, weil das ist wirklich... das hat sich echt super entwickelt. Ich meine, es gibt ja immer mal wieder so Tools, die so ihre Zeit haben und dann so vor sich hingammeln. Gerade bei diesen ganzen System-Monitoring-Tools, aber bei diesen iStats-Menus, da tut sich richtig was.
Die sind drangeblieben auf jeden Fall seit Jahren.
Genau, extrem hilfreich. Jetzt im letzten Update haben sie vor allem dieses Problem des Klatters, dass man einfach immer dann... Du willst alles mögliche monitoren und dann hast du noch mal, noch mal, noch einen und irgendwas, dann gehst du zur Menüzeite vor. Jetzt hast du so Combined-Controlls, das heißt, du kannst halt explizit Sachen, die du zwar auf den Klick haben willst, aber nicht unbedingt immer alle gleichzeitig direkt sichtbar haben willst, kannst du zusammenfassen in einem Menü, sodass das sozusagen sehr kompakt hast. Und sie haben auch schon vor einiger Zeit das, was ich sehr praktisch finde. Du kannst sozusagen über den Status auch immer gleich auf die richtigen Frequenzen gehen. Du kannst sozusagen Frequenzen, Präferenzen gehen, auf die richtigen Settings gehen. Also, was weiß ich, du klickst irgendwie auf Netzwerk und dann bist halt auch gleich in Netzwerksettings. Einfach so einfache Sachen, die man eigentlich immer als gegeben angesehen hat. Kostet halt mir mal wieder ein paar Mark, aber ich finde das Tool ist einfach super.
Ich gab es da früher so als Dashboard-Dings nur, so ein riesengroß und bunt.
Ja, es gab schon immer Menu-Mieters zum Beispiel. Von so was rede ich aber jetzt.
Ja, bei iStat war ja früher so ein Dashboard-Dings.
iStat ja, aber nicht iStat Menus. Also iStat, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht, ob das noch mal anders hieß oder so. Ich hab das jetzt nur als iStat Menus im Kopf, seitdem ich das so kenne und benutze. Und das sieht einfach schick aus, das funktioniert gut. Und das hat einfach so wirklich für alle wichtigen Sachen, hat das halt extrem schön konfigurierbare Sachen. Also du hast halt CPU, Memory, Disk Usage, Disactivity, Network, eben sehr ausufernden Sensorsupport. Das heißt, du kannst alle möglichen Sensoren, die in deinem Rechner drin sind, auch anschauen. Du hast so Fan-Speed-Control mit drin, dieser ganze Climb-In. Was man eben so manchmal haben will. Du kannst sehr flexibel Date und Time anzeigen. Du hast da gleich so einen Kalender-Browser drin, was auch extrem praktisch ist. Wenn du so oben aufs Datum drauf gehst, kannst du gleich wie in iCal quasi durch dein Kalender durchblättern. Also wenn du mal eben Datum nachschlagen willst, musst du nicht irgendwie ein blödes Programm starten, sondern du bist da gleich mit drin. Und du hast auch gleich deine International Time, was weiß ich Keynote ist. Du willst irgendwie wissen, wie spitz in San Francisco. Klickst du drauf, hast halt auch einfach gleich auf einen Klick deine World Clocks mit drin. Also alles einzeln für sich betrachtet, alles nicht aufregend, aber das Paket macht es und es ist irgendwie...
Kostet wie viel?
Ist irgendwie gut. Und jetzt eben auch noch mit diesen Combine-Teilen sehr gut.
Sachen fragen. Ah, da, klick.
django.com. Oh, die haben auch iPad-Apps und iPhone-Apps, guck an. 16 Dollar.
Ist das allemal wert?
Also das ist so wie launchbar, muss ich sagen. Vermisse ich das mittlerweile genauso. Wenn es nicht da ist, dann fühlt sich der Computer irgendwie nackt und unvollständig an.
Ich sitze das aus. Ich versuche ja auch so diese Tools, die...
Auch CPU-Belastung und Speicherfolien.
Genau, CPU-Belastung, wie hoch ist die?
Wie jetzt gerade?
Die ganzen Stat-Tools hauen noch immer mir. Also die verbrauchen wir am meisten.
Achso, ja, nee, das nicht. Aber ich muss sagen, da gerade also bei der CPU, er hat auch noch so eine Anzeige der Top 5 Prozesse und er zeigt mir andere Prozesse an, die CPU verbrauchen, als es mein Activity-Monitor tut. Also da ist noch irgendwo ein Bug.
Und vor allen Dingen rechnet er sich bestimmt selber auch gerne raus aus der Richtung. Nee, aber, also ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich will halt so Tools, die permanent irgendwo monitoren und reingucken und irgendwie was updaten. Trau ich ja einfach nicht. Einfach so ein Grundgefühl. Die hängen sich da irgendwo rein, wo sie gar nicht hingehören und pollen auf irgendwas, was irgendwie, wo jemand anders viel besser pollen sollte. Keine Ahnung.
Aber Glaube.
Das einzige, was ich hier habe, ist SMC Fan Control. Der zeigt mir im Menü immer an, wie schnell meine Lüfter drehen. Das ist mir wichtig, weil dann kann ich mal sehen, wenn es heiß wird und so weiter.
Das macht er auch.
Wenn es heiß wird draußen.
Naja, ihr müsst das ja nicht kaufen. Ich sag nur, ich find's toll.
Das sieht auch immer sehr schick aus.
Das sind so Sachen, die müsste man mal erwähnen. Außerdem ist mir auch eingefallen, haben wir eigentlich schon mal die McHackers-Mailing-Liste erwähnt.
Gibt's die noch?
Ja, die gibt's noch.
Ich weiß, die gibt's noch. Aber ich lese die eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich schau auch nur ab und zu mal wieder rein, aber ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, dass das einfach...
Echt?
Na, die läuft doch über den UDKs, aber immer noch...
Was, die McHackers-Liste?
Hat wohl jemand mal da eingerichtet, war?
Sicher?
Hat die nicht Mac irgendwann mal eingerichtet?
Ich hab die eingerichtet.
Du hast die eingerichtet. Okay, dann läuft sie doch nicht über den Uniserver, oder?
Nein, die läuft auf ListCCCDE.
Warte mal, Moment. Jetzt gucken wir mal. Das Wiki läuft auf dem Uniserver, genau.
Ja, aber das Wiki, das war Fail. Das ist Quatsch, das kann man auch mal löschen. Das hat nie geklappt. Aber die McHackers-Mailing-Liste ist eigentlich die älteste deutsche Macintosh-Tech-Liste. Ich kann jetzt für die aktuelle Situation nicht so sprechen, aber was ich immer großartig fand auf der Mailing-Liste, die war einfach nahezu flamethrie. Einmal einen, den hab ich auch gleich rausgeschmissen, weil das finde ich auch sehr anständig, oder sagen wir mal notwendig, dass auf Mailing-Listen einfach eine gewisse Gesprächskultur zu herrschen und Leute, die da einfach den Ton nicht treffen, die haben da einfach nichts zu suchen, Punkt.
Sonst können sie gleich ins Use-Net gehen.
Ja, genau, dann ist diese Mailing-Liste auch tot. Das ist also wirklich ein beeindruckendes Element, dass da einfach ein extrem guter Ton herrscht.
Ich lese die ja, weil ich halt, also genau deswegen bin ich da drauf subscribed, weil ich denen irgendwann mal sagen wollte, als ich die Candela neu gemacht habe, ob ich das Wiki dann nochmal anschalten soll, dann ja, das Wiki, Wiki neu machen, Wiki toll, Wiki wiederbeleben, latest changes. Also du siehst halt, ja.
Ja, nein, das war Fehler. Ich meine, das war auch so die Zeit, wo das Apfel-Wiki auch gestartet ist und die hatten da sehr viel mehr Energie und das hat ja auch super funktioniert.
Aber dadurch kann ich halt sagen, dass die da auf jeden Fall aktiv sind und eigentlich, wenn immer, wenn ich mal so einen Thread kurz reinlese, das da geht es sehr zivil zu und...
Und wer das jetzt hört und wer sozusagen an einer guten Macintosh, wir reden über Technik, irgendwie auf einen ordentlichen Levellist interessiert, soll sich da subscriben. Und wer irgendwie ein alter Flamer ist oder so ein Wheres-Kiddy oder wer irgendwie den Ton nicht trifft, der soll gleich draußen bleiben. Genau.
Andererseits muss ich halt sagen, zum Beispiel mir persönlich, gibt die halt jetzt nicht mehr so viel...
Weil du schon alles weißt.
Na nicht das, aber...
Ausdauer muss sein, Mailing-Listen sind manchmal einfach das Richtige um bestimmte Sachen. Aber da werden halt auch immer wieder so difficile Probleme besprochen. Und es ist vor allem einfach eine deutsche Ressource und davon gibt es halt einfach nicht so viel.
Ja ne, stimmt. Da gibt es schon so Themen, wie kann ich jetzt irgendwie mein iPhone aus dem Jahrgang XY mit der Revision irgendwie nochmal zurücksetzen, wenn ich auf dem X-Surf mit L-Dub on?
Da werden sie geholfen. Deine V-Mode, da ist die Batterie oben ist auch schon alle.
Was uns zu diesem wahnsinnigen Thema bringt, auf das ihr alle schon gewartet habt. Nein, nein.
Falschen Button erwischt.
Jetzt geht's um Batterien.
Ach so.
Apple hat doch die Batterie neu erfunden. Jetzt neuer Strom, iBattery.
Aber das hatten wir schon mal, das Gerät und so.
Ja, das hast du schon mal, da hast du mir nämlich davon erzählt, dass diese Apple-Batterien da, diese Apple-gebrandeten Batterien, die mit ihrem geilen neuen Apple-Ladeteil, was einen direkt ins 21. Jahrhundert befördert, wenn man das kauft, worauf ich nicht beschlossen habe, gleich 10 zu kaufen, was aber ich getan habe. So, da hast du diese ganze Geschichte mit In-Loop-Batterien und so weiter und dass die jetzt irgendwie ganz toll sind, erzählt.
Ja, habe ich.
Und dann habe ich mir In-Loop-Batterien gekauft.
Und Max hat doll gegehend.
Max hat doll gegehend, die Sau. Und?
Und jetzt machst du Ikea-Batterien rein.
Jetzt mache ich Ikea-Batterien rein, weil ich gerade alle In-Loop-Batterien hier schon verdinkt habe. Da sind doch zwei. Ja, die laden gerade neu. Und die anderen habe ich nicht jetzt gerade drüben. Aber ich muss eh meine alten...
Die sind doch grün.
Ich muss meine alte Alkaline, muss ich eh noch verbrauchen. Die müssen weg. Ja, da kommen wir nämlich zum interessanten Punkt. Weil ich habe mir dann nämlich auch kein Apple-Ladegerät gekauft.
Und das war schon gleich ein Fehler oder wie?
Naja, was heißt Fehler? Die laden.
Lädst du schon noch oder?
Sie laden, ja. Aber das ist eben, glaube ich, der Unterschied zwischen so einem Apple-Gerät und so einem Sanyoni im Haar Batterie-Charger. Das Ding ist wenigstens weiß, ja, aber das sind einfach immer diese kleinen Touches. Und das ist halt die Frage, ob man jetzt 15 Euro ausgibt für ein Gerät, was vier Batterien gleichzeitig laden kann oder 30 Euro, was nur zwei Batterien gleichzeitig laden kann. Das ist von Apple. Das heißt, es kostet das Doppelte, kann nur halb so viele Batterien laden und ich vermute auch...
Du meinst Apple ist gar nicht so gut?
Moment, ich vermute auch, dass Apple keine Option hat, wie dieses Gerät, was für mich nämlich jetzt kaufentscheidend war, dass ich hier auch die AAA-Akkus von Eneloop laden kann, weil ich nämlich auch ein Gerät habe, in dem ich...
Aber du hast in unserer vorletzten Sendung dann nicht richtig zugehört, weil wir haben dann nämlich von einem Ladegerät erzählt, was sich abkürzt mit dem Namen BC700.
Da wurde es auch gerade im Chat schon wieder aufgerufen.
Genau. Und das ist mit Display. Du kannst da refreshen, dischargen, laden und entladen.
Ja, das war für mich windlos. Das wollte ich nicht haben.
Das ist kein Wind los.
Doch, mit Display und so weiter ein Ladegerät.
Ich bitte dich. Aber Discharge, also dass man die erst mal sauber leer macht und die dann sauber voll zu machen und einen Testmodus und vor allem einen Refresh, der kaputte Batterien so ein paar Mal hin und her lädt, bis sie wieder okay sind und dir auch anzeigt, welchen Stand die gerade haben. Also der kann ja gar nichts außer, dass er sagt, er ist jetzt voll und er kriegt da nichts mehr rein. Dieses andere Gerät sagte, ich habe es jetzt geladen, aber da ging nur 1000 Ampere, also milli Ampere rein und mehr geht irgendwie nicht. Das wirst du bei diesem Ding ja gar nie mitkriegen, wenn deine Batterie im Arsch ist.
Dein Ladegerät ist lame.
Genau. Das ist aber billiger als das von Apple.
Und es passt noch mal Batterien rein.
Aber da immer noch keine Features.
Kann ich damit auch Triple R laden? Sonst muss man doch noch einen BC 700 kaufen.
Der sieht auch gut aus.
So, aber jetzt mal, wenn man jetzt mal nur...
Der BC 700 ist sozusagen...
Okay, lassen wir mal kurz...
Der alles könner in billig.
Okay, lassen wir mal den BC 700 gerade mal raus. Jetzt mal nur dieses Gerät vergleichen mit dem von Apple. Steckt hier in dieser Steckdose. Und dadurch, dass hier vier Batterien reingehen, ist es natürlich so breit, dass es links und rechts die Steckdose natürlich auch noch weitgehend überlappt. Das heißt... Ja, wenn du den Stecker vorher reinsteckst, dann passt es vielleicht gerade noch, aber danach reinstecken geht halt irgendwie nicht. Das ist halt so das typische Problem. Super, wenn du so eine Wand... Wenn du eine Stegdose hast, wo jetzt wirklich nur so ein einziger Stegdose ist, aber in allen anderen Fällen, wo du eine Stegdosenleiste hast und den normalen Abstand hast, dann ist es halt irgendwie blöd. Und dann ist das mit dieser grünen Lampe, du steckst es halt rein und dann geht eine grüne Lampe an.
Oh, voll!
Die geht aus, wenn es geladen ist. Genau. Ich hab das Apple-Gerät jetzt noch nicht in Action gesehen, aber von der Beschreibung her meine ich, dass wenn es lädt, ist es gelb, wenn es geladen ist, ist es grün und das hält dann irgendwie zwölf Stunden an oder sechs oder irgendwie sowas und dann geht es dann aus, weil es sich komplett abschaltet.
Genau, aber der Trick bei dem Apple, das Ding kostet das ja auch so viel, weil es nur ein Zehntel des Stromes verbraucht wie dein Gerät, wenn es nicht am Laden ist. Das heißt, wenn der da jetzt fertig ist und du lässt den da ewig drin, was die meisten ja machen, dann haut der irgendwie 0,1 Watt weg oder ein halbes Watt und das von Apple nur 0,05 oder so.
Aber das Ding so breit ist, nehme ich es immer wieder raus.
Das von Apple, das verbraucht so viel weniger Strom, dass man irgendwie einen Euro im Jahr spart. Weil es ist nämlich sowieso schon so wenig bei so Netzzellen, die sagen zwar, es verbraucht nur ein Zehntel, aber es ist Netzzelleverbrauchung wirklich.
Ja, aber wenn du sagen wir mal 1.000 von den Dingern hast, ja, dann ist es schon 1.000 Euro mehr.
Ja, aber dann hast du 1.000 mal 15 Euro mehr bezahlt als für das da. Das heißt, du musst das Apple Netzer auch, das rentiert sich erst so nach 5, 6 Jahren.
Aber die Umwelt.
Das BC 700 kostet 24,20 hier.
Beim BC 700 kann man gleich dazu sagen für unsere Lovely Hörers, oder wie nennt man das?
Lovely Hörers.
Da gibt es verschiedene Angebote. Also ich habe es glaube ich für 18 Euro oder so gekauft und da waren vier Batterien dabei.
Krass.
Also man muss da so ein bisschen gucken, weil das wird oft auch rebrandet, also es gibt es in allen möglichen Formen, aber es ist immer das gleiche Gerät und da muss man ein bisschen gucken. Also ich habe es auch schon für 30 Euro gesehen, aber es gibt es definitiv so um die 20 auch. Meistens immer mit Batterien, damit sie überhaupt noch verdienen, damit sie den Preis ein bisschen hochhalten können. Aber ich habe es jetzt seit einem halben Jahr oder noch ein bisschen länger und das ist wirklich cool.
Das ist schon vor den i-Batterien.
So und jetzt noch ein kurzer Nachtrag zu den Batterien. Diese Enoloops gibt es ja schon seit ein paar Jahren. Jetzt wohl seit diesem Sommer, seit Juli oder so, gibt es noch mal welche, die noch mal ein Stück besser sind. Die haben zwar nicht mehr Power, aber die haben eine noch geringere Selbstentladung und deren Temperaturrange ist noch ein bisschen größer geworden. Das ist das eine. Aber die kriegt man jetzt ja wahrscheinlich sowieso, weil die alten gibt es dann nicht mehr. Erkennen kann man die neuen Batterien daran, dass da so ein Kronen-Symbol auf der Batterie drauf ist. So ein kleiner Dreizack.
So wie König.
Genau. Und dann hat Sanyo noch angekündigt, dass im Dezember wohl kommt eine neue Batterie, weil die von Apple und von dieser InnoLoop, sie haben ja so 2000 mAh. Da kommt eine, die hat 2500 mAh, heißt XX. Und die hat nicht ganz so eine super Selbstentladung wie jetzt die normalen InnoLoops, aber immer noch locker. Also wenn man die nicht drei Jahre lang frisch braucht, dann tut das locker. Die sind mehr so im Bereich von einem Jahr. Und haben halt mehr Saft. Fast so viel schon wie die normalen, mit der normalen Selbstentladung. Und das ist sozusagen das, was man haben will, wenn man ein bisschen mehr Power braucht. Und jetzt fällt mir gerade noch ein kurzes Thema ein, schieb ich noch nach. Und zwar gibt es von Sanyo auch so kleine Ladebooster fürs iPhone. Oder überhaupt für alle Geräte, die USB brauchen. Ich hab jetzt leider den Namen vergessen. Du könntest ja als mein Assistent mal kurz googeln. Sanyo Mobile Booster iPhone oder irgendwie so. Das ist, man kann die per USB aufladen, indem sie da so ein USB eingekamen. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie einen USB-Ausgang und da kommt der Strom raus mit 500 mAh. Und da ist so eine Lithium-Batterie drin, so ein 3,7 Volt-Dings. Aber ist egal, der Lith zählt mit 5 Volt über USB und auf der anderen Seite kommt auch wieder per USB-Strom raus. Und mit dem kleinen Ding kannst du so ein iPhone irgendwie einmal laden und dann nochmal ein halbes Mal. Und den gibt es aber auch ein Doppel so groß, mit zwei Lithium-Zellen drin. Und dann kannst du da so ein iPhone locker dreimal mit laden, würde ich so behaupten. Oder zwei, dreimal, sagen wir mal.
Also ist hier scheinbar so eine kleine weiße Kiste mit zwei USB-Parts, wo Sprung auskommt.
Zeig mal her, ob die richtig ist. Genau. Und die heißt, wo ist hier der Name? Kein Name. Den Namen müssen wir jetzt noch schnell haben. Weil ein Kumpel von mir hat es, der ist auch voll zufrieden. Ein anderer Kumpel hat sich das auch geholt, weil der wollte nie 3,7.
Das ist KBC-L3SE-Mobile-Booster-Akku.
Genau, die Dinger. Die sind wohl echt handlich, funktionieren super und brauchen keinen Netzteil, weil die werden mit USB geladen und kommt auch per USB der Strom wieder raus. Also alles wirklich ganz easy-peasy. Und das sind wirklich, haben keine Ecken, keine Kanten mehr.
Und das sind auch die ganz normalen, da macht man einfach die normalen AHA-Akkus rein.
Nein, da sind schon fertige Lithium-Ionen-Akkus drin, also welche mit ein bisschen mehr Bums, so mit 3,7 Volt.
Aber es gibt ja auch eine, wo die Batterien drin sind.
Ja, aber die haben nicht so viel Power. Und, das ist nämlich genau, kam mit diesem XX, mit dieser Meldung, was da im Dezember kommt, gibt es demnächst so eine Art Stift, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Kugelschreiber. Und da kommen zwei so eine Ede-Loops rein. Das ist so eine Aluröhre, die sieht designmäßig eigentlich ganz cool aus. Und die hat auch einen USB-Ausgang. Und damit kannst du auch dein iPhone laden. Da musst du dann halt aber die Ede-Loops irgendwie selber laden, glaube ich. Du könntest ja sozusagen immer so eine Metallröhre, so eine Aluröhre mit dir rumführen. Das ist eigentlich auch nicht so schlecht, wenn man zum Beispiel für seine, wie heißt die Maus jetzt? Magic? Magic? Wenn man für seine Magic-Maus immer Ersatzbatterien mit sich rumschleppt, dann kann man die gleich innerhalb von diese Aluröhre rumschleppen. Und entweder hast du USB-Power aus der Aluröhre oder falls die Maus leer ist, nimmst du die Batterien raus aus dem Ding und hast Ersatzbatterien dabei. Also eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Die sind ja all about batteries, die Jungs.
Ja, also die haben echt coolen Shit am Start.
5.000 mAh.
Das eine hier heißt KBC LS2. Tim wird alles auf der Mobile-Max-Seite verlinkt.
Genau, wird schön verlinkt hier mit Affiliate-Link und so und wir werden reich.
Ist das so?
Naja, das ist eher so pfennig Beträge auf Dauer. Also bisher hat es noch keine Überweisung gereicht. Ist auch eher immer so ein Testbetrieb, ob das überhaupt irgendwas bringt. Aber ich finde das irgendwie noch halbwegs fair, oder? Das geht doch, oder? Erfüllte Links nicht so schlimm. Aber was hat denn der hier für komische Ports? Sieht aber komisch zusammengequetscht aus, dieses Plastikgehäuse, ist alles so billig immer. Geht das nicht auch ordentlich?
So, ich finde leider nicht das mit den Alustangen, da fällt mir aber jetzt auch kein Name ein. Ach so, die bewegen sich so. Der Preis von diesen Ladedingern ist so zwischen, das Kleine kostet, glaube ich, so 20 Euro und das Große, wo wirklich was 5.000 mAh hat, kostet ja so 30, 35.
Genau.
Und hier, genau hier sind... Genau, das ist das Große.
Genau. Hier ist es schon ganz nett. Also ich bin mir hier noch nicht ganz so sicher. Ich habe das jetzt hier so großflächig umgerüstet und betreibe jetzt die ganzen Remotes und alles, wo ich irgendwie Batterien habe, sobald meine alten Alkaleins alle verbraucht sind.
Und so sieht dann dieses mit der Aluröhre aus, die kannst du auch nochmal suchen. Musste mal nach Sunny und Booster suchen nach der Sendung. Die kommt aber auch erst noch raus, die gibt es noch nicht. Aber ich fand die ganz cool.
Cooler Shit.
Warum beschäftigst du dich damit so viel?
Ich hab im Club gesehen einen Typ, der den Sunny Booster rein klein hatte und der war voll begeistert hier. Und die Maha hat auch so einen anderen Freund aus dem Club, der hat auch so ein Ding. Und die sind beide begeistert.
Wie geladen bekommt man da sein iPhone? Mit dem dicken?
Na, mit dem kleinen glaube ich so anderthalbmal. Und mit dem dicken halt, der hat genau doppelt so viel. Der hat halt zwei so Akkus drin, so ein Lithium-Dinger.
Also das zwei vollständige iPhone-Füllung in so einem kleinen Teil. Und kannst das selber jederzeit per USB laden, sozusagen?
Die laden jetzt nicht so wirklich schnell, weil es dauert halt eine Weile, weil aus USB kommt ja nicht so viele raus. Wahrscheinlich, wenn man hier so ein USB-Netzteil nimmt.
So ein iPad-Netzteil, das macht so irgendwie zwei Ampere.
Genau, weil man es nicht am Rechner lädt, sondern am USB-Netzteil, dann sind die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schneller voll. Wobei langsam laden ja immer besser ist für eine Batterie. Man soll ja gar nicht so schnell laden, das vertragen ja gar nicht so gut.
Und Es gibt ja bei dieser ganzen Laderei auch irgendwie einigen Voodoo, den Apple da betreibt. Also dieses Läd über USB. Da gab es doch, haben wir da hier drüber gesprochen? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht.
Da gab es mal einen Artikel, dass der eine, der diese Minty Box, oder wie die heißt, Minty Box, das ist auch so ein Arduino Projekt, der sich so ein USB Ladekästchen in so einer Bonbon Dose gebastelt hat. Ich glaube, der ist Minty Box, oder weil die Bonbons heißen Minty oder so. Ich muss dann nochmal kurz gucken. Und der hat rausgefunden, dass es da...
Dass man sozusagen diesem iPhone noch kommunizieren muss, was man überhaupt sozusagen zu liefern in der Lage ist. Und wenn das iPhone das nicht ausreichend rauskriegt, dass es unter Umständen nicht von allem Nutzen zieht, was da angeboten werden könnte, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Minty Boot heißt das Teil.
Genau, es ist aber nicht dokumentiert, wie das wirklich ist, zumindest nicht nicht Lizenznehmer, keine Ahnung, inwieweit Apple da überhaupt ein Programm für hat. Deswegen frage ich mich jetzt gerade, wie so ein Booster da sozusagen kommuniziert.
Aber da kann man bei Amazon, bei den Boostern gucken und da sind die Leute, die sagen, dass es geht.
Ich bezweifle nicht, dass da Strom rauskommt oder so.
Nee, dass es auch am iPhone funktioniert.
Ja, dass es geht, aber die Frage ist, ob es sozusagen auch maximal schnell lädt. Ob es sozusagen so schnell, wie es könnte, auch tatsächlich überträgt.
Ich glaube, die sind genau auf 500 mAh ausgehend.
Das ist ja wenig. Wobei es ist eh absurd. Also zum Beispiel hier an meinem MacBook Pro, die haben ja diese High-Power-USB-Ports. Das heißt, die sind da irgendwie in der Lage, da auch ein Watt rauszuschicken.
Das heißt ein Watt sowieso.
500 mW.
Der Strom kommt in milliampere, mal Volt und dann kommst du auf deine Watt.
Der Port kann aber, wenn du sozusagen nur ein Gerät dran steckst, dann schaltet er in so einen High-Power-Modus und liefert irgendwie das Doppelte. Also 1 Ampere. Und damit kannst du halt erstmal dein iPhone schneller laden und damit kannst du auch ein iPad laden. Und dann sagt das iPad auch, dass es lädt. Interessant ist nur, wenn ich mein iPad zum Beispiel an meine Airport Express ranstecke, als USB-Stromversorgung, dann steht da, lädt nicht. Lädt aber trotzdem.
Aber langsamer.
Aber langsam. Aber er lädt so langsam, dass er sich noch nicht mal traut, mir zu sagen, dass er lädt. Er sagt, er lädt nicht, aber das Ding bleibt dann immer noch brand.
An meinem Laptop hier so ein 4 Jahre altes MacBook Pro.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Genau, der lädt da so ein iPad nicht. Aber er lädt es auch wirklich nicht. Also ich hab beobachtet, es wurde nicht mehr. Also wahrscheinlich, weil das Display an war die ganze Zeit. Vielleicht, wenn das Display aus ist, dann lädt das auch. Aber solange es benutzt und es dran ist, dann wird es nicht mehr. Hab ich probiert. Ist bei 4% stehen geblieben für eine Stunde.
Naja, also es ist echt, wo der Strombedarf steigt und von daher sind die ganzen USB-Zulieferer durchaus gehalten, da mehr Wum zu liefern. Aber wie das halt mit dieser Kommunikation läuft, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass diese Booster, dass die alle so auf USB-Basis sind. Du kannst ja so einen Booster kaufen und du musst ja nicht unbedingt auch dein iPhone damit laden, sondern kannst das ja an alles Mögliche ranstecken heutzutage, weil...
Hast du noch was anderes außer ein iPhone, iPad?
Aber ich könnte. Und die EU hat ja gesagt, die Telefonhersteller sollen mal klarkommen, weil die sollen ab sofort irgendwie, eigentlich schon dieses Jahr, aber es wurde noch mal verschoben, sollen ja sich alle per USB laden lassen, damit es mal so einen einheitlichen Steckerstandard gibt und nicht jeder sein eigenes Netzteil macht. Da haben die sicher was eingelassen. Und dafür sind diese Booster ja dann auch genau richtig.
Was ich auch ganz schick fand, war ja dieser Aufsatz, dieses Enclosure fürs iPhone, was dir dann hier unten in den Port auch reingeht und dann so Induktionsladung ermöglicht, hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal. Also wie beim Palmen das macht. Genau. Da steckst du dir halt so ein Dings hier rein, das ist auch so enclosured dann so relativ dünn, hinten in der Akku zusätzlich und dann kannst du das so drahtlos laden. Ich weiß. Aber war halt irgendwie so, dass man es vielleicht gerade noch so auch dran lassen könnte.
Ja, viel interessante Informationen hier bei Mobile Max.
Mobile Max.
Jetzt haben wir irgendwie aber auch schon wieder unsere dreieinhalb Stunden hier voll, wa?
Ja, Quatsch. Nächste Thema.
Tatsache, wir haben um acht angefangen, oder? Ja, siehste.
Ihr könnt noch? Ich kann nicht mehr.
Sag mal die Themen, wir machen das schon. Du kannst ja auch mal zuhören.
Ich schlaf doch eine Runde auf dem Sofa jetzt hier. Ich hab hier nur noch...
Ich hab hier nur noch Glaskugelthema.
Keep it coming. Wir können auch Feierabend machen. Ich muss ja morgen auch früh aufstehen.
Ja, ich muss morgen noch mal live podcasten. Ich leg mich ins Bett, wach offen, was mach ich wieder?
Podcasten.
Obsession. Morgen dann wieder mit Holgi. Ja, lustig. Da ist die Themenliste noch länger. Ich glaube, das könnte eine lange Sendung werden. Mal gucken, wie lange er durchhält. Ja.
Und jetzt?
Freuen wir uns erstmal auf nächsten, wann ist das? Donnerstag oder wann?
Genau. Nee, 20. war?
Wir sind ja jetzt pünktlich. Genau, wir sind ja jetzt pünktlich. Da kann man ja fast schon die nächste Sendung ankündigen. Und ich hab auch Zeit an dem Tag. Das ist fantastisch. Das ist dann der 28. Oktober. Und dann gibt's dann Mobile Max wieder live. Schön abends. Ihr könnt euch schon mal drauf einstellen. Wir schaffen's in der Regel bis acht. Auch wenn wir immer sagen halb. Aber so ist das eben.
Ja, das Disko ist das Viertel.
Das Disko ist das Viertel in 30 Minuten.
Ja, und Jungs, hier nochmal Game Center, ne? Da geht's, also es reicht noch nicht. Ihr müsst noch mehr. Dennis2342, Hucke und BadBrit. Genau, der hat schon noch viele. Schnickschnack. Ich hab 324 erst, ich brauch noch ein paar.
324? Ja, ich hatte vorhin 344.
Ich hab jetzt 330.
Das geht nach Schönheit. Wahre Schönheit kommt von innen.
Gut, also nicht drum rumgequatscht, wir machen jetzt mal Ende hier, ne? Haben wir noch den Abschlusssong?
Was sollen wir da noch weiteres sagen?
So, die Fanboys verabschieden sich.
Abschlusssong haben wir nicht. Was hast du denn vorhin so schönes gesungen?
Genau, machen wir noch mal.
Wolltest du nicht...
Lalalalalala. Die Höhle ist auf der anderen Taste.